when theresa may stood down she
she uh got quite emotional she didn't
have a big crowd of people but boris
johnson likes to perform to a crowd so
this is slightly different to have such
a big band of mps and then his staff
there i haven't seen harry johnson his
wife it might be that
as
other partners have done in the past she
comes out and stands behind him uh let's
see i i imagine we will see it today but
we have to see they came back to number
10 last night
thank you okay well
well this is
this is it folks
thank you everybody for coming out
so early this morning
in only a couple of hours i will be in
balmoral to see her majesty the queen
and the torch will finally be passed to
a new conservative leader
the baton will be handed over in what
has unexpectedly turned out to be a
relay race they changed the rules
halfway through but never mind that now
and through that lacquered black door a
new prime minister will shortly go to
meet a fantastic group of public
servants the people who got brexit done
the people who deliver the fastest
vaccine rollout in europe and never
forget
seventy percent of the entire population
got a dose within six months faster than
any comparable country that is
government for you that's this
conservative government
people
who organized those prompt early
supplies of weapons to the heroic
ukrainian armed forces an action that
may very well have helped change the
course of the biggest european war for
80 years and because of the speed and
urgency of what you did everybody
involved in this government to get this
economy moving again from july last year
in spite of all the opposition
all the naysayers we have
and will continue
to have
that economic strength to give people
the cash they need to get through this
energy crisis that has been caused by
putin's vicious war
and i know
that liz
trusts and this compassionate
conservative government will do
everything we can to get people through
this crisis and this country will endure
it and we will win and if putin thinks
that he can succeed by blackmailing or
bullying the british people then he is
utterly deluded
and the reason we will have those funds
now and in the future is because we
conservatives understand the vital
symmetry between government action
and free market capitalist private
sector enterprise
we're delivering on those huge manifesto
commitments making streets safer
neighborhood crime down 38
in the last three years 13 790 more
police on the streets building more
hospitals and yes we will have 50 000
more nurses by the end of the decade and
40 more hospitals by the end of
50 000 by the end of this parliament i
should say 40 new hospitals by the end
of the decade putting record funding
into our schools and into teachers pay
giving everybody over 18 a lifetime
skills guarantee so they can keep up
skilling throughout their lives three
new high-speed rail lines three
including northern powerhouse rail
colossal road proud programs from the
pennines to cornwall the rollout of
gigabit broadband up over the last
three years i am proud to say since you
were kind enough to elect me from seven
percent of our country's premises having
gigabit broadband to 70
today and we are of course providing the
short and the long-term solutions for
our energy needs and not just using more
of our own domestic hydrocarbons but
going up by 2030 to 50 gigawatts of wind
power that is half of this country's
energy electricity needs from offshore
wind alone a new nuclear reactor every
year
and looking at what is happening in this
country the changes that are taking
place that is why private sector
investment is flooding in more private
sector more venture capital investment
than china itself more billion pound
tech companies sprouting here in the uk
but in france germany and israel
combined and as a result
unemployment as i leave office
unemployment down to lowe's not seen
since i was about 10 years old and
bouncing around on a space hopper my
friends and
on on the subject of
on the subject of bouncing around in
future careers
let me say that i am now like one of
those booster rockets
that has fulfilled its function and i
will now be gently re-entering the
atmosphere and splashing down
invisibly in some remote and obscure
corner of the pacific
and
like cincinnatus
i am returning to my plow
and i will be offering this government
nothing but the most fervent support
this is
i'll tell you why this is a tough time
for the economy this is a tough time for
families up and down the country we can
and we will get through it we will come
out stronger the other side
but i say to
my fellow conservatives it's time for
politics to be over folks it's time for
us all to get behind liz truss and her
team and her program
and deliver for the people of this
country
because that is what the people of this
country want that's what they need
and that's what they deserve
i'm proud
to have discharged the promises i made
to my party when you were kind enough to
choose me winning the biggest majority
since 1987 the biggest share of the vote
since 1979 delivering brexit delivering
our manifesto commitments including by
the way including social care reforming
social care helping people up and down
the country ensuring that britain is
once again standing tall in the world
speaking with clarity and authority
from ukraine to the orcas pact with
america and
australia because we are one whole and
entire united
kingdom whose diplomats security
services and armed forces
are so globally admired and by the way
as i believe as i leave i believe our
union is so strong that those who want
to break it up they'll keep trying but
they will never ever succeed
thank you to everybody
behind me in this building
thank you to all of you in government
and thank you everyone who's helped look
after me and my family over the last
three years including
including dylan the dog
and i just say to my party if dylan and
larry
can put behind them their occasional
difficulties then so can the
conservative party
above all thanks to you
the british people to the voters for
giving me the chance to serve all of you
who work so tirelessly together
to beat covid to put us where we are
today
together we have laid foundations that
will stand the test of time whether by
taking back control of our laws or
putting in vital new infrastructure
great solid masonry on which we will
continue to build together
paving paving the path
of prosperity now and for future
generations
and i will be supporting liz truss and
the new government every step of the way
thank you all very much thank you and
goodbye thank you
[Applause]
so boris johnson there uh with harry his
wife uh he has made the speech he's uh
said farewell uh to his uh parliamentary
and political back as you can see ben
wallace big applause and cheers and he's
got into the car
uh and that is it there you can see them
uh the children not there their their
small toddler and and baby romy yes less
than a year old uh and that's it the end
of the boris johnson regime regime he
and carrie johnson in the car to see the
queen fulsome applause
in the street in downing street from his
uh parliamentary his political
supporters his allies his sister rachel
johnson nadine
there's sadness here uh there's uh hugs
uh and that's it boris johnson is
leaving down the street uh for the final
time as promised we'll commemorate what
you said in a moment beth but just
reflecting it's a remarkably human
moment isn't it looking around you saw
some faces that were really
really upset and hurt by by what they
were facing sadness yeah genuine sadness
and actually i i i mean jacob rees-mogg
i could see him out in the distance he
looked upset i mean a lot of people here
upset boris johnson did command fierce
loyalty from those who supported him and
you saw that in the way that they
defended him some of his cabinet
to the very end but it is over and what
it was a i i would say a a classic
forrest johnson speech there
there was a serious message injected uh
with humor at the end where he talked
about if you can unite dylan the dog and
uh larry the cat uh the two uh pets
actually larry's just um emerged from
down his street there uh then you can
unite the conservative parties he called
for colleagues uh to come together as i
thought he went through his greatest
hits you just heard that he talked about
the vaccine rollout he talked about the
war in ukraine and britain's role in
leading
the world in its response as he talked
about you know he got applause
for some of that but also
you could
sense
the bitterness
in the beginning of that speech done in
a very johnson way
but when he talked about it was a relay
race you said and the rules halfway
through changed and that we raised our
eyebrows with that we did because it was
almost
it's a reflection of i won a confidence
vote you remember there was a confidence
vote which he won
and still
uh the party wanted him out
and then that precipitated the
resignations and the threat of a second
confidence vote and he to the very end
thought he could fight on and it was
only when his closest political
islanders said you'll either get forced
out by cabinet and colleagues or you
will face another confidence vote and
get forced out that he knew the game was
out but a little swiped there really at
a parliamentary party that forced him
out of office when he certainly didn't
want to go
what did he say about the energy crisis
because that is what the country really
care about the moment he said that the
government will give people the cash
they need to get through the energy
crisis
and he said uh if putin thinks he can
succeed uh he against the british people
they are utterly deluded echo in that
sense that he gave last week about
urging the public uh to stick with it
that the price worth paying is worth it
for the freedom of ukraine but of course
when people are facing such crippling
energy jobs worried about their own
livelihoods and their own families
expecting action on that um what did he
say about party unity he said it's time
for politics to be over and he said it's
time to get behind liz trust and her
program and deliver for the country and
the issue about the programme is
actually the difference in economic
approach of the sunnat camp versus the
trust camp it's going to be a big issue
over the autumn as she does record
levels of borrowing potentially in order
to fund fast uh energy price freezes in
some form potentially and then those
promised tax cuts and what does it do to
the markets you've seen the pound
devaluing now at near three decade lows
as investors get nervous about the
economic credibility of the uk
she has a hell of a job on her hands
both to reassure the public and
investors in these first few days we
expect the energy packet by package
potentially thursday by the end of the
week yeah
as you say it seems classically johnson
in his speech some laughs for some
people and a serious message as well but
i think it's worth reflecting is the
street starts to clear because you know
boris johnson and his wife carrie have
now left on their way to see the queen
at balmoral reflecting on his legacy
reflecting on
the country that he will leave after
three years three and a bit years in
office
boris johnson has been one of the
shortest serving prime ministers in
modern history which given that he won
as he said himself the biggest electoral
majority since the days of margaret
thatcher
uh you expected him to have a long run
at the premiership we expected i
remember talking about it on the night
he won that election that he had won the
power to reshape this country with a
majority uh that david cameron nor
theresa may never enjoyed when they were
prime ministers he had it within his
power to really change the country and
in the end as i said
you know at the time
in the end it was his own mistakes
missteps that brought himself down that
brought an end uh to his reign but he is
a consequential prime minister it might
have been a short tenure ship but it was
so impactful in terms of brexit he
delivered one of the biggest economic
and political changes to this country
this century uh the ramifications of
which will last for decades to come he
then had to handle a pandemic and
deliver the vaccine roll out he then was
hospitalized himself
nearly put into
intensive care potentially he managed to
stay off a ventilator but he was very
ill gravely ill at that time and i think
when history looks back on him uh the
fact that he was the man that campaigned
for brexit and then delivered it it
makes him a consequential prime minister
despite all the flaws that eventually
drove him out of office consequential
can have a double meaning kind of so i
bet really appreciate that analysis
thank you so much for that uh let's get
more reaction of course to what we've
heard from the outgoing prime minister
now joining me is the conservative mp
and chair of the defense select
committee that's tobias elwood good
morning uh tobias i would thank you so
much for being with us this morning as
we look at pictures of boris johnson's
range rover departing downing street for
the final time what
your reflections on what you just heard
yeah it's certainly emotional day i
think you've got to bear in mind many
mps that were there uh were reliant on
boris johnson and his energy to get
elected but we enter a new chapter it
isn't just in the interest of the party
of the government to show unity i'd
argue it's actually in the interest of
the nation as well given the scale of
challenges that you've been speaking
about the cost of living crisis is
arguably as crippling if not more than
covid it's going to require some smart
intervention by government to support
businesses pubs and restaurants and so
forth as well as households we all need
to give the space to this prime minister
to provide some of those solutions there
won't be another prime minister let's
hope not until the next general election
uh is then up to us to make sure we
provide a short-term solution to get us
through this difficult winter a
longer-term strategy to make sure we
don't repeat this and then we can see
the economy uh grow and then it'll be up
to the electorate in 2024 to recognize
whether we've answered those solutions
or do we move the country forward or
whether we've been buried by
them and we'll come on to what liz trust
may well be doing but let's just stay a
little bit longer if we can with what we
heard from from boris johnson i mean did
you get a sense from that speech so
that's the the final time we've seen
boris johnson in front line at politics
um i think we
see him recognizing straight away that
we have to unify behind uh liz trusses
absolutely that is the the prerogative i
don't think it'd be helpful for him to
comment from the sidelines um i think
it's very very important that uh he
recognized that this trust needs to be
given the space to provide the authority
the command the leadership that we want
to see around the cabinet table
to deal with these big challenges that
you and i and all of us have been
discussing and everybody is so aware of
in fact that we've been delayed you know
had a summer of delay because of that
leadership contest was only focused
perhaps on the minute i issues uh rather
than the bigger picture simply because
of the nature of the contest itself
and now you will have seen the reporting
this morning
about the the size of the package being
considered by the prime minister
your feelings on that is that going to
be sufficient i mean that may well some
people see be
an undervalued amount it's a hundred
billion pounds
yes it is it's a huge economic uh
intervention uh i you know i dismissed
perhaps the the uh the loss of the
summer but clearly teams under nadim
sahari and others have been looking at
the various options for the new prime
minister to now consider and understand
that we will get some major
announcements this week not a moment too
soon i think the country will welcome
that but if i can just link that to what
uh the outgoing prime minister also
focused on our armed forces and indeed
ukraine and the prime minister the the
former prime minister boris johnson can
be commended for what britain has done
to support that country but i make it
very very clear this didn't come up in
the leadership contest you know our
world will continue to become more
dangerous not less you know the west
remains too risk-averse in standing up
to putin and his
agenda many of the challenges oil gas
indeed food prices because the grain
can't get out of odessa
will remain or indeed get worse it
requires international leadership it
requires countries to come together nato
to be a bit more assertive if we're
going to change the direction of travel
what putin is trying to achieve that is
something that i hope that we will now
focus on
okay tobias chair of the defense select
committee appreciate your thoughts this
morning thank you very much
for being with us
all right now as i said down the street
has started to clear out restaurants and
has left on his way to baltimore to see
the queen to officially tended his
resignation but speculation is swirling
about the makeup of liz truss's cabinet
as she deals with multiple crises while
trying to restore unity to a
conservative party after what has been a
long bruising and bitter leadership
place well joining me now is the former
head of the civil service that's lord
kirsten lorcursley good morning to you
and thank you for being with us uh
before i talk to you about the processes
that uh will be coming into place once
this trust assumes office just reflect
if you can on what you heard from boris
johnson
well it was a typically upbeat speech
from boris he rightly i guess wanted to
make the most of what he felt he had
achieved in office
but we can't deny the fact that we
have major challenges and those
challenges are going to be inherited by
a successor liz trust so the kind of
speech you would always expect to see
from boris he must reflect i guess that
given his huge majority and
the achievement of brexit he might have
achieved
more but we are where we are we move on
and now liz trust has to pick up some
very very big issues
yeah she certainly does and where did
she begin you would have seen the
reporting this morning about that huge
package that's being uh proposed um i'll
get your thoughts on it if you don't
mind her little curtis lake i mean what
do you think that seems to be enough 100
billion pounds being proposed to try and
help households and potentially
businesses
well look uh it's absolutely right that
the immediate priority is the question
of the cost of living and the cost of
fuel it's clear that the war in ukraine
is going to afraid drag on prices are
going to remain sky high as far as
particularly gas is concerned and
there's no question that urgent action
is needed time's really been lost over
the summer
it's hard to say whether 100 billion
will be enough and we don't yet know the
details of this package what i think is
clear is that there has to be some way
of containing the price increase both
for ordinary people if you like and for
businesses if we don't do that then i
think the consequences as we move into
the winter are going to be catastrophic
the price is high but the consequences
of not doing something of this scale i
think are uh literally unacceptable
uh lord kesley you mentioned those two
months that you described as as time
lost time wasted that some may feel for
um trying to deal with this crisis but
in your former role as head of the civil
service how much work will have already
been going on to make sure that uh
whoever assumed office and now we know
of course it's going to be liz trust has
got all the details all the plans in
place so they can start being
implemented immediately i'd say time
lost
for other people to judge whether it was
wasted but it undoubtedly was time lost
and
yes a huge amount of work will have been
done to prepare the option for an
incoming government and indeed the
business of government on the day-to-day
issues carried on the problem here was
that there was a very fundamental
difference of view between the two
competing candidates uh rishi sunak and
liz trust about the right way forward
and in that situation
you had to wait until the winner was
known before you could move but yes
there'll be a lot of detailed
calculations of different options
having been prepared and the
conversations will have happened with uh
the people who are likely to take up key
roles we've known for a little while
that quasi-cuateng is almost certainly
going to be the new chance for the
exchequer
and so on so i think yes those
conversations have happened but now
they've really got to move ahead press
ahead on the detail and what i'd say to
you is that the challenge for this trust
here is that there are very
big and competing issues that she has to
address here so if she puts money into
tackling the fuel issue that in turn
impacts on the public finances
and at the same time she's got the issue
of the tax cut and what that does and
the nhs and the need for more funding
there particularly for care i'm afraid i
didn't agree with boris johnson that he
sorted social care he hasn't there are
major challenges still there to be
addressed
okay lord because i do appreciate your
expertise this morning thank you very
much for being with us let's bring back
in our political editor better be still
with us so paul kurzler they're laying
out just the challenges facing uh liz
trust of course uh we've heard boris
johnson's farewell speech he is now gone
so look ahead to us what we are going to
expect happens
well the key thing clearly is the energy
crisis people's bills both families and
businesses and what will she do about
that we could hear as early as thursday
what the plan is she has quasi quantum
currently the business secretary to
become the chancellor working on this
along with nadeem sahari currently the
chancellor it's expected that he will
move to the cabinet office so her key
lieutenants are in government already
working on the plan what might it look
like look the details are still being
worked out but it's fair to say that it
will be to quote one of my uh sources in
the trust campus shock and all moment a
big and bold plan is how penny mordant
who's also expected to go into cabinet
put it what might it look like well
labour have promised an energy price
freeze freeze in household bills at the
levels set the cap set in april 2022
will they freeze uh bills in october
2022 it will cost the ifs expects about
38 billion pounds she might also decide
uh to freeze the wholesale price of
energy and gas that will help business
as well look in the round we don't know
the detail what we do know is it's going
to be a multi-billion pound package and
it will be a big bold moment and it
could define whether she succeeds or
fails in these early months as prime
minister what about 40 seconds left
betsy just give us your final
reflections on boris johnson after what
we've heard this morning he's on his way
to see the queen's seat on the way to
see the queen a politician who was full
of potential that he never quite
realized uh clear disappointment there
anger a bit that he's been pushed out of
office he says he's going to go and land
in a remote corner of the pacific but
let's see what he does next he is loved
he is loathed but he will go down in
history as the prime minister that
delivered brexit and that is quite a
legacy
okay
thank you so much for that analysis as
we look at these pictures of boris
johnson and his wife carrie johnson
saying goodbye to the assembled
conservative mps who came to say their
farewells was on his way to see the
queen plenty more throughout the morning
scottish breakfast stay with us
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm ivan bonio i'm a sailor
i spent half time of my life on the on
the sea
we have a factory we can convert this
plastic to energy
and so after at the end we can minimize
the footprint carbon of the board
[Music]
hello and good morning it is 8 00 a.m
that's it folks the words of boris
johnson a short time ago here on downing
street giving his farewell speech to the
nation after leaving number 10. he
called on the conservative party to get
behind his success at this trust and is
now on his way to scotland to officially
tender his resignation to the queen
thank you thank well
well this is
this is it folks
thank you everybody for coming out
so early this morning
in only a couple of hours i will be in
balmoral to see her majesty the queen
and the torch will finally be passed to
a new conservative leader the baton will
be handed over in what has unexpectedly
turned out to be a relay race they
changed the rules halfway through but
never mind that now
and through that lacquered black door a
new prime minister will shortly go to
meet a fantastic group of public
servants the people who got brexit done
the people who deliver the fastest
vaccine rollout in europe and never
forget 70
of the entire population got a dose
within six months
faster than any comparable country that
is government for you that's this
conservative government
people
who organized those prompt early
supplies of weapons to the heroic
ukrainian armed forces an action that
may very well have helped change the
course of the biggest european war for
80 years and because of the speed and
urgency of what you did everybody
involved in this government to get this
economy moving again from july last year
in spite of all the opposition
all the naysayers we have
and will continue
to have
that economic strength to give people
the cash they need to get through this
energy crisis that has been caused by
putin's vicious war
and i know
that liz
trus
and this compassionate conservative
government will do everything we can to
get people through this crisis and this
country will endure it and we will win
and if putin thinks that he can succeed
by blackmailing or bullying the british
people then he is utterly deluded
and the reason we will have those funds
now and in the future is because we
conservatives understand the vital
symmetry between government action and
free market capitalist private sector
enterprise
we're delivering on those huge manifesto
commitments making streets safer
neighborhood crime down 38
in the last three years thirteen
thousand seven hundred ninety more
police on the streets building more
hospitals and yes we will have fifty
thousand more nurses by the end of the
decade and forty more hospitals by the
end of
fifty thousand nurses by the end of this
parliament i should say 40 new hospitals
by the end of the decade putting record
funding into our schools and into
teachers pay giving everybody over 18 a
lifetime skills guarantee so they can
keep up skilling throughout their lives
three new high-speed rail lines three
including northern powerhouse rail
colossal road proud programs from the
pennines to cornwall the rollout of
gigabit broadband up over the last
three years i am proud to say since you
were kind enough to elect me from seven
percent of our country's premises having
gigabit broadband to 70
today and we are of course providing the
short and the long-term solutions for
our energy needs and not just using more
of our own domestic hydrocarbons but
going up by 2030 to 50 gigawatts of wind
power that is half of this country's
energy electricity needs from offshore
wind alone a new nuclear reactor every
year and looking at what is happening in
this country the changes that are taking
place that is why private sector
investment is flooding in more private
sector more venture capital investment
than china itself more billion pound
tech companies sprouting here in the uk
that in france germany and israel
combined and as a result
unemployment as i leave office
unemployment down to lowe's not seen
since i was about 10 years old and
bouncing around on a space hopper my
friends and
on on the subject of
on the subject of bouncing around in
future careers
let me say that i am now like one of
those booster rockets
that has fulfilled its function and i
will now be gently re-entering the
atmosphere and splashing down
invisibly in some remote and obscure
corner of the pacific
and
like cincinnatus
i am returning to my plow
and i will be offering this government
nothing but the most fervent support
this is i'll tell you why this is a
tough time
for the economy
this is a tough time for families up and
down the country we can and we will get
through it we will come out stronger the
other side
but i say to
my fellow conservatives it's time for
politics to be over folks it's time for
us all to get behind liz truss and her
team and her program
and deliver for the people of this
country
because that is what the people of this
country want that's what they need
and that's what they deserve
i'm proud
to have discharged the promises i made
to my party when you were kind enough to
choose me winning the biggest majority
since 1987 the biggest share of the vote
since 1979 delivering brexit delivering
our manifesto commitments including by
the way including social care reforming
social care helping people up and down
the country ensuring that britain is
once again standing tall in the world
speaking with clarity and authority
from ukraine to the orcas pact with
america and
australia
because we are one whole and entire
united kingdom whose diplomats security
services and armed forces
are so globally admired and by the way
as i believe as i leave i believe our
union is so strong that those who want
to break it up they'll keep trying but
they will never ever succeed
thank you to everybody
behind me in this building
thank you to all of you in government uh
thank you everyone who's helped look
after me and my family over the last
three years including
including dylan the dog
and i just say to my party of dylan and
larry can put behind them their
occasional difficulties then so can the
conservative party
above all thanks to you
the british people to the voters for
giving me the chance to serve
all of you
who work so tirelessly together
to beat covid to put us where we are
today
together we have laid foundations that
will stand the test of time whether by
taking back control of our laws or
putting in vital new infrastructure
great solid masonry on which we will
continue to build together
paving paving the path
of prosperity now and for future
generations
and i will be supporting liz truss and
the new government every step of the way
thank you all very much thank you and
goodbye thank you
[Applause]
so there we have it in the last 40
minutes or so boris johnson delivering
his farewell message to the nation
comparing himself to a
booster rockets that was now going to
come down somewhere in the pacific but
there was some more sort of high brow
descriptions that he used about himself
as well yeah it was it was for me a
vintage johnson speech there it had
jives it had jokes there was an element
of seriousness uh
in it there was also a sense of uh
self-congratulation in what he had
achieved and quite typical of boris
johnson not much acknowledgement of
things he might have got wrong it's been
a characteristic of his leadership ever
since i have followed him
from that brexit referendum in to number
10 in terms of uh the legacy the boris
johnson legacy uh he talked about covid
the vaccine rollout he talked about the
role of the uk
in ukraine and it was something that he
certainly feels that he led the world on
and actually has been acknowledged by
president zielenski as one of uh
ukraine's closest allies and then of
course he talked about brexit now on the
politics there was a clear dig there
saying that people had changed the rules
and uh he was forced out of office that
the anger he feels and the injustice of
being forced out of office they're still
pretty plain to see no acknowledgment of
mistakes that he made and his own
conduct uh that contributed to the
building scandal that eventually tipped
so many of his supporters his own
backbenchers his own cabinet over the
edge to force him out but no
acknowledgement there of that what he
did say was it's time to put the
politics behind us and get behind liz
trust and on that as well he talked
about energy bills trying to reassure
the public that there will be as he put
it cash in their pockets to help on
bills we should hear about that
potentially on thursday and then just
finally a bit on his future he talked
about cincinnati uh he was a
roman statesman who uh helped the empire
and then went back to his plow he taught
he described himself as that but will he
make a return that is the thing that is
still hanging in the air when it comes
to boris johnson finally he thanked his
family and landed with that joke didn't
he that if dylan his dog and larry uh
the cat can get along so should the
conservative party and with that uh he
was off into a band of supporters he's
always been the politician that wants to
show his party that he is the man that
can connect when he's on his best form
to parts of the electorate that others
can't but despite the support down there
the party did not want him anymore and
he ends his reign as prime minister one
of the shortest serving uh prime
ministers in modern history he had it in
his gift uh to be one of the most
consequential of this decade
really appreciate that analysis thank
you so much for that all right um well
the thoughts of beth review there as i
said just 40 minutes after hearing from
boris johnson let's bring in now the
deputy leader of the labour party that's
angela rainer angela good morning to you
thank you very much for being with us so
you will have listened to boris
johnson's speech there and i do wonder
have you just lost your most potent
electoral asset now boris johnson's out
of office
i mean it was a classic boris johnson
speech completely deluded about what's
happened over the last couple of years
and the crisis that people are facing
high tax under the conservatives under
boris johnson the highest tax rate for
decades high inflation
lower living standards businesses that
are facing absolute bankruptcy because
of the situation and business rates done
nothing on that done nothing to support
uk industry and i just felt that there
was no acknowledgement of how the
scandal and sleaze that has engulfed his
party and his government over the last
couple of years whether that was him
supporting the scandal around owen
patson supporting chris pincher with the
situation with sexual harassment whether
that was the absolute billions of pounds
that was wasted on money that was given
to mates um through the global pandemic
and of course the partying that happened
when the uk public were told that they
had to go into lockdown and had to
follow the rules i think it was
completely deluded and it stunk of all
the hallmarks of somebody who's had a
privileged background who thinks that
they can just do what they like
i mean angela you made that very clear
as to how you felt about it you didn't
actually answer my question because now
that he has gone after all of those
scandals that you're laid out you've got
this trust to face who's already perhaps
got a proposal that goes way beyond the
labor party's plan to deal with the
energy crisis that we're facing
well i've not seen any proposal that
goes beyond labour's plan labour's been
calling for a freeze on the energy bills
and that we've said it should be paid
for by a windfall tax on oil and gas
companies liz trust hasn't said that she
thinks that working people should foot
the bill for that um she said that she
would reverse the national insurance
contribution rise which she voted for
let's be clear liz trust has been part
of the cabinet and has been part of the
decisions that have been made that has
propped up boris johnson and got the
country in the mess it said now so yes
it's great that boris johnson has left
anyone would think that he's left of his
own fruition when that's clearly not
true but we've seen a conservative party
that are behind the curve constantly on
the crisis that is engulfing many people
and many businesses in the uk today and
i don't think they're in touch with
what's happening on the ground in the uk
they're completely deluded the gp
situation the nhs situation the social
care situation trying to get a passport
trying to get your driving license it's
complete backlog because of the
conservatives have not been doing their
job
yeah and the reporting this morning uh
miss rainer is that some 100 billion
pounds is going to be spent and that
would bring in a freeze and energy bills
and the reporting in conservative
leading newspapers suggest that's going
to come in until 2024. now as you know
the labour policy was 28 billion for
only six months so i put it to you again
that the conservatives have outflanked
you on this one
well no because we can't just quite
frankly keep pouring money in the
conservatives have raised the national
debt we've seen inflation at its highest
rate labour has said that we've got to
have a medium-term plan where we look at
renewables we look at home insulation
and that we boost a long-term strategy
around how we deal with our energy
crisis the government have been in power
for 12 years and again boris johnson
talked about jam tomorrow it was all
we're going to get these nuclear power
stations one every year that's tomorrow
not today there's been 12 years of
conservatives where they failed to deal
with these issues and now we're at a
crisis point we do have to have a
long-term solution to this labors put
that plan forward and we can't just keep
going from one crisis to the next we
have to have a long-term plan from the
government about how we're going to use
renewables and how we're going to
insulate homes and how we're going to
get these good skilled jobs into the uk
so that instead of leveling down which
is what we've seen boris johnson talked
about rail investment northern rail has
been scaled down the people of greater
manchester the only reason we're getting
um changes to transport is because of
our labour mayor in greater manchester
we're making a difference on the ground
the government have leveled down and
have not delivered on the promises that
they made to the people of the uk
and i thought on the potential makeup of
the the top team religious trust is
putting in place it looks like it's
going to be one of the most diverse
great states office states of office um
in history with not one white man in
that grouping i mean the labour party
who had the first black mp uh is it
shameful that the conservative party
beats having such a diverse
cabinet well i welcome diversity in
politics i've been talking about that
for a very long time both on social
economic but also on ethnicity and of
people from up and down the uk being
involved in politics and i think it's
important that we do that but it's also
important about what people do and liz
trust has been part of the cabinet that
has got us into this situation in the
first place and now we need to see
action to make sure that people of
britain can see real change that will
help them with their living standards
now liz trust throughout this leadership
campaign has not been talking about the
issues that are really facing the people
of the uk you've been talking about tax
cuts as opposed to really dealing with
the cost of living crisis that
businesses and households are facing at
the moment so i think it's more about
what you do in government that is really
important at the moment to people of the
uk but diversity is always welcome we
need more diversity in politics and in
the executive boardrooms in all of our
uk top companies
right and angela finally then you would
have heard boris johnson speak he talked
about uh being the leader of the whole
of the uk but you'll know that there is
of course that um independence movement
in scotland and there is reporting now
that this trust is going to bring in new
legislation to try and make it even more
difficult for the smp to to go for
independence i mean
democratically how dangerous is that if
new legislation is going to come in i
know you perhaps don't support
independence for scotland but how
dangerous democratically is that new
legislation going to be for that
movement
i think one of the most dangerous things
that we've seen in the uk and it applies
to scotland as well as parts of england
that feel left behind is the inequality
that's growing in in the uk and i think
that is the most dangerous risk to the
union at the moment is people need to
see that real investment not jammed
tomorrow not broken promises but
investment across the united kingdom and
that devolution so that people have more
control over what's happening in their
lives locally and i think if we're able
to do that and people can see that
respect is given to all parts of the uk
and opportunity is given then i think
that will solve some of these issues but
until that happens then of course people
are going to be frustrated just as
people in the north of england have been
frustrated i can see why people in
scotland are frustrated and the only way
really we can change all of that is by
changing the government and having a
labor government that are willing to
invest in all parts of the uk
okay angela reyna deputy leader of the
labour party appreciate your time this
morning thank you for being with us
now in a formal sense at least the most
significant event today is going to take
place some 500 miles away in scotland at
balmoral that is where the queen is
spending her summer holiday and where
boris johnson is going to offer his
formal resignation and recommend that
this trust is asked to form a new
government
now shortly after that the new
conservative leader will arrive for the
process which is called the kissing of
hands
all right let's go to uh outside of
balmoral now i'm bringing our royal
correspondent rhiannon mills who's live
for us we annon good to have you with us
so what's the choreography boris
johnson's left here left in london i
guess he's on his way to the airport
wanted you to arrive up there
so it's going to be a few hours before
he arrives here in scotland and i think
what is going to be particularly
striking about today is usually we see
the kind of ceremony the circus of this
power handover all play out where you
are that short distance between number
10 and buckingham palace and the whole
process is wrapped up in less than a
couple of hours today is going to be a
lot more strung out and the theater is
all moving here to the i'd say more
dramatic certainly more remote setting
of the highlands has to be said for the
first time i think both number 10 and
the palace both with their eyes on the
sky certainly looking at the weather
forecast which may well change the
timing slightly but while the logistics
have had to change it's all been because
of the queen and simply from a practical
perspective last week the decision was
made yes the queen is hugely important
today but she isn't the only important
person for today and it's all been about
making sure that everyone knew what plan
was in place in terms of what was going
to happen uh today as you mentioned
earlier the formalities are going to
look very much the same as they are when
it's all carried out at buckingham
palace so boris johnson is due to arrive
here at about 10 past 11 and a lot was
made wasn't it that first speech that he
made in downing street where he
announced that he was stepping aside he
didn't mention that word resignation
today though he will formally resign in
front of the queen also at that moment
he will advise that the queen calls liz
truss to form a new administration of
course she is already on her way she
will be already on her way she will then
arrive for that very special first
audience with the queen described as the
kissing of hands in the court circular
no kissing involved instead a handshake
a bow or a curtsy and yeah for liz trust
it will be the start of a very important
relationship for her prime
past and certainly into the future have
described how important that
relationship has been there is only one
person like the queen that they can
really open up to share everything with
and know that all those conversations
are going to stay in that room i also
think in terms of the optics of today
yes it's caused difficulties potentially
people traveling all the way here up to
scotland but i think everyone knows that
it's important that the queen is seen to
be carrying out those constitutional
duties as boris johnson alluded to tough
time economically tough time for many
families up and down the country and
some would say a time of political
instability and so for some up and down
the country i think the queen continues
to be that reassuring presence and once
again today the palace ultimately being
practical being very common sense about
it saying look the 96 year old monarch
traveling down south just was not going
to be practical and so today we will
still see her that carry out that key
really important constitutional role the
old one
okay rhiannon in balmoral appreciate
that now what you're looking at now
viewers is a private jet that is
raf northolt where we believe the prime
minister is on his way to as i say just
about 40 minutes ago he left downing
street in a range rover
flanked by outriders with his wife
carrie johnson he's going to fly up to
balmoral as rhiannon was saying to
formally tender his resignation to the
queen this is uh live pictures from raf
norfolk where a private jet is awaiting
to take the outgoing prime minister to
formally resign to the queen
the queen will then meet the incoming
prime minister she's flying up as well
but in a different plane for security
reasons and she will officially
become prime minister now private jets
uh nerds will know exactly what kind of
crap that is i don't know but uh it
looks like a fast one it'll be up there
before lunchtime now
liz truss grew up in leeds let's find
out a little bit about her home town and
uh what they want to hear now from the
incoming prime minister our reporter
fraser moore is in leeds
for us this morning frasier good morning
again to you so as i said uh liz trust
grew up in the sheet she tells us a lot
about her story and her
essentially quite normal beginning so
what do people in leeds want to hear
from the incoming prime minister
yeah good morning this is where liz
trust grew up from about the age of ten
she said it was a reasonably humble uh
start to her life this is where she
studied and people here are hoping that
she will have an eye on the north when
it comes to taking over as prime
minister i can have a chat with andrew
ormond from a fantastic charity homeless
charity here in leeds and george's crypt
that helps hundreds of people with a
whole range of issues
what could liz trust do for you could do
to help the people that you help i think
it's going to be very very difficult i
think as you know we're in a cost of
living crisis
we've just come out of a pandemic i
think there's going to be all sorts of
things on her plate but i think as you
say have an eye on the north have an
understanding for the most vulnerable
people in our society
and have that compassion with her that
she can look to us and she can look to
the kinds of people that we work with
and we serve
and and make sure that we don't fall
into into any more poverty than we
already are and that's the danger is
that we're hearing a lot about fuel
poverty she's promised to tackle head on
the energy cost crisis i mean that could
be a big help for people couldn't it
prevented people from becoming homeless
in the first place and i think that's
one of the biggest things i think as we
were talking about i don't think that
there's going to be
much of a problem with funding for
people who are actually homeless but
it's the people who are on the on the
line on the poverty line people who are
entering into homelessness
people who
are are not earning that much and people
who can't make their bills people who
can't make buy their food people who are
are in food poverty and fuel poverty
they're people who are in desperate need
now and who are going to be hitting that
line now so i think it's there's there
needs to be an awful lot of focus there
okay well thanks for talking to sandra i
know you've got a busy day ahead so uh
troubled times ahead potentially uh this
trust needs to get a grip on the cost of
living needs to get a grip on listening
to communities like those here in leeds
okay fraser for now thank you very much
for that um we're still staying with
these pictures here from raf norfolk
where that jet is continuing to taxi on
the tarmac it will be carrying the prime
minister and his wife carrie up to
balmoral so he can
officially tend his resignation to the
queen
there it is
coming through the security fence there
borussia is expected in scotland in the
next couple of hours and of course once
he does arrive there will uh bring the
very latest now after he has tended his
official resignation to the queen um
let's trust the incoming prime minister
will also meet the queen there's a
ceremony called kissing of the hands and
as we've been telling you this morning
they don't actually kiss and it's
probably gonna be a formal handshake
where she is officially asked to form
the next government she'll then make her
way back here to london where she's
expected to give her first address as
prime minister
uh sometime this afternoon and we're
expecting her to give that address just
outside number 10 if the weather remains
set fair as it is this morning all right
well let's just uh
get the thoughts of uh the liberal
democrats as we continue watching our
playing rf north the thoughts of lib
dems and the leader of the lib dems who
was of course listening into the prime
minister's outgoing speech there and i'm
pleased that we can bring in uh sired
davey who is joining us now live uh for
more on the final days of the prime
minister and the new pm who is coming in
uh sure davey good morning to you and
thank you very much for being with us
this morning i'll get you first of all
if you can just to reflect on what you
heard from boris johnson there in his
outgoing
speech
what boris johnson failed to
mention was our economy is in a mess
we
are the lowest growth
projections of any industrial country by
russia
energy bills are going through the roof
people are really worried about food
prices they're worried about the crisis
in the nhs
and that's all happened under his
premiership
and so you know what liberal democrats
are saying with the new prime minister
is
we need to hear real plans and i've been
listening to liz trusts and the
conservatives over the summer over their
leadership contest and what alarm me and
i think must have really worried
millions of
families and pensioners um is that she
didn't seem to put forward a plan at all
whether it's on the energy bills or the
nhs and um either they don't get it or
or they don't care
well she's pivoted now hasn't she
surrendered as you'll know the reporting
this morning suggests that she's
preparing a package worth at least 100
billion pounds to try and help with the
energy crisis
well there are reports but the ones i'm
reading are quite worrying liberal
democrats argued for a freeze on the cap
so people's bills wouldn't go up this
autumn and that should be paid for by a
one-off tax on the oil and gas companies
are making huge profits that's our
position and what we're hearing from
these reports is that she's going to
announce a sort of loan system uh
dressing it up as a freeze but it won't
be a freeze it will be a loan and uh
families and pensioners and businesses
will be asked to pay that back
over the next few years uh paying later
what liberal democrats say is actually
given these oil and gas giants are
making tens of billions of pounds of
profit they never expected to
because president putin invaded russia
that we should be asking of them to make
a fair contribution and not putting it
um onto families
and as part of
the reported plans
there's going to be an expansion of
extraction of fossil fuels from the
north sea and also perhaps
a renewing of fracking in parts of the
country
well there's been a lot of dishonesty
about fracking um
the reality is that it's not going to
reduce the price of gas
and it's energy bills we need to cut for
people people are struggling we need
they want to see their energy bills
lower and the way to do that
actually is to invest in renewables and
insulation they are have the potential
to bring down people's energy bills
because uh electricity generated by wind
and solar is so much cheaper than
electricity generated by burning gas
i mean so red davies it's all very well
and computer say this now but you were
part of a coalition government that
stopped those new nuclear power plants
being built
you're wrong i'm afraid
i was the first energy secretary in the
generation to announce a new nuclear
power station which is being built as we
speak and not only did i do that but
liberal democrats quadrupled renewable
power we saw a massive expansion in
solar wind and became the world's leader
in offshore wind we insulated over a
million homes the problem was in 2015
after those excellent liberal democrat
policies which
were really helping getting bills down
the conservatives changed the policy
they didn't invest in insulating
people's homes they didn't invest
properly in renewables and they haven't
done anything on nuclear so it's been
the failure of the conservative energy
policies that have got us into this mess
uh well i'm sorry david then you must be
pleased then to hear as borrower johnson
said in this speech that they're going
to be building a new nuclear power plant
every year
uh
it's just not going to happen
unfortunately he hasn't got any serious
plans
if we want to make a difference
now and in the next few years the best
way to do that is to
take on the liberal democrat record and
build on that with
onshore wind offshore wind and solar and
really insulating people's homes that is
the way we can cut people's bills that's
what liberal democrats want we want to
cut people's bills
and unfortunately the proposals from
boris johnson on nuclear would put up
people's bills nucleus actually is very
very expensive far more expensive than
wind and solar and obviously a lot more
expensive than insulating people's homes
so people don't have to use the energy
in the first place so i'm really worried
that the conservative energy policy
which have been a disaster for so long
can continue to be a disaster because
they're going to go after the most
expensive options and what people want
is much cheaper
energy
all right sir david leader of the
liberal democrats do appreciate your
time this morning thank you for being
with us
now boris johnson as i have said has
delivered his final speech as prime
minister calling for the conservative
party to get behind his successor this
truss
well the new conservative party leader
will take over as pm later today she is
going to meet the queen about moral
around lunchtime
[Music]
the trust will then address the nation
in downing street this afternoon before
appointing her first cabinet
[Music]
all right let's bring in our political
correspondent tomorrow who's been with
us throughout the morning for more on
what we've seen in the past hour or so
tomorrow i'd love to have you with us
again so let's just reflect a little bit
on what we heard from boris johnson
first of all
that's all folks he said it was jovial
it was never emotional that's not the
outgoing prime minister's style there
was the tiniest dollop of bitterness it
wasn't as bitter as the speech that we
saw in july when he was obviously full
of raw bitterness about how he was
forced from office by resignations from
within his party he said it turns out it
was a relay race and they changed the
rules halfway through but he said never
mind that now he's had a couple of
months to think on it and he wanted to
talk about his achievements of course we
heard about the vaccine rollout about
the military aid to ukraine not that
much about brexit given that was the
reason that he came into power of course
about the 80-seat majority
also some of what he hoped will be
written up as achievements the 40 new
hospitals which he says will happen by
the end of the decade if indeed they
really will and the 50 000 nurses that
he promised some of those history will
judge whether they were really domestic
achievements but
boris johnson
said he talked about himself as a rocket
booster that had fulfilled its
usefulness and he would land in the
pacific somewhere can we really believe
that that's true or will he hang around
the political scene he said he would
offer his full support to liz trust as
prime minister coming in at a difficult
time and with the challenge of energy
bills and he finished with a line which
i think we will be mulling over most of
the day he said like the roman emperor
cincinnatus he would be returning to his
plow returning to his farm but i think
there was some debate about whether
cincinnati's in fact made a bit of a
comeback later on so he's leaving us to
think on that one entirely open-ended
wasn't it and he'll know that because
he's a classic he knows exactly what
happens so we'll think about whether
whether that is what he means but i
think you saw him trying to secure his
place in history with what he believes
his achievements are with his
characteristic bullishness and colourful
language
take a little listen to some of what he
had to say
this is a tough time for the economy
this is a tough time for families up and
down the country we can and we will get
through it we will come out stronger the
other side but i say to
my fellow conservatives it's time for
politics to be over folks it's time for
us all to get behind liz trust and her
team and her program
and deliver for the people of this
country
well tomorrow
that was boris johnson giving his his
final thoughts and he to the end tried
to remain optimistic which is his
character tracing it doesn't apologize
and he doesn't explain there was no
remorse there was no real
self-reflection about the sequence of
events partygate the chris pincher
affair which brought him down expected
to hear him say sorry for some of that
stuff i think we expected it more in
july when he was forced out from office
to say something to his party about it
but he's always found that side of
things difficult
he now wants to dwell on his
achievements labour and the liberal
democrats we just heard that i think
it's delusional but of course he was
the most electoral success electorally
successful prime minister 30 years
and it's pretty clear that he's saying
to liz trust look i'm gonna be a hard
act to follow yeah and crack on with it
and make sure you follow on okay
tomorrow i really appreciate that thank
you very much now of course during the
leadership race which lasted for two
months this trust set the tone for what
could potentially be more strange
relations with the leaders in scotland
by referring to the first minister
nicolas sturgeon as an attention seeker
who should be ignored let's get the
thoughts now on the smp's westminster
leader that's ian blackfin blackford
good morning to you it's nice to have
you with us um i mean you heard what
this trust said about um
about nicolas sturgeon and i know you've
commented on that i want first of all
for you to reflect on what you heard
from boris johnson as he was going as i
put to angela arena now that he's gone
have you lost an electoral asset in the
fact that you've seen the back of him
no look i mean i will today i wish him
all the best him and his family for the
future but i'm glad he's gone because we
need to remember the reasons why he had
to leave office he had the first prime
minister in history that broke the law
one that's lied to parliament one that
illegally shut down parliament so i'm
glad that's over and i hope that liz
trust learns some of the lessons from
that because the language that you
talked about saying that the first
minister of scotland was an attention
seeker we need to have a relationship
where the government in london and the
devolved administrations when it's
appropriate can work together we face
what is the biggest economic crisis that
we've had since the
1970s and we have a responsibility to
make sure that we can reassure the
public and reassure businesses that will
deal with the cost of living crisis
that's the priority that we have today
we need to make sure that we can cap
energy prices but there's going to be a
big debate as to how this is paid it
can't be done on the way of just
deferring bills for people we need to
make sure that government accepts its
responsibilities we're in the situation
we're in
no short measure because of the ukraine
war and of course we stand with ukraine
and the illegal war that putin is
engaging on against them but there's a
price to be paid for that and government
needs to recognize that we need to have
a windfall tax that fairly taxes those
that have benefited from this and we
need to make sure that government puts
its hand in its own pocket and pays for
the cost and crucially if we do this we
can probably knock about four percentage
points off inflation so let's make sure
that we do the right thing let's support
consumers let's support businesses but
now is not the time for having a debate
about tax cuts that would be the wrong
thing to do and i'm looking forward to
having that engagement that debate with
the prime minister over the course of
the next day or two
well that's engagement and debate that's
a very magnanimous way to put it are you
expecting there to be a little bit of a
reset then after what was said during
the leadership
campaign
but there has to be because i think
there's there's got to be a recognition
that the government in edinburgh has got
its job to do and we need to have
appropriate communication with all the
involved administration indeed with the
opposition parties as well we will have
very clear political differences but
there are times that we need to make
sure that when things are happening in
westminster like this it's going to
affect the devolved administrations
affect their budgets no less that
there's a appropriate communication
that's taking place but secondly i think
there's got to be respect for the
devolved administrations and if you take
the position that we are in that we
stood on a commitment of delivering an
independence referendum in the first
half of this parliament the first half
of the scottish parliament and this
trust has got to respect democracy and
has got to respect the right of the
scottish parliament to allow people in
scotland to have a say on their
constitutional future
now of course there are reports this
morning that this trust is planning some
kind of change legislation to make it
more difficult for an independent
referendum to be held of course there is
going to be a hearing at the high court
all about the legality of a next uh
independence referendum where do you
stand on what you're hearing these
reports about um this trust and her
potential plans
well let me say it's barking mad it's i
think what we refer to as gerrymandering
when you stand for an election and when
you have a referendum you put your case
you encourage the electorate to vote and
of course you want to have the highest
turnout possible but the idea that
somehow or other you can change the
rules
i think people in scotland whether or
not they agree with us or not are going
to reflect on what is you know a silent
behavior which is just completely
unacceptable and if you think about the
the rules that
liz trust and our government are
thinking of putting in place that means
for example that brexit wouldn't have
happened because you weren't able to
clear that hard though you'd be left in
a situation where those on the electoral
roll that sadly may have passed on would
effectively be counted as a no voter in
such a contest it's not right it's wrong
and this should be put to bed we should
simply not be
tolerating or considering these things
what we need to recognize is the
scottish parliament has a mandate to
deliver a referendum my message to this
trust is she needs now to sit down with
the first minister of scotland and
negotiate the terms of that referendum
to make sure it can take place and the
timeline that the scottish government
has indicated which is a referendum in
october 2023 i regret that we're having
to go to the supreme court but we're
having to go to the supreme court
because the government in london
wouldn't recognize that people in
scotland have that right to determine
their own future
yeah and the courts will make that
ruling in due course won't they but i
mean i'll pick you up on this mr
blackford you know we've gone from this
sort of reset where you hope that
there's regis which is going to be
better to describing the plan as barking
mad and there's obviously there's a bit
of friction there isn't there and there
is a coming to heads coming to ahead
pretty soon between you guys and the
incoming prime minister well it's about
democracy and it's about fair play and
the idea that you can gerrymander the
rules for a referendum is simply not
right and i think people not just in
scotland right across the united kingdom
will will recognize that and i think
there has to be a degree of common sense
and rationality when we're having these
discussions
now mr blackburn of course this trust
says she wants to keep the union
together and that is her stated position
so
i mean how do you expect this to play
out
i i respect anybody that wants to argue
the case for the union and they should
do that and that's a a much more
rational debate whether it's liz trust
or the scottish conservatives or
scottish labour let them lay out their
case as to how they see scotland in the
union and i want to have that debate
because i want to be able to showcase
what we can deliver with independence i
want to make sure that we can accelerate
our green energy production and to do
that for the purpose of making sure that
we can generate the investment that's
required to deliver a green industrial
future for scotland of course we need to
deal with the problems for brexit and
we're paying a price for that and for us
i mean the clear demonstration of the
will of the people of scotland is to be
back in the european union so i look
forward to having that debate let's have
that respectful debate of what is in the
best interest of the people of scotland
but let's not have this this silly
debate about changing the electoral
rules let's treat people with respect
actually let's have that debate about
how we improve the lives of people that
live in the country of scotland
okay uh ian blackford the s p's leader
in westminster appreciate your time this
morning sir thank you for being with us
thank you
all right well that was of course the
view of people from scotland let's cross
to northern ireland now where of course
uh the incoming prime minister is going
to face well i'm actually being told we
can't go to northern ireland so let's
bring in the historic historian anthony
selden for an overview of what we've
heard this morning what we can expect to
come in coming hours days months and
weeks of course ahead uh anthony seldon
good to have you with us this morning um
thanks for being with us um your
reflections first on boris johnson's
final address to the nation
well um interesting about
that reference to cincinnatus wasn't it
my memory but i may be wrong is that
cincinnatus returned now if that is
indeed correct boris johnson wouldn't
have made a mistake with that and that
is would be one of the if not the most
provocative uh farewell statements ever
uttered by a prime minister outside
downing street about their intention to
come
back
so who knows uh that needs to be uh
stress tested but it wasn't a contrite
speech was it i think boris johnson
would have done better to have
acknowledged
the problems in the economy uh with the
unions uh with the cost of living
it it wasn't uh it was the kind of
speech that one would have delivered
before one came to power full of the
things one was going to do
rather than a dignified
speech on exit so i think he will
reflect
um
and maybe think that he would have been
wiser to have been a a more
compassionate uh and thoughtful and
considered speech rather than a
booster-ish one that's just my sense of
it
fascinating so anthony i mean thank you
for clearing that up when i was uh
crouching down here listening to that i
heard returned to my plan which i guess
we kind of get to the same point that
he's left it open that he wants to
return it at some point in the future i
mean
you have of course uh reflected on boris
johnson's premiership and the way that
it's affected the sort of democratic
processes in this country i mean how do
you think he's going to be viewed by
history
in in 10 years time
well in 10 or 50 or 100 years time he
will be viewed as the person who got
brexit done and uh that therefore
put to bed a
terrible three years of indecision after
the referendum whatever people thought
of brexit the country clearly voted for
brexit and clearly it had to happen he
got that achieved he did win a landslide
prime minister's rarely achieve
landslides uh some 20 or less in the
whole entire history of the premiership
the question that historians will want
to know is did he make the most of that
incredible opportunity he had in
december 2019 to remake britain to get
brexit done to show all the benefits to
level up the country uh to make it
fairer more prosperous uh and to have
that rebirth of britain as a
sovereign country outside europe
they'll also reflect on covid
and people will always argue about covid
but there were many positives not least
the vaccine roll out and they'll
remember his very strong and i think
very personal stance uh on uh the
ukraine so there are many uh positives
there and it's everything with boris
johnson it's all in technicolor in
bright lights uh some very strong
positives and some equally very strong
negatives more flaws indeed in his
character than uh the london shard which
he uh which oversaw city hall where he
had been mayor for eight years
comparing his character to the london
chancellor anderson seldon
always with a turn of phrase we
appreciate your time more from you i
hope throughout the morning thank you
very much for that for now but um we can
now
cross to northern ireland where of
course the incoming prime minister is
going to face a bunch of challenges uh
not least um working out how to make
brexit work and let's bring in david
blevins who is in northern ireland for
us this morning david good morning again
to you so just take us through uh she
got a huge intro facing her when she
walked into number 10 but she got
another
mountain of problems facing her in
northern ireland
yes and wasn't it interesting this
morning to hear boris johnson talk about
having got brexit done and sir anthony
there describing that as his legacy but
as far as northern ireland is concerned
brexit isn't done because there's still
such dispute over the brexit trading
arrangement that established a border in
the irish sea to avoid there being a
need for one on this island in fact that
northern ireland protocol is the reason
the unionists will not return to the
power sharing government here at
stormont three months after the election
so there is no devolved government i
remember it was shin fein who won that
election and they say that liz trust
needs to stop pandering to the dup needs
to get stormed back up and running
because there are more pressing concerns
like the cost of living crisis so we
expect the new prime minister to be here
very quickly to try and address this
political vacuum but it isn't going to
be an easy issue to resolve quickly
david blevins and stormwind appreciate
that thank you very much for that
reporting all right let's go back of
course to the only story this morning
that we're discussing english trusts is
about to become prime minister today
after winning the conservative
leadership contest she's the uk's fourth
prime minister in just over six years
and someone knows plenty about working
inside that building and dealing with
prime ministers the former director of
communications at number 10 that is
alistair campbell esther campbell good
morning to thank you very much for being
with us let me start you off by getting
you to reflect on what you heard from
boris johnson earlier
well i look he arrived in that building
as a as a liar and a fantasist and he's
leaving it as a liar and a fantasist i
mean the the disconnect
between the country that he was
describing and the country that he has
actually helped to preside over was
enormous
and you know you just heard there from
david blevins his big claim about
getting brexit done brexit in northern
ireland he's proven to be something of a
catastrophe and the chances are that
list trust has got no plan to deal with
that so look boris johnson has always
been about boosterism he's always been
about the fancy line he's always been
about getting people to talk about his
you know superficial knowledge of greek
mythology and all the rest of it the
country is in a worse state than it was
when he took over you can't get a
passport you can't get a driving test
you've got industrial action and all the
stuff that's happening that i accept
that covid was very difficult the war in
ukraine was very difficult but these are
things that prime ministers have to deal
with that is their job what we've had
from boris johnson is the systematic
debasing of this of our standards in
public life the debasing of the office
the debasing and undermining of the rule
of law and not a hint of humility or
contrition as he left not any acceptance
even talking about the rules being
changed rather than the fact that his
party finally faced up to the fact that
they put in a liar and a charlatan
inside downing street so i'm afraid he
left exactly as he arrived as somebody
who should never have been there in the
first place
all right
thank you for that mr campbell now just
tell us about the challenges that then
will be facing uh liz trust not not just
in the politics and the policies but i
want to talk about the the running of
the number 10 operation of course you
famously ran a a pretty tight ship um
with uh sir tony blair so what kind of
um running of number 10 do you think
you'll see from this trust it's very
hard to work out because i don't know
that well um those people who work for
her before i do a podcast with rory
stewart who was one of her ministers and
the impression you get from people who
have worked closely with her
is that she
tends to ignore advice she tends to
adapt fairly sort of idiosyncratic
approach to policy making and decision
making but we'll have to see i think
there was a very interesting interview
yesterday with gus o'donnell the former
cabinet secretary and he made i think a
very important point
since frankly
right through the 12 years of this
government there has been
a fairly systematic undermining of the
civil service and i think if she had any
sense at all she would put a stop to
that she's facing massive challenges
she's going to need the support of the
civil service and i think she should do
two things one try to bring her divided
party together if the reports of the the
reported
cabinet new cabinet are true then she's
clearly not going to do that and the
second thing is to understand that she
won't be able to do that much unless she
gets the civil service machine up and
running properly so it will depend on
her personality but i i do think that
our experience of the civil service was
if you give them clear direction they
know genuinely what your priorities are
you trust them and you respect them to
work with them properly then you can get
a lot done if she goes in and just does
the same gaslighting and populism
approach that we've seen from johnson
then i'm pretty sure that she'll fail
and she'll fail pretty quickly
i mean but don't you have any options in
that she would have learned from those
mistakes i mean we sure boys johnson
have to replace his team two or three
times because of errors and judgment
areas that um he put in place himself so
you can't expect this trust to having
having seen that with the team around
her to make those similar mistakes and
perhaps she will reinvigorate the civil
service
well the only thing i'd say about that
is that i
it has been extraordinary to watch this
this leadership contest over the last
few weeks where they seem to have
forgotten that they got rid of boris
johnson because he was becoming a
catastrophically bad leader liz truss
has spent most of her leadership
campaign and indeed her speech yesterday
saying what a marvelous prime minister
he was and how he quotes got the big
calls right and so forth she she is
carrying on to my mind with a policy
where she accepts that she is dishonest
about a lot of the things that she says
and does
she says for example just to give you
one example that came out through the
thing she says the whole time that she's
going to be straight with people and
level with people and yet at the same
time refuses to acknowledge that brexit
is causing any difficulties in relation
to northern ireland or in relation to
trading and so forth so these big
problems she's got to face up to the
reality of the problems not the
mythology of the conservative party and
i think that she's actually she's become
you know
my friend janaga fjortof the
ex-footballer he actually tweeted
recently this is
beginning to look a bit like doris
johnson she tells lies she gaslights she
doesn't actually confront the problem
that's in front of her she confronts the
problem that she wants to see in front
of her that is not a way to govern the
country
okay alistair campbell you're always
talking about if you're talking listen
to your podcasts and yeah you bring him
up every chance you get thank you very
much for your analysis thank you
all the rest is politics
i already got a plugin for his podcast
as well maybe she should have mentioned
it tomorrow all right just reflect on
what we've had for the past hour or so
we've heard boris johnson's a farewell
speech as the campbell thinks it was
completely unapologetic there was no
sort of sense of humility
nick boris johnson's critics say that he
has played fast and loose with the truth
uh you know that labour politicians say
he's demeaned the office of prime
minister with everything he did
partygate and so on but there's little
doubt that boris johnson as he dwells on
his speech there
has a force of personality which we will
remember for a long time he won an
80-seat majority against all the odds he
realigned politics effectively winning
over seats that had been labor for
decades and yes that is a challenge to
liz trust would you hold that all
together but
he changed politics in a major way he is
a prime minister of consequence although
he either let it slip from his grasp or
had it pulled from his grasp desperately
unfairly depending on who you talk to i
thought you heard in his speech he
couldn't resist a dig at his colleagues
turned out to be a relay race he said
and they changed the rules halfway
through we didn't hear much humility or
remorse as alistair campbell was saying
that is not boris johnson's style but he
was saying that he it's time for him to
go he will give his fervent support he
said to liz trust i felt like maybe
there was just a hint that he would stay
on the political scene at the end there
talking about cincinnatus the roman
senator who may have made a comeback
historian
is confirmed that cincinnatus did in
fact make a comeback yes
i i would defer to his superior
knowledge on that subject yeah so um
left the door open as we predicted he
may well do i mean i think we can bring
up some of the pictures of the scene
here as he came out because it was there
was a bunch of people the number 10
staff who came outside outside number 11
and then all the conservative
mps down the end there tomorrow and i
was taken with sort of how human it all
fell because every there was some real
sadness actually amongst the people
around can be brutal i mean political
careers
end either you know in on election night
in a town hall at 4 a.m or they end
when you leave downing street your
belongings all been packed up he'd said
goodbye to his staff last week formerly
gone around all the different areas of
number 10 to say goodbye to staff and
that's it as you said that's all folks
him and his wife carrie got into a car
and they will never come back here
barely a backwards glance you're allowed
as you leave office and they after going
to balmoral will be brought back to
london to be dropped off at wherever the
location is that they will begin their
life post office their normal home not
living above the shop if you like with
an army of staff to do everything and i
think prime ministers take a long time
to get over that yes boris johnson has
had a strange couple of months because
we've been in parliamentary recess he's
been on holiday not much has been going
on in parliament as for example it was
you know for theresa may when she
resigned she was busy every day doing
things having state visits and so on so
he's had a couple of months to let it
sink in those close to him say it's been
almost like a grieving process sort of
coming to terms with how it all ended
and
by tonight someone else will be in there
with a new team and they'll be beginning
a new a new era yeah i'll turn a new
chapter in the political dynasty okay
tomorrow i appreciate that thank you
very much that is all from this hour of
scania's breakfast as we watch the car
departing carrying boris johnson and
carrie johnson to raf north fault uh
flanked by outriders the
outgoing prime minister on his way to
scotland to formally tender his
resignation to the queen the jet
carrying him has taken off he saw that
in the last hour and then once he has
resigned liz truss is going to meet the
queen and be asked to form a new
government once she has done that she
will return here to london to downing
street whereas tomorrow said all her
stuff will be in and she will give her
address to the nation stay with plenty
more to come after the break
[Music]
i'm ivan bonio i'm a sailor
i spent half time of my life on the on
the sea
we have a factory we can convert this
plastic to energy
and so after at the end we can minimize
the footprint carbon of the board
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello everyone and good morning from
downing street it is 9 a.m that's it
folks the words of boris johnson earlier
before taking off for scotland where he
will officially tender his resignation
to the queen in his farewell speech he
called on the conservative party to get
behind his success and this trust will
enter number 10 facing the toughest
conditions of any prime minister in
decades now the labour party's angela
rainer accused mr johnson of being
deluded
here's what boris johnson had to say at
around 7 30 a.m
thank you thank well
well this is
this is it folks thank you everybody for
coming out
so early this morning
in only a couple of hours i will be in
balmoral to see her majesty the queen
and the torch will finally be passed to
a new conservative leader
the baton will be handed over in what
does unexpectedly turned out to be a
relay race they changed the rules
halfway through but never mind that now
and through that lacquered black door a
new prime minister will shortly go to
meet a fantastic group of public
servants the people who got brexit done
the people who deliver the fastest
vaccine rollout in europe and never
forget
70 of the entire population got a dose
within six months faster than any
comparable country that is government
for you that's this conservative
government
people
who organized those prompt early
supplies of weapons to the heroic
ukrainian armed forces an action that
may very well have helped change the
course of the biggest european war for
80 years and because of the speed and
urgency of what you did everybody
involved in this government to get this
economy moving again from july last year
in spite of all the opposition
all the naysayers we have
and will continue
to have
that economic strength to give people
the cash they need to get through this
energy crisis that has been caused by
putin's vicious war
and i know
that liz
trus and this compassionate conservative
government will do everything we can to
get people through this crisis and this
country will endure it and we will win
and if putin thinks that he can succeed
by blackmailing or bullying the british
people then he is utterly deluded
and the reason we will have those funds
now and in the future is because we
conservatives understand the vital
symmetry between government action and
free market capitalist private sector
enterprise we're delivering on those
huge manifesto commitments making
streets safer neighborhood crime down 38
in the last three years thirteen
thousand seven hundred ninety more
police on the streets building more
hospitals and yes we will have fifty
thousand more nurses by the end of the
decade and forty more hospitals by the
end of
fifty thousand nurses by the end of this
parliament i should say 40 new hospitals
by the end of the decade putting record
funding into our schools and into
teachers pay giving everybody over 18 a
lifetime skills guarantee so they can
keep up skilling throughout their lives
three new high-speed rail lines three
including northern powerhouse rail
colossal road proud programs from the
pennines to cornwall the rollout of
gigabit broadband up over the last
three years i am proud to say since you
were kind enough to elect me from seven
percent of our country's premises having
gigabit broadband to 70
today and we are of course providing the
short and the long-term solutions for
our energy needs and not just using more
of our own domestic hydrocarbons but
going up by 2030 to 50 gigawatts of wind
power that is half this country's energy
electricity needs from offshore wind
alone a new nuclear reactor every year
and looking at what is happening in this
country the changes that are taking
place that is why private sector
investment is flooding in more private
sector more venture capital investment
than china itself more billion pound
tech companies sprouting here in the uk
that in france germany and israel
combined and as a result
unemployment as i leave office
unemployment down to lows not seen since
i was about 10 years old and bouncing
around on a space hopper my friends and
on on the subject of
on the subject of bouncing around in
future careers
let me say that i am now like one of
those booster rockets
that has fulfilled its function
and i will now be gently re-entering the
atmosphere and splashing down invisibly
in some remote and obscure corner of the
pacific
and
like cincinnatus
i am returning to my plow
and i will be offering this government
nothing but the most fervent support
this is i'll tell you why this is a
tough time for the economy
this is a tough time for families up and
down the country we can and we will get
through it we will come out stronger the
other side
but i say to
my fellow conservatives
it's time for politics to be over folks
it's time for us all to get behind liz
trust and her team and her program
and deliver for the people of this
country
because that is what the people of this
country want that's what they need
and that's what they deserve
i'm proud
to have discharged the promises i made
to my party when you were kind enough to
choose me winning the biggest majority
since 1987 the biggest share of the vote
since 1979 delivering brexit delivering
our manifesto commitments including by
the way including social care reforming
social care helping people up and down
the country ensuring that britain is
once again standing tall in the world
speaking with clarity and authority
from ukraine to the orcas pact with
america and
australia because we are one whole and
entire united kingdom whose diplomats
security services and armed forces
are so globally admired and by the way
as i believe as i leave i believe our
union is so strong that those who want
to break it up they'll keep trying but
they will never ever succeed
thank you to everybody
behind me in this building
thank you to all of you in government uh
thank you everyone who's helped look
after me and my family over the last
three years including
including dylan
the dog
and i just say to my party of dylan and
larry
can put behind them their occasional
difficulties then so can the
conservative party
above all thanks to you
the british people to the voters for
giving me the chance to serve all of you
who work so tirelessly together
to beat covid to put us where we are
today
together we have laid foundations that
will stand the test of time whether by
taking back control of our laws or
putting in vital new infrastructure
great solid masonry on which we will
continue to build together
paving paving the path
of prosperity now and for future
generations and i will be supporting liz
truss and the new government every step
of the way thank you all very much thank
you and goodbye thank you
[Applause]
boris johnson they're taking about seven
minutes and 40 seconds to sum up uh
three and a bit years of a premiership
um
this is the live picture now from raf
north folds uh just a short while ago we
saw the jets that we believe was
carrying boris johnson up to balmoral
departs and this is the second jet that
will be carrying the incoming
prime minister liz truss who will go to
balmoral to meet the queen once uh the
queen has finished speaking to mr
johnson as you can see there the uh
steps just folding up on to that jet so
it'll be uh do they still do trucks away
but that jet will be
taxing around the runway and this trust
will be making her way to balmoral very
shortly and she will likely be there
meeting the queen at around lunchtime
before coming back to london to give
her remarks to the nation
now of course the opposition parties had
this morning responded to what they
heard from boris johnson in that speech
that he gave earlier and our political
correspondent tomorrow cohen is with us
to reflect on what we heard now tomorrow
we heard um from all the opposition
parties uh thus far this morning let's
first pick up when we heard from the
labour party um deputy leader angela
rainer speaking to me earlier and making
it very clear that what she heard from
boris johnson
really just laid out how sort of out of
touch she felt he is with what's
actually happening in the country
the opposition parties have been gunning
for boris johnson for a long time and
then two months ago of course after his
conservative colleagues turned on him he
was forced from office i think they will
be reflecting on whether
his successor liz trust will be an
easier or more difficult opponent for
them
is she tainted by what happened during
boris johnson's time in office not of
course by partygate or anything that
happened with chris pincher towards the
end but with serving in his government
liz trust was obviously loyal to boris
johnson to the end and i'm sure we're
going to hear from opposition parties
starting from wednesday at prime
minister's questions something about
that and trying to
trying to pin that on liz trust if you
like but they know this is a new era
she's going to have a very different
style
boris johnson sort of bombastic colorful
language we're not going to see very
much of that i think from liz trust and
so it was the end of an era when he made
his final speech here and then went off
to balmoral and the opposition parties
had their final go at him as he was
leaving saying that uh what he'd said
was out of touch with reality this is
what angela rainer told us
it was a classic boris johnson speech
completely deluded about what's happened
over the last couple of years and the
crisis that people are facing there is
no acknowledgement of how the scandal
and sleaze that has engulfed his party
and his government over the last couple
of years whether that was him supporting
the scandal around owen patterson
supporting chris pincher with the
situation with sexual harassment whether
that was the absolute billions of pounds
that was wasted on money that was given
to mates
through the global pandemic and of
course the partying that happened when
the uk public were told that they had to
go into lockdown and had to follow the
rules i think it was completely deluded
and it stunk of all the hallmarks of
somebody who's had a privileged
background who thinks that they can just
do what they like
yeah angela they're not holding back on
what she thought about boris johnson but
definitely actually avoiding the
question whether she thought that it
would a bit of an electoral asset that
boris johnson was for the labour party
and difficult challenge now with liz
trust as you mentioned and that debut of
course has been speaking about the boris
johnson legacy and what he heard from
his speech this morning
yes the labour party
towards the end
talked about how they didn't mind if
boris johnson stayed in power in the
sense that they felt it was good for
them but i think
some of them would acknowledge that he
was a very difficult opponent it was
always very difficult to pin any
criticism on him and sometimes kirstama
would say things particularly about his
integrity and sort of failed to land the
blows will they find liz trust an easier
opponent it depends whether she gets a
boost in the polls from whatever it is
that is in her energy package
liberal democrat leader ed davey also
talking about some of what boris johnson
said and look
he knows that people will take issue
with the 40 new hospitals that he says
will be built by the end of the decade
and whether they really are knew the 50
000 nurses he promised to recruit they
are some of the way there but they will
say that look he's giving a list of the
things that he has not achieved
reforming social care i mean i think the
sector would dispute some of that this
is what ed davey the lib dem leader had
to say
what boris johnson failed to
mention was our economy is in a mess
we
are the lowest growth projections of any
industrial country bar russia
energy bills are going through the roof
people are really worried about food
prices they're worried about the crisis
in the nhs
and that's all happened under his
premiership
thank you very much
yeah the opposition parties they're
laying out very clearly is what they
think about boris johnson we heard also
from ian blackford the leader of the snp
here in westminster and and there there
is a real issue that's going to be
coming to a head very very soon for uh
liz trust when she takes over and this
is the case of scottish independence
it's going to go to the supreme court
but there's reporting this morning this
trust has a plan to try and make it more
difficult for them to go for a second
referendum that's right i mean ian
blackford the westminster leader of the
smp and boris johnson always enjoyed a
bit of knockabout in parliament and i
think the snp saw boris johnson as a
real electoral asset for them he was
unpopular in scotland the scottish
conservatives often found it quite
difficult to justify some of what he
said and did and often tried to distance
themselves from him i'm sure they'll be
hoping that liz trust similarly puts her
foot in it yes we are expecting a
supreme court ruling on whether nicholas
sturgeon's plan to have an independence
referendum without permission from
westminster next october can go ahead or
not so that is in her bulging in tray as
well as of course the northern ireland
brexit arrangements and various other
important constitutional issues to do
with the union this is what ian
blackford told us about his views on the
handover of power
well let me say it's barking mad it's i
think what we refer to as gerrymandering
when you stand for an election and when
you have a referendum you put your case
you encourage the electorate to vote and
of course you want to have the highest
turnout possible but the idea that
somehow or other you can change the
rules
i think people in scotland whether or
not they agree with us or not are going
to reflect on what is you know a silent
behavior which is just completely
unacceptable
he's one of the leaders that liz trust
will be up against in her first prime
minister's questions on wednesday it's
all happening really fast she is at raf
northalt at the moment we saw those
pictures she will be meeting the queen
at balmoral just after boris johnson he
goes in he leaves liz trust goes in is
has the ceremony with the queen the
kissing hand ceremony will become prime
minister we'll come down here we'll hear
from her this afternoon she'll appoint
her cabinet straight to the house of
commons tomorrow there is really no let
up and we will be hearing pretty soon
about what the energy bill support
package that she will unveil is and she
knows that her reputation will depend on
it being seen as rising to the scale of
the challenge may come thursday as well
so it's really all happening really
quickly isn't it it may she said that
she would act within a week and i'm
hearing that we will hear the details of
it on thursday the there are various
serious options that are in contention
and one of her senior cabinet allies
said to me that the new cabinet would
have to sign it off on wednesday at
their first cabinet meeting so
if she does freeze energy bills which
her team have been discussing that is
something the energy companies have put
forward exactly how it will work what
the threshold will be will businesses be
involved as well as households and
crucially how much it will cost and
where they get the money from if she
remains averse to windfall taxes all of
that will need to be worked out this is
going to be complicated and it's going
to have implications of course for other
areas of government
analysis when it does happen right
tomorrow thank you very much for that
now as we're looking at these pictures
of the jet there on the tarmac at raf
north vault we believe that is carrying
the incoming prime minister liz trust
who is on her way up to balmoral now
about half an hour or so ago
the um current prime minister boris
johnson left um in a similar looking jet
from raf norfolk on his way to barumore
let's go there now live where our royal
correspondent leonardo mills is standing
by for us so rihanna and i can confirm
boris johnson is in the air he's on his
way up to balmoral to take us through
what's going to happen when he
eventually arrives up there
yeah already this morning is looking so
different isn't it from what we have
seen throughout the queen's 70 year
reign in terms of this power handover
usually it would all be happening where
you are in that short distance between
number 10 and buckingham palace and all
happen within such a short space of time
so usually under two hours and it's all
done and dusted we have a new prime
minister but as you say we currently
have an outgoing prime minister in the
air at the moment heading to aberdeen
and it has to be said because of the
good old scottish weather certainly the
weather here in the highlands plans have
already had to change this morning
things have been moved slightly earlier
so it's meant that boris johnson is now
on his way to try and i think miss some
of those those storms and make sure that
he gets here at 10 past 11 because
rather than having a helicopter to take
him from aberdeen airport here to
balmoral we are anticipating that it's
going to be a car journey instead which
will probably take
about an hour or so yesterday apparently
they were they were practicing how that
police convoy uh was going to work but i
think for all sides involved whether
it's the outgoing the incoming prime
minister and the palace as well it was
basically decided last week that from
practical terms it was all going to
happen here we know that the queen is
still having those mobility issues and
wanted to make sure that
whatever was planned was actually going
to happen if the queen got up this
morning didn't feel entirely well then
plans weren't going to have to be ripped
up we know that she did in this earlier
in the summer probably intend to travel
down to london but 96 years old it was
decided that everyone else instead is
going to travel up here in terms of the
formalities of what's going to happen
yes it's going to have a very different
look a very different feel i think a
different kind of intimacy happening
here at balmoral but we wait and see
exactly how it all unfolds later we are
expecting pictures of boris johnson
arriving liz trust arriving and liz
trust then leaving as prime minister
yeah and we'll be back to you for that
when that does happen
rhiannon appreciate that thank you very
much for now these uh as you can see the
latest pictures from raf north of that j
it's still waiting on the tar back um
before it does begin attacking and
making its way up to balmoral the flight
takes uh probably just uh just over an
hour to get up there and once uh this
trust gets up there she will meet the
queen and officially become our prime
minister now let me just bring you these
pictures that have been released by the
number 10 press office in the past hour
or so i wanted a little flash
photography in these now this is the
scene inside number 10 now of course the
press pack was assembled outside
as we were waiting for this moment for
boris johnson and carrie johnson to come
up but you can see them here walking
through the halls of number 10 being
clapped flanked by the staff of number
10. the final walk through those halls
for the johnsons before
boris came out and delivered his
farewell address to the nation and it
was a quite an emotional scene as i was
saying to tomorrow earlier what was
really most sort of affecting by it was
the people that had been around boris
johnson through all of this through the
ups and downs the past few years
seem to be deeply
affected by the fact that despite him
having that 80 seat majority back in
2019 he is now leaving office before his
term is out
all right well let's just bring in
um someone who is still in government
for now uh simon clark who is currently
chief secretary to the treasury and it
was an early supporter of this trust
incoming prime minister simon clark good
morning to you and thank you very much
for being with us so
i wonder if you can clear up some of the
reporting that we're getting this
morning about this package that's being
prepared some 100 billion pounds to help
people deal with their energy bills
well what i can say is that liz truss
recognizes completely the urgency of the
situation facing households
and businesses during the autumn and
winter ahead and that will there will be
a major intervention to help provide
clarity and comfort that the government
is is on people's side uh in the days
ahead uh and we we hope to deliver that
uh during the course of this first week
of liz being our prime minister it's
it's something where uh the country is
obviously looking for for early
reassurance we're going to provide that
i mean yeah many people have asking for
reassurance for the past couple of
months mr clark haven't they uh now
we've got these reports this trust will
be here in a few hours time giving her
first address
to the nation so the reports we're
seeing this morning are they not true
can you tell us that
i'm afraid i can't comment on the
specifics of of of the plans it's not
for me to do that today you wouldn't
expect me to liz has not yet even got
the keys uh to downing street but it is
absolutely the case that people can be
reassured there will be early action on
this as part of liz's government and it
will literally as i say be a matter of
days
it'll be something of that magnitude
won't it mr clark and and this reporting
seems to be focused on households
what will be done to help businesses
i i can't comment on the specifics of
the of the package as i say but it will
embrace both households and businesses
and it's something which the government
is determined to help
deliver as a matter of
the utmost priority because uh without
this frankly we can't we can't do the
rest of our work and there is there is a
whole lot
more to be done but until we've
addressed cost of living and then
clearly there is uh that there isn't
going to be space to do that so this is
this is the top priority of liz's uh
first first days in office
now your chief secretary of the tragedy
so you have been in office while we've
been waiting for a plan to be laid out
and i'm sure the work has been done to
try and get this paid for can you give
me your preferred way of making sure
that whatever package is paid for um
gets funded
that's a very tempting question but uh
the full detail of the package including
uh not just how it will operate but how
it will be funded will be set out in in
the days ahead as i said i simply cannot
uh preempt that i do think viewers will
understand that there is there are going
to be answers very very soon but it's
not for this interview for me to to set
those out
i mean they will understand that mr
cloud but they'll also be very
frustrated i think you can't give us any
sort of a sense of the scale of this
because it's a huge challenge that we're
facing um but i'll i'll take your
answers this morning and we'll move on
just give us a sense of what kind of
prime minister you think we'll see in
liz trust and what kind of operation
she'll run out of number 10 i think
we'll see someone who is uh
thoughtful uh evidence-led uh tough
uh and and resilient and and you know
liz has a focus as she set out in her
speech yesterday on delivery for the
british people there is there is an
urgent need whether that be the
short-term uh challenges that we know we
face with cost of living through to the
long-term issues like facing down
russia's invasion of ukraine or uniting
and leveling up this country uh and liz
will bring the same uh urgency of of
action and the same clarity of thought
to to the job of prime minister that
she's brought to successive roles where
she's made a huge uh success of them
whether that be as foreign secretary as
trade secretary uh justice or
environment or treasury or education liz
has served across government over the
last 12 years and has made a success
wherever she's been the focus clearly uh
is going to be on uh making sure that
all of her ministers are delivering the
same way
yeah and talking about her ministers
then the discussion yesterday was when
we saw the reports of what the cabinet
would be made up of that it's really
from one side of the party from the
right of the party are you confident
that when you see the cabinet laid out
that it's going to be a show the broad
sort of depth of the um conservative
party and have a range of opinions well
there's been a uh there's been a lot of
speculation about uh who's going to be
in the new government as there always uh
understandably is uh liz will form a
government which draws on talent right
from across the conservative party but
it will obviously be of people who are
strongly behind her agenda of delivering
a focus on growth on making sure that
this country's public services work
and that we are a strong voice
for freedom and democracy abroad those
are her priorities as prime minister and
uh it will be a government clearly that
enables her to deliver that
okay simon cloud chief secretary
treasury i appreciate your time this
morning even though you didn't tell us
what the plan is going to be i'm sure
we'll get you back on again and maybe
get the plan for you eventually thank
you thank you
all right let's bring enough political
correspondent tomorrow cones listening
into simon clark they're chief sexist
treasurer you wouldn't tell me anything
about the plans i had to wait more time
a few days he said in the coming days we
expect it will be thursday but there was
something that i did say was there will
be significant support to households and
when you ask them about this businesses
as well because we've seen all these
businesses posting their energy bills
aren't capped posting these pictures of
twenty thousand thirty thousand pounds a
year for energy and saying where's our
support from the government if liz trust
is to help businesses with their energy
bills that is going to be even more
expensive labor's proposed energy bill
price freeze for six months they put it
30 billion to that 60 billion a year if
she tries to freeze energy bills at the
current level which is just under 2 000
pounds we don't know if that's what
she's going to do but if she tries to do
that for a couple of years until the
next election we're already looking at
well over 100 billion before you can
bring in businesses so look the options
are all expensive
we know that some of the conservatives
supporting her for the leadership would
rather she targeted support to
particular people pensioners people on
benefits
it's clear to her and her team that
support will need to go far wider than
that just as it was clear to boris
johnson and his former chancellor rishi
sunak that people
who are not just in those groups will
struggle and will need government
support
is there a way a middle way there where
you help some people more than others
these are the difficult decisions her
cabinet will need to sign off on
wednesday and whether or not this is
seen as successful is going to set the
tone for her time in office appreciate
that samara and someone who might well
have an opinion on that middleware that
tomorrow was suggesting that is uh paul
johnson from the institute for physical
studies who i'm pleased to say we'll be
speaking to
after the break plenty more to come here
throughout the morning on sky news
[Music]
[Music]
all right let's take you now live again
to raf norfolk where as you can see the
jet is now taxiing on its way to
balmoral in scotland it's carrying this
trust the incoming prime minister who
will be going up to scotland to meet her
majesty the queen now the ceremony is
called the kissing of the hands when she
is officially appointed prime minister
but as we've been telling you throughout
the morning there will be no kissing of
hands it's going to be a formal meeting
where uh the trust will be as to form
the next government um that plane is
currently waiting for clearance i guess
to take off
once this trust has finished in scotland
she will jet her way back down here to
london where we can expect her to give
her first address to the nation from
downing street sometime this afternoon
now as tradition dictates it's usually
done from a election as we saw foreign
outside but the weather forecast is not
great so there may be a slight change of
plans but of course so i will let you
know where we can expect to see um this
trust now boris johnson has just arrived
in the past couple of minutes in
scotland he'll be on his way to balmoral
as rhiannon was telling us a short while
ago where he will formally tend to his
resignation
to her majesty the queen and the
handover of power will begin
all right let's uh bring in now the uh
director of the institute for fiscal
studies that's paul johnson who were
just discussing just before the break uh
tomorrow was laying out paul whether
there is a middle way to to get some of
this funded to make sure the maximum
amount of health can be given to people
to help with their energy bills and
what's your analysis of what you've
heard
um in the reporting is the plan being
proposed
well it looks like uh we're going to get
a huge intervention to fix energy bills
at some level maybe their current level
maybe a bit more maybe
a bit less um that's uh i mean that is a
big bazooka as it were to
ensure that nobody loses out through
higher
energy prices now that's incredibly
expensive 100 billion pounds plus i mean
that's that we're talking kuvid style
levels of intervention actually quite a
lot more than we spent
on the furlough scheme um the
it's a terrible policy but it may be the
only one that's available it's a
terrible policy because it's so
expensive because it gives lots of money
to people um who don't need it and
actually i think if if the price doesn't
go up we've got more risk of rationing
and shortages
but it's very hard to think of other
ways of getting support to all of the
people who are actually going to need it
because the alternative of trying to
focus support on people who need it
probably means missing out millions and
leaving them in really serious problems
yeah just explain that in a bit more
detail then if you can uh paul
how because there's been a lot of talk
of that we could have this as targeted
support for people on universal credit
but just explain why that may well mean
as you say lots of people who are low
earners would potentially miss out on
that help
well the problem in a sense is that
because energy bills are going up from
not much more than an average of a
thousand pounds or so a year ago
probably to 5 000 pounds
by we get the time we get through to
the january that's not going to be
difficult just for people on mean sets
of benefits on universal credit and so
on that's going to be a real problem for
a lot of people who are not in the
benefit system or on modest kinds of
earnings 20 30 even 40 000 pounds um a
year
and some of those will have energy bills
or more
than 5 000 pounds a year after this now
targeting that really quite large group
through the benefit system is really
hard because they're not on benefits
targeting them through the tax system is
also extremely difficult and targeting
just them through energy bills is
something that's pretty hard to do
because the energy companies of course
don't know what the incomes are of the
people and who they're supplying energy
to
and that's why i say i think the
overall
an overall energy price freeze is
something to be avoided at pretty much
all costs but we may be at the point
where the cost of not freezing the
energy bills will be higher than the
cost of doing so
yeah and you described it as a bazook
and you say it might well be the only
course of action but there are
differences of opinions about how it's
going to be paid for the opposition
parties i want there to be an increase
in in the windfall tax the government
and energy companies are talking about
essentially a loan system where energy
companies are loaned extra money to make
sure that they can then freeze the
prices and that money is then paid back
um over over time i mean of those two
methods which is your favorite method uh
for you mr johnson
well
a windfall tax is clearly not going to
come close to being uh adequate to pay
for this i mean you cannot get a hundred
billion pounds out of a couple of energy
uh companies that would be that are
making the big profits you can get
a small number of tens of billions so
you can get some way towards it but only
a small minority
of the way uh towards it um i'm not
either terribly convinced by the idea of
doing this through loans to
energy companies i think the idea there
is that we all pay this back over a very
long period through higher
energy bills well um whether we don't
know when energy prices are going to go
down we don't know what level of
additional spending people are going to
be able and willing to do
seems
a much more straightforward way of doing
this which i understand is not
politically attractive is to say that
this will be paid back over five or ten
years
through slightly higher income tax rates
for example uh that means uh for example
those of us who are
getting this help who don't really need
it those on relatively high incomes
will pay back more in the longer run and
that uh that will seem to me to be a
straightforward uh affair and a
relatively um
transparent way of paying for this i do
worry that we'll end up getting into
all sorts of clever clever financial
instruments which make it look like this
isn't government borrowing make it look
like we're not really paying for it but
in the end it really is government
borrowing it's government back borrowing
and in the end uh we may end up having
to bail the energy companies out in any
case
yeah and that's where it would seem to
to end up wouldn't it mr johnson i mean
is there any other way around this other
than to just have all that
a massive increase in government
borrowing
well in the short run if this is the
policy that's going to be followed it's
going to have to be done through big
government borrowing in the short run
just as we did big government borrowing
to cover the cost of covid
um in the short run so i don't think
there's any way around that if this is
the kind of policy that's going to be uh
that's going to be pursued but i think
it's really important that we're honest
about that it's also important to
distinguish this kind of policy which we
hope will be relatively
short-term it's a one-off cost to the
government it's a one-off increase in
debt that's a different sort of thing to
for example the big tax cuts
that the new prime minister is proposing
that's a permanent and long-term cost
uh to the public finances and in the end
they may quote only cost 30 billion a
year but that's a lot more in the long
run than a one-off hundred billion
pounds uh which is not repeated
yeah and let me just uh strontium just
wait there for me for a moment let's
just tell our viewers what we're
watching here on the left-hand side you
can see the jet raf more thought
carrying the incoming prime minister and
this trust
as wheels up on its way to
the sea
the queen to officially become prime
minister and on the right hand side
there that's the jet that left
north fault um you know about 45 minutes
to an hour before um this trusted yet
that one is carrying the current prime
minister boris johnson
aberdeen airport there and the vehicle
has just arrived that will take mr
johnson to drive from aberdeen to bamron
where he will officially resign as prime
minister so we're just watching uh one
prime minister go and another one on its
on their way uh paul johnson is still
with us um for more on the economic
situation facing the incoming prime
minister liz trust uh and paul johnson
during the campaign there was a lot of
talk by this trust about this um fiscal
event an emergency budget that she was
going to bring in that would lay out how
um any borrowing that was needed was
going to be paid for and how any help
for customers dealing with their energy
bills was going to to come about and
there was discussion about the office of
budget responsibility not having the
time to do the work i mean
in your analysis was that correct that
the obr wouldn't have had the time to do
the work necessary for these plans to be
in place
well i don't think what we're going to
have is a formal emergency budget i
think we'll have
yet another of these big fiscal spending
events that we've had dozens of over the
last two or three years and they've on
the whole not come with obr forecast now
we know because the obr has told us that
they are in a position to provide
an economic update and forecast of where
the public finances will be
so i think it'd be quite helpful uh to
have transparently in the public domain
the obr's view of
where the public finances are and what
the consequences would be
of some of these policies now they won't
have a lot of time to look at the
specific policies that are being
proposed but for example
if we're looking at a cut to the
national insurance rate or the
corporation tax rate or an increase in
the um or support for energy bills those
are pretty straightforward numbers to
come up with and plug into the public
finance numbers they've already done
so i know that the obr are willing and
ready to provide these numbers the
question is uh will the new chancellor
ask them uh to provide these numbers
yeah i guess we'll find that out in the
next few days okay paul johnson from the
institute for fiscal studies to
appreciate your time this morning thanks
very much for that analysis always
worthwhile
all right well viewers you are still
watching that uh jet carrying the prime
minister boris johnson uh on the timeout
there at the airport in aberdeen if
you're paying close attention you would
have seen the luxury vehicles
them up to balmoral where boris johnson
is going to formally attend his
resignation to the queen beginning
the process of the transfer of power
now the incoming prime minister liz
trusts of course grew up in leeds so
it's worth going back to her hometown to
get a sense from people there what
they're expecting from the next prime
minister and uh correspondent fraser
moore is in at least for us right now
good morning again to you fraser so just
just tell us from those you've spoken to
this morning over the past few days what
are they expecting to hear and we'll
just trust
office and gives us that speech in
downtreatment
yeah we're here at martin market in the
heart of the city and i think people are
wanting liz trust to listen to them
before she makes any key decisions we're
here to find out what it's going to mean
to the business community what they want
to hear no better person to ask than
james mason who's the ceo of the west
and north yorkshire chamber of commerce
james what is it that businesses want to
hear from liz trust this week well they
want some certainty they want to know
that they can operate into next week
into next month into next year and
they're really well we've spoken to a
few this morning especially at coffee
shop lanes just down the road in leeds
they need to know that their electricity
bill their energy bill is going to be
affordable
we're hearing quotes of fourteen
thousand pound this year forty five
thousand pound next year businesses
cannot survive these prices so we need
the new prime minister and what an
opportunity to freeze prices for
domestic customers and business
customers
in terms of what it means to businesses
i mean that lack of certainty about fuel
costs and so on uh we're hearing now
that they could be capped but then many
businesses have already committed to to
longer-term contracts haven't they try
and avoid the uncertainty that's exactly
the problem at the moment you're fishing
around for the best price you're going
to take what you can and that might be
an extortionate price but you'll take it
so you can lock it in the problem then
is with the cap is you're locked in for
the next year so potentially grants a
reduction in vat would help especially
in hospitality
off gem give them more powers to
restrict these energy suppliers um
creating millions and billions of pounds
so businesses really need immediate help
from the prime minister and what an
opportunity for her to put a mark in the
sound this week
in terms of what she's going to do she
says that she's got a bold plan how bold
does it need to be to get the economy
back up and running well it needs to be
bold she said she'll deliver delivered
deliver this needs to be a
once-in-a-lifetime
mark in the sand and bold can be many
things but i think now she's got to
really take a stand and support
businesses there's two there's two sides
of this coin support businesses with
loans and grants etc or actually commit
to long-term sustainability any business
that goes out of
extinction this week means jobs losses
means mortgage is going down the pan
means that the hinterland of other
businesses are splashing all failing so
she's really got to make a big bold move
this week okay thanks james you get out
of the rain i know you're a busy man
today so a bold plan is needed that's
what we want to hear here in west
yorkshire north yorkshire as well from
james who's the ceo of the chamber of
trade for there as well businesses want
some certainty and they certainly need
some help with those energy bills
yeah big bold moves in there she did say
in that speech yesterday that she will
deliver so we'll wait to find out how
she plans to do that phrase up thank you
for now all right let's get a little
more reaction uh to what we've heard
this morning by bringing in uh joe
tanner now she is a former advisor to
boris johnson and joins us now live good
morning to you joe thank you very much
for being with us you will have listened
to boris johnson's speech i mean where
did you put that in the chart of his
speech is it classic boris
well there was there were elements
weren't there always elements of classic
boris whenever he speaks and i think it
was a better speech than perhaps when um
it was first clear that he was leaving
office um i felt then there was a there
was the issue about the herd moving and
it just sounded
a little it didn't seem to hit the right
spot to me that day but i think today
was was the right message the right tone
and um
support for liz who's got a very
difficult job coming in
yeah but as
a commentator eventually no sort of
humility no sort of
sorry again for for the way that it's
played out
yeah i think that would have been nice
to have seen but i think from his
perspective he'll have felt that he's
he's done that um i think that i think
the point was all about looking forward
today i think it was it was about trying
to
i suppose underline what's been achieved
um and i think less about
you know
griping or sniping about what's gone
wrong uh in terms of the the way that he
was as he might see ousted and certainly
some commentators have talked about um
and even some of his own mps and party
members so i think it was better to talk
about his um
willingness to support liz trust who's
got a lot to do but um i think that was
probably as far as we were going to get
i'm not sure we'd have got a full uh
postmortem of his time in office and uh
and you know a big apology on on the uh
outside number 10.
no is that just not his personality i
mean you know him quite well that just
not he's not the kind of guy to just say
look that was i messed up and i'm sorry
that it really played out like this
i don't i don't think that is him i
think that's that's probably
characterized him for for many years
that that isn't necessarily something
that he does um
you know some of us are very willing to
to be the first to say sorry even in an
argument and i'm sure that that's that's
defining in terms of a personality but i
think that moment is about trying to say
look this is what i did and this is what
happens next and the big question on
everyone's lips has been you know what
will he do next and he was quick to uh
affirm that he was going to be
supportive let's see what that support
looks like it's going to be very hard
for someone who's always had opinions to
not have opinions while on the outside
yeah certainly will be and you will have
heard that quote the user from
cincinnatus i mean i didn't get unknown
classicist but it's about him returning
to his plow now there's some debate and
sir anthony seldon historian tells
cincinnatus made a comeback boris
johnson has quite clearly not ruled out
not making a comeback you know him what
do you think
he's still a young man really in
political terms um i think that
i don't i don't think his time is done
but what that looks like i mean there is
unknown there are many many routes um
that former prime ministers can take and
part of that is actually how history
regards them in terms of how they're
viewed what they did um actually the
landing that they have after being prime
minister those first you know the first
sort of outing after that point and how
you approach that um that will be uh
quite definitive for what he does next
it will also be interesting for him to
see the offers that come forward i think
many people assume that he will start
writing again which has always been a
huge passion of his
and not just the books but also will he
end up with another column because
actually he found that an incredibly
useful and enjoyable outlet
but how he uses that uh is going to be
probably quite an interesting uh
move you know his first column out of
the blocks what will he say will he
continue to talk about ukraine
will he be talking about domestic policy
um
i don't think he's he's a big beast in
terms of you know the power that he's
had in terms of whipping people up uh
getting people behind him getting people
interested in what he's saying but he's
also still a big thinker so it will be
interesting that out of the trappings of
office what is it that he will actually
want to talk about what will he want to
focus on because
as i say i'm not sure he's completely
done yet
no as you mentioned he may well go back
to doing some more writing and whatever
he says is going to be consequential but
the question is whether he chooses to be
consequential in the fact that it
helps the debate and furthers things or
whether he chooses to throw a bit of
shade to those who've replaced them
yeah and there's also that huge
challenge that we've got a covert
inquiry you know going to be taking
place and
there will be that inevitable period
where everyone tries to rewrite history
as he may see it he will you know we saw
rishi sunak talking about the kovid
restrictions and his views about that
during the leadership campaign so there
will be people that will be pouring over
what's happened over the last couple of
years and discussing whether they agreed
with something whether they were asking
for something else and those voices will
obviously be almost trying to sort of
manipulate how we view those last couple
of years and he's inevitably going to
want to in his eyes set the record
straight or at least get his views
across about what happened so there will
be
the potential for this kind of touring
and throwing between key figures that
have been involved in quite significant
decisions that took place over the last
couple of years but also
there is there has to be a period of
reflection there has to be a
sense of you know what next it's been
well reported that he's likely to need
to earn money um and so therefore the
decisions you make and how interesting
you are no newspaper is going to want
him unless he's got something to say um
they're going to want people to buy
their newspapers so
you know inevitably if he's just going
to be fairly boring and and you know not
boris-like then i'm sure that those
columns will not be forthcoming so
inevitably yes there is going to be uh
something to say but how that plays into
the current domestic agenda or whether
he starts to champion certain causes
that he's passionate about that's
obviously when when the sort of
trappings of office are off um you can
start to talk up those issues that
perhaps you were really passionate about
and for british johnson we have to
remember that kovid impacted his time in
office significantly there's a lot of
stuff that he wanted to do that he
didn't even get near to doing um
and i wonder if some of that those
things will be picked up uh in his time
now that he's leaving number 10.
i mean just quickly what kind of things
do interest him in terms of public
policy and helping helping the country
well i mean he still talks a lot about
his time in london he was very
passionate the leveling up agenda which
i think a lot of people felt didn't
really they didn't really make the
inroads in that arena that they they
could have i think that issue about
disparities we used to talk immensely on
the london campaign that i worked with
him on about even just health
inequalities in places like london that
if you travel just a few stops on the
tube your chances of living a certain
number of years
differed immensely
simply because of your
your economic prospects your
conditions that you lived in that the
local environment so
there are things around that that have
defined him because of other things that
he's seen and other things that he's
he's sort of talked about and has
researched and has been interested in in
the past so i think something around i'm
not sure if it's quite social mobility
but i think something around those
inequalities will still be of interest
to him um but i also think that boris is
a big thinker he will be looking ahead
he will he'll be interested in the next
big things and whether he decides to
champion causes in the future because
they are the next big things and he
wants to be visionary still as i say
still a relatively young man politically
um that will be quite defining the
conversations he will have the people
that will come and talk to him now and
perhaps get him excited about things
that maybe in number 10 they could
simply couldn't look at or couldn't do
yeah joe turner do appreciate that um
analysis of what we might expect from
boris johnson joe tanner former advisor
to the outgoing prime minister during
his time as mayor of london appreciate
your time this morning thanks for being
with us all right let's bring back in
the historian uh sir anthony selden for
his thoughts on what we've seen this
morning and what we may we'll see in the
future uh sir anthony jotan are there
talking about boris johnson perhaps
going back to writing his columns and
and i don't want you to sort of um
reflect on what kind of column he would
write but
just his input going forwards how
important is that as an outgoing prime
minister to have a constructive input to
the discourse
uh well one thing of course uh to
mention is that uh winston churchill
about whom he wrote a biography did come
back uh to power in uh 1951 and
that was just a glorious trailing and a
bit of mischief but a bit of maybe uh
future stargazing there by boris johnson
with that reference to cincinnatis uh
just taunting us uh they're tantalizing
us
um and
he can't stop thinking and he knows he
knows inside himself that he didn't
achieve uh what he wanted to achieve as
prime minister beyond getting brexit
done covered fair enough that wasn't
what he planned to do he uh as joe was
saying there he really does care i mean
he's a one nation uh centrist tory he
really does care about the condition of
uh people and uh leveling up what was
underachieved uh massively uh he does
care deeply also not mentioned about the
environment which he shares with uh
carrie his his wife he cares deeply
about ukraine there's a strong sense of
justice there uh within him there's so
much he wants to do
um and despite what he says about being
an ever so loyal um a good boy
in class to the new teacher
coming in mistrust
he will despite himself he won't be able
to restrain
um saying all kinds of provocative
things he simply can't stop himself
and of course uh the editors will want
him to be extremely uh provocative uh so
he'll probably keep quiet for about uh
10 days uh maybe a month um and then
he will be uh saying things and they'll
be all over
uh our newspapers and news bulletins
that is boris johnson
yeah and sir anthony
described as consequential of course and
his premiership has changed the politics
in this country so with the
interventions that you uh described
there being provocative i wonder what
that will do further to the politics
that we we see in the uk
well it's fragile isn't it um
it's fragile within the conservative
party
um she didn't have the support of her
mps she'll i'm sure worked very hard to
get that she didn't have an overwhelming
support from conservatives in the
country she certainly doesn't have that
support within the nation it is at the
end of a long period of single party
ascendancy you do not want to become
prime minister it's extremely hard in
history
to become prime minister at the end of a
long period of power
no party since 1832 has won five
elections on the trot she's got economic
uh cultural social
diplomatic
and union militancy problems and more
the cohesion of the country
the condition of her majesty uh herself
she can't carry on forever she is the
factor that holds the united kingdom
together so there's a lot on her in trey
uh a lot that was left by boris johnson
undone including uh the northern ireland
protocol and showing the country that
brexit really was uh in the interests of
the country uh boris johnson was
responsible for that uh but liz trust
has been a very strong advocate she'll
want to show
that brexit is more than sloganizing an
emotion it really does hit people
where it most uh counts which is in
their pocket
okay serenity seldom always appreciate
your thoughts thank you very much for
being with us for now let's bring back
in our political correspondent tomorrow
cohen who's still with us here uh
downing street and tomorrow just throw
forward then to what we can expect in
the next few hours time now and um what
the choreography is going to be like so
boris johnson is gone that was his last
act and with some jokes some serious
messages a bit of bitterness at his
colleagues and a hint of a comeback he
left downing street to go and see the
queen and tender his resignation we will
now see
him go
from balmoral
to the location where he will spend his
post office life we will not see him
leave he is now out of the spotlight liz
truss will leave balmoral to come to
downing street where she will we expect
in the afternoon stand on the steps of
downing street and give her first speech
and this is the speech where a prime
minister sets out their priorities if
they've won an election they say thank
you to the public for electing them she
has not won an election she takes over
mid-term with a whole load of problems
piling up in her entry the top of which
is of course the energy price crisis and
what she will do about it we're not
going to get chapter and verse of what
she'll do although there's plenty of
ideas knocking around in the newspapers
but she'll give some hints of it and of
what she wants to do as prime minister
will she talk a bit about her story her
beginnings with left-wing parents and
leads going to a comprehensive school
and not expecting perhaps in her wildest
dreams to be a conservative prime
minister
she will tell us a bit about herself
then she will get into downing street
and get on with the business of
appointing her cabinet who will meet for
the first time on wednesday and then
straight into prime minister's questions
and the very difficult business of
governing they will need to sign off of
course her energy bill package and we
may hear about that in the coming days
so there's no time really to get her
feet under the table and very little
time very little political honeymoon
really for liz trust who takes over just
two years before a general election but
a new team and a new approach under
the foreign secretary
who
was not that well known to the public
before this leadership race and we're
yet to see really what sort of prime
minister she may be yeah we'll find out
in the coming hours tomorrow thank you
very much for that plenty more analysis
from us here at downtree in the next
hour stay with us
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
organized
[Music]
this is sky news today live from downing
street it is 10 a.m
that's it folks boris johnson finally
bows out promising to get behind the new
prime minister in a defiant final speech
i am now like one of those booster
rockets
that has fulfilled its function and i
will now be gently re-entering the
atmosphere and splashing down
invisibly in some remote and obscure
corner of the pacific
they formed farewell from the starfads
downing street as boris johnson leaves
number 10 for the last time he's now on
his way to balmoral to meet the queen
and formally hand over the reigns of
power to his successor
this trust is to be in her first day as
prime minister facing an energy crisis
but promising a hundred billion pound
energy price freeze that could last
until the next election
we'll have all the latest from here at
stanley street and from balmoral as the
keys to downing street are handed over
and the new prime minister begins her
work
[Music]
hello and good morning from downing
street where boris johnson has said his
final goodbyes promising to get behind
the new prime minister this trust every
step of the way mr johnson is now on his
way to balmoral to meet the queen and
formally hand in his resignation now in
his final speech as prime minister boris
johnson described himself as a booster
rocket that has fulfilled its function
at championing his administration's
achievements highlighting the brexit
deal that he said he's got done the
vaccine rollout and the uk's response to
the war in ukraine
well this is
this is it folks thank you everybody for
coming out
so early this morning
in only a couple of hours i will be in
balmoral to see her majesty the queen
and the torch will finally be passed to
a new conservative leader
the baton will be handed over in what
has unexpectedly turned out to be a
relay race they changed the rules
halfway through but never mind that now
and through that lacquered black door a
new prime minister will shortly go to
meet a fantastic group of public
servants
the people who got brexit done
the people who deliver the fastest
vaccine rollout in europe and never
forget
70 of the entire population got a dose
within six months faster than any
comparable country that is government
for you that's this conservative
government
people
who organized those prompt early
supplies of weapons to the heroic
ukrainian armed forces an action that
may very well have helped change the
course of the biggest european war for
80 years and looking at what is
happening in this country the changes
that are taking place that is why
private sector investment is flooding in
more private sector more venture capital
investment than china itself more
billion pound tech companies sprouting
here in the uk
but in france germany and israel
combined and as a result
unemployment as i leave office
unemployment down to lowe's not seen
since i was about 10 years old and
bouncing around on a space hopper my
friends and
on on the subject of
on the subject of bouncing around in
future careers
let me say that i am now like one of
those booster rockets
that has fulfilled its function and i
will now be gently re-entering the
atmosphere and splashing down
invisibly in some remote and obscure
corner of the pacific
and
like cincinnatus
i am returning to my plow
and i will be offering this government
nothing but the most fervent support
this is
i'll tell you why this is a tough time
for the economy
this is a tough time for families up and
down the country we can and we will get
through it we will come out stronger the
other side
but i say to
my fellow conservatives it's time for
politics to be over folks it's time for
us all to get behind liz truss and her
team and her program
and deliver for the people of this
country
because that is what the people of this
country want that's what they need
and that's what they deserve
together we have laid foundations that
will stand the test of time whether by
taking back control of our laws or
putting in vital new infrastructure
great solid masonry on which we will
continue to build together
paving paving the path
of prosperity now and for future
generations
and i will be supporting liz truss and
the new government every step of the way
thank you all very much thank you and
goodbye thank you
restaurants final words there as prime
minister about seven and a bit minutes
that speech was tomorrow laying out
exactly how he plans to support this
trust but also going through some of his
greatest some of the achievements he
feels that he has made during his time
in office so what did you make of what
you heard boris johnson and the setup
that we had out here as he gave his
speech indeed the last words we were
here from boris johnson as prime
minister and
typically it was fizzing with energy he
was talking about what he believes his
great achievements are some genuinely
the vaccine roll out his support for the
ukrainian people some that his critics
would quibble with the 40 new hospitals
he says will have by the end of the
decade and the 50 000 new nurses have
promised to recruit
overall it was jovial it wasn't
emotional like some of his predecessors
have been it's not his style he's not
theresa may it also didn't have the
solemnity of for example gordon brown's
speech when he talked about the honor of
serving as serving through a difficult
period of the financial crisis this was
very much upbeat
very boosterish as we've come to expect
from boris johnson and with a little
hint at the end there of perhaps a
comeback there was a dig at his
colleagues this wasn't a bitter speech
like we saw when he resigned a couple of
months ago and talked about how his
colleagues had basically pulled the rug
from under him he said turned out to be
a relay race and they changed the rules
halfway through but he said let's not
talk about that now
then the end he said like cincinnatus
who's a roman statesman we learn
i will return to my plow but there was
some debate about whether cincinnatus
this is two and a half thousand years
ago uh in fact left his farm and
returned to help out the roman republic
later on so was this a hint of a
comeback that he's left us to chew on
for the rest of the day perhaps but i
think boris johnson
in typical style not much remorse not
much self-reflection about how it all
went wrong for him and suggesting that
maybe we have not heard the last of him
leaving it very very open-ended there
tomorrow appreciate that now so thank
you so much now boris johnson has made
his way from downing street
in that range rover to aria from norfolk
where he got on a jet
to fly to baltimore now he landed at
aberdeen airport in
the past hour or so and james matthews
is at aberdeen airport as boris johnson
touchdown james uh tell us what happens
now where is boris johnson off to next
well he's on his way by road thankfully
towards balmoral i say thankfully
because take a look at this aberdeen
airport peace super
next to the north sea and i can tell you
we didn't see much of boris johnson
because of the sight of the aircraft
that he disembarked from i think we'll
see even less of liz trust who is on her
way
but
um you know it's thick mist i mean this
is uh not what i would call or anyone
would call ideal flying conditions there
was a lot that went into the planning of
this journey
first of all to aberdeen then onward to
ball modeler was the option of a
helicopter discussed they will be happy
that they opted for the car convoy
because this is not great helicopter
whether at all indeed north sea
helicopter pilots there are many around
here they know a thing or two about
putting aircraft in the air from
aberdeen airport they were rushing out
this morning to catch the good weather
before this car rolled in so yeah liz
cross is on her way
and she too will make her way to
balmoral by
convoy escorted by police as she makes
her way and contemplates the land that
she will govern she may well reflect on
the scotland that she knew as a child of
course because she spent eight years in
paisley her dad took a job in 1979 at
the paisley college of technology and
liz trust remembers that fondly she was
quite politically active her mother took
her on cnd marches whilst she lived
there she also took part in a school
play
and she performed the role of who else
her hero our political hero margaret
thatcher and she recalls getting no
votes when that came to pass the big
question of course in terms of the
politics and where she goes from here is
where she takes the union how she
connects or disconnects with nicola
sturgeon nicola sturgeon was dismissed
by those trust you'll remember as an
attention seeker who deserved to be
ignored and nicola sturgeon and her in
her turn
she said that this trust would be a
disaster as a prime minister since then
she has said since the appointment she
said that she wants to work
constructively with this trust so time
will tell how the politics and the
chemistry go on that one much to be
discussed particularly talk of a new
referendum act being floated that would
involve a yes vote on independence being
declared if more than 50 percent of the
whole scottish electorate voted yes not
50 percent of those who voted that's a
plan that's been floated over the
weekend we'll see if that comes to pass
in reality
in the due course james matthews is at
peace super and aberdeen appreciate that
and as james mentioned now that boris
johnson has touched down aberdeen he's
making his way in convoy to balmoral to
officially attend his resignation to the
queen and waiting outside balmoral is
our royal correspondent on mills and
rihanna just take us through
what the process will be once uh mr
johnson arrives there and meets her
majesty
so as james mentioned there the
logistics around this have all been very
carefully planned and yesterday we were
being told that boris johnson was due to
arrive here at about 10 past 11 so we've
got around an hour to go that car
journey if you're driving it just by
yourself without a police convoy would
normally take about 50 minutes an hour
so i suspect potentially boris johnson
and carrie johnson being held somewhere
to make sure they don't arrive too early
uh here to meet the queen it was
actually last week that we were told
that this is how it was all going to
happen of course a complete change from
the rest of queen's 70-year reign every
one of her 14 prime ministers has always
been appointed at buckingham palace so
to a degree a sense of shock last week
that they had decided to riff up the
rule book and make it all happen here
but i think from all sides it was
decided that it was simply practical and
when it comes to the queen actually that
is really the mantra now and i think for
the palace they decided that yes she is
still having those mobility problems no
sense that she's deteriorated in any way
across the summer but it could have been
that she was going to fly down to london
and then simply woke up in the morning
and wasn't feeling up to it so instead
of course she is not the only important
person today there's an outgoing an
in-going prime minister to consider as
well so at least everyone knew the plan
and that now is what we're seeing
happening this morning of course we're
used to the whole process normally
happening over kind of a couple of hours
that handover of power so already this
morning is looking very different but
one aspect that won't look different and
an aspect that we don't see up close is
the formality of it all boris johnson of
course has had many meetings with the
queen throughout his premiership today
will be his final meeting and so much
was made wasn't it in that first speech
that he made announcing that he was
going to step aside the fact he didn't
use that word resignation today he will
have to formally tell the queen his
intention to resign and at that moment
he will also tell her that he recommends
that liz trust
be called to form a new government of
course we know that liz trusts well
she's already in the air she's already
on her way so the usual phone call that
would be made by the queen's private
secretary summoning liz trust well that
won't happen instead liz trust will
arrive here the queen in what's
described as a kissing of hand ceremony
no kissing simply a handshake will ask
her to form a new administration and as
soon as liz trust says yes then that is
the moment that she becomes prime
minister we're still waiting to find out
whether or not spouses will be allowed
in to meet the queen
so lots up in the air in terms of that
um but certainly a real moment for boris
johnson as he says his farewell uh to
the queen and liz truss begins a very
important relationship with the monarch
absolutely right okay round on in
balmoral do appreciate that reporting
thank you more from your course
throughout the day here on sky now to
some polling and it's consistently
pointed to victory for liz trust in the
leadership but also showed differences
between the conservative voters who
voted for her and the electorate as a
whole let's bring in a polling expert
chris curtis from opinion polling for
more detail on some of the research
that's been done in the past
few weeks chris curtis good to have you
with us now let's first of all look at
um how liz trust is being viewed by
voters in terms of whether they feel
that she's in touch there's been an
interesting change in how voters feel
this trust connects with them and sort
of understands their concerns
yes so obviously over the summer we have
been polling conservative party members
who have just uh elected liz trust
leisure of the party our final poll was
most accurate we're very proud of that
but also we've been polling voters out
there in the country to see what their
views are you know liz trust wasn't
particularly well known over the start
of summer so it's a really interesting
question what voters are going to think
of her as they start to get her to know
her and you know right at the start of
summer we did start to see her polling
numbers increase a little bit you know
more people saying that they liked her
but actually as time's gone on uh those
numbers have gone down again and you
know there's a lot of opportunities for
her to turn this around of course but
she starts the job um as a not
particularly popular new prime minister
okay chris i think we can bring up the
the figures as well that we have on this
i mean
the percentage that um
was was
put forward by those you spoke to before
has now dropped below zero percent is
that right
yeah so what we're looking at is um even
conservative voters specifically more of
them say that she doesn't look like a
prime minister in waiting that does look
like a prime minister in waiting um you
know more people more of them say that
they think she'll be an incompetent
leader than a competent leader and you
know these are the people yeah she needs
to win almost all of those people almost
all of those who voted conservative at
the last general election she needs to
win almost all of their support at the
next general election um if she you know
wants to remain in power and replicate
that result uh that boris johnson did in
2019 the conservative party just got rid
of boris johnson because it no longer
looked like he could do it but actually
liz truss is taking over um and you know
she's not she's not a majority of
conservative party voters i currently
don't have a particularly favorable view
of her either now you know i don't want
to read too much into this she will have
lots of opportunities to turn this
around and you know most people out
there in the country still don't have
a particularly strongly held view about
her so for example um you know we're
going to see a big cost of living plan
this week to try and address the rise in
energy bills this winter how that goes
down with the public will be a really
significant moment very early on in her
premiership that i think will start to
shape how
voters view her so lots of opportunities
for her to turn this around but she
doesn't start off in a particularly good
place
okay chris from opinion poland do
appreciate your analysis this morning
thank you
now melissa trust arrives in downing
street later on this afternoon it will
be the start of an exceptionally busy
month for her as the new prime minister
she's heading to balmoral right now to
meet the queen where she will officially
be appointed pm she'll then come back
here to london where she'll give her
first speech as leader outside
number 10. now senior officials are
going to be installed in number 10
immediately while the first members of
this trustee cabinet will be announced
shortly thereafter now on wednesday ms
trussell faced mps at prime minister's
questions for the first time in the days
after she'll appoint other government
ministers of course now her first
foreign trip is going to be in less than
two weeks the new pm will attend the un
general assembly in new york that's on
the 19th of september
but before that there is likely to be
something of an emergency budget to try
and deal with the cost of living crisis
then later on the 5th of october
there'll be conservative party
conference where this trust will speak
to the
members now we're in northern ireland
those trust faces the twin challenges of
a standoff with the european union and
trying to re-establish power sharing
between stormont's fierce rivals so
let's go to storm right now we're seeing
island crosstalk david levins is
standing by uh
david good to have you with us again so
look i made it very simple there that
there's issues that are facing this
trust in dealing with northern line just
lay out
how much of a task she has ahead of her
well it's difficult to see how the new
prime minister is going to square this
circle because of course we've heard
again this morning the outgoing prime
minister boris johnson talking about
having got brexit done but as far as
northern ireland is concerned it's not
done because the northern ireland
protocol the brexit trading arrangement
that created a border in the irs sea to
avoid the need for a border on this
island is the very reason the dup will
not return to the power sharing
government here three months after the
election now they want liz trust to
honor her commitment to remove the
protocol but that's easier said than
done because sinn fein won that election
they like the majority of
politicians elected here to the assembly
believe the protocol is the inevitable
consequence of brexit and to remove it
would be a breach of international law
in their opinion so does she uh
respond to what the dup wants in order
to get stormin back up and running uh
and by so doing risk the possibility of
a trade war with the eu the last thing
really that the uk would need in the
middle of a cost of living crisis
okay david blevins storm thank you for
that
the incoming prime minister grew up in
leeds so let's go back to her hometown
and find out what people there want to
hear from her when she finally addresses
the nation
this afternoon fraser moore is in leeds
forest this morning so fraser just tell
us what are people there telling you
they want to hear from the new prime
minister
yeah they want to hear movement on
energy bills that's for sure i'm here in
curt gate market right in the heart of
the city i'll have a chat now with one
of the market traders here paddy just in
the middle of serving a customer sorry
paddy to interrupt what do you want to
hear from our new prime minister liz
truss
well
as long as he promises what she preaches
that's the best thing you get me
been in here has it been tough have you
noticed people with less money to spend
well
less money to spend more huggling to
marketing at the end of the day so
you know you can't really win either way
but
it's not easy for everyone
have you noticed business dropping off
recently dropping off
kind of but
we sell food that's like
a staple diet for people so it's a bit
different but
our expenses are very high
yeah
at least um fuels come down a bit
because i live in bradford so i travel
to lee's every day
so it's a bit you know but like i said
it's
everyone's struggling don't get me even
traders you know
i mean
we're struggling
kind of but
the thing is it's
it'll get worse
it'll get worse you can't blame the war
in ukraine for everything do you get me
but like i said
it is why isn't it you have to just
take it with a pinch of salt
you get me keep on keeping on oh that's
it yeah all right paddy thanks ever so
much for talking to us nice speaking let
me get back to it you take care so
practice what you preach that's what
they want to see uh here in leeds market
they want to list trust to get on top of
the cost of living crisis and do that as
quickly as possible
absolutely right fraser and thank you
paddy looked like a lovely produce there
at leeds market now you're watching sky
news today and still to come
we'll look at the big economic
challenges facing the new prime minister
as soon as she enters number 10.
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm stuart ramsey and i'm sky's chief
correspondent
well there's a real sense now that
people are beginning to expect that this
whole airlift is coming to an end and
they're really really desperate
[Music]
we saw snatch squads going in grabbing
people and putting them into trucks
[Music]
you either live and recover
or you die
okay so that's like a wall that's the
war
yeah we help you understand the world
with us
over the past 24 hours the soldiers have
been attacked on a number of occasions
[Music]
it's really sending a clear message that
venezuela is eager for change
[Music]
to take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
they were convinced the united st
[Music]
the information on this could bring down
the entire network not just in iraq and
syria but across the world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello and welcome back you're watching
scones today live from downing street
now who could be working in the new top
team under the new prime minister and
this trusts her cabinet is rumored to
include quasi quartens braverman james
cleveland therese coffey and jacob reese
mogg
now will they all make the grade and get
new jobs the former scottish presenter
and political editor adam bolton joins
us now for his analysis on what you can
expect from his cabinet adam good to
have you with us this morning so what do
you make of those rumors does it seem
likely that those people will be in
those top jobs
well i think it's pretty clear as you
say that the top jobs have been handed
out it would be a shock now if quasi
quarten isn't the next chancellor uh
james cleverley uh the next foreign
secretary and suede bravo man uh the
next home secretary because of course uh
pretty patel announced that she was
going to the back benches yesterday and
that will be one first it'll mean it'll
be the first time that in the top four
great offices of state as they're called
there isn't a single white man
but
i think lowered down the batting order
as ever with cabinet reshuffles it's
proving a little bit more difficult and
that might have been expected uh
northern ireland secretary for example
was being pensioned in uh pennsylvania
javid he's now said he wants to go to
the back benches as well we know conor
burns would like that job we know robert
buckland also uh was interested in doing
it but he appears to be going to wales
and likewise
some question over leader of the house
it was being said that he and duncan
smith might come in they'll come back as
leader of the house now appears more
likely that that's going to go to the
runner-up number three runner-up in this
leadership contest
penny mordent
and also some question over who's going
to go to health again it's been
suggested that therese coffee may be
heading in that direction uh on the
other hand she is one of the closest
political allies
of liz trust and the new prime minister
may want to see her going somewhere else
now the plan
is that liz trust is clearly working now
uh on her cabinet appointments and they
would like uh to have a full cabinet
sheet available pretty much by the time
she gets back
to make her statement as prime minister
either on the doorstep of number 10
depending on the weather or inside
number 10 uh roundabout tea time they
would like pretty much to announce the
cabinet then and then quite possibly
even to have a cabinet meeting this
evening
my guess
is it may just take that little bit
longer that's nothing unusual that's how
uh cabinet reshuffles tend to go
yeah they could still have in place uh
tomorrow morning before pmq's couldn't
they add them and that probably wouldn't
be too bad it gives them more time to
make sure because my next question
really is
are we confident that this cabinet will
sort of have the breadth of the party
because one of the other challenges
facing the trust apart from her economic
policies and how she's going to run the
country is trying to bring the
conservative party back together well i
think you can say that this is not going
to be a government of all the talents
we're not seeing one nation
conservatives being speculated on about
joining uh in uh the uh new cabinet
we're not really seeing uh supporters of
rishi sunak uh being talked about i mean
you might think of uh names like jeremy
hunt as a one nation person uh and also
uh you might think about uh sunak
himself perhaps of getting the camera
that's not gonna happen so this is going
to be
a fairly
right of center within the conservative
party
boris johnson loyalist
uh type of cabinet and particularly when
you've got people like
sanji javid saying they're not going to
be in it that will that will only
increase
uh that interesting however uh that
nadine doris is another one who said
that she's uh going to the back benches
and quite possibly going to the house of
lords uh sooner on
she was one of the early supporters of
liz trust but that kind of culture
warrior uh is not going to be in the
culture department and that i think
gives this chance this trust a chance to
be a bit more pragmatic perhaps in her
approach and to try and maybe damp down
the culture wall rhetoric a little bit
yeah i mean i suppose there will be
plenty of culture warriors still there
kevin baden off his tip for a job and
jacob rees-mogg too and i wonder if we
do see a cabinet made up like that adam
what does that do when there's trust in
that cabinet eventually have to go to
the country
well i think that's the big question
mark you know the conservatives are
trailing labor at the moment and you
have to ask yourself
is liz trust becoming prime minister
going to give them a boost and are there
any people that she can put in the
cabinet that are going to make people
think
maybe
i ought to take another look at the
conservatives floating voters and so far
i mean kemi badnik you mentioned that
name is perhaps one tom tougenhart is
perhaps another but we're not quite
clear yet where they're going to settle
uh in the lineup
okay adam always appreciate your
announcements thanks for being with us
all right you are watching sky news
today and still to come
boris johnson's resignation speech we'll
bring it to you in full 7 minutes 27
seconds stay with us
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello and welcome back you're watching
sky news today live from downing street
let me bring you a little bit of
breaking news that's coming to us
in the past a few minutes here at sky
news you of course remember the killing
of a nine-year-old olivia pratt corbell
just a couple of weeks ago
shot by an unknown person in our home in
liverpool shot and killed her mother was
injured in the incident and police are
still hunting for the gunman in
louisville and asking anyone with
information to come forward now olivia's
family have put out a statement in the
past a few minutes i just want to read
some of it to you um
words can't express the pain we're going
through after olivia was so cruelly
snatched away from us those responsible
need to know what they have done olivia
was a real bright spark who knew her own
mind and then no problem making friends
she would talk to anyone and loved to
laugh and make people laugh she could be
a proper wind-up merchant and loved to
wind her nieces up particularly those
who are older than her when they didn't
like it she'd just laugh and say don't
forget i'm your auntie
now olivia's future has been cruelly
snatched away from her and we have been
deprived of a real light in our lives
now we know that there's been an
exceptional response to police appeals
and we would like to thank those who've
come forward at the same time we want to
urge others who may have evidence to
keep coming forward with information
which could help put those responsible
for olivia's murder behind bars
the statement goes on to say we've been
really taken aback by the kindness and
support we've received from family
friends and neighbors in the last two
weeks and we'd like to thank them for
being there for us we know that most
people on merseyside are good-hearted
and kind just like them and we all need
to stand together we don't want to see
another child lose their life in such
horrendous circumstances and we don't
want to see another family suffer like
we are suffering now
olivia's death cannot be in vain and we
want people to feel safe and be safe
that will only happen if we all come
together and make sure there is no place
for guns or those who use guns on our
streets or in our communities
if you have any information make sure
you tell the police if you don't feel
able to do that give the information to
crime stoppers anonymously so action can
be taken if you can't do it yourself do
it for a liv do it in olivia's name and
the children across merseyside who
deserve to enjoy their lives
to the full
now that is the statement as you said
released by uh
olivia pratt corbell's father john
francis pratt in the last few minutes
here laying out what olivia
was like
and appealing again for assistance and
help from anyone who may have
information into who pulled the trigger
uh resulting in her death they have of
course
in the past we've also been a number of
arrests four people are being held in
custody in connection with this killing
and police are continuing to appeal
any more information to find out who
killed olivia
all right let's return it to the
politics now
and this morning boris johnson left down
the street for the final time after
delivering a speech outside of number 10
in which he promised his fervent support
his successor and likened himself to a
booster rocket returning to earth here
is his speech
thank you thank well
well this is this is it folks thank you
everybody for coming out
so early this morning
in only a couple of hours i will be in
balmoral to see her majesty the queen
and the torch will finally be passed to
a new conservative leader the baton will
be handed over in what has unexpectedly
turned out to be a relay race they
changed the rules halfway through but
never mind that now
and through that lacquered black door a
new prime minister will shortly go to
meet a fantastic group of public
servants the people who got brexit done
the people who deliver the fastest
vaccine rollout in europe and never
forget 70
of the entire population got a dose
within six months faster than any
comparable country that is government
for you that's this conservative
government
people
who organized those prompt early
supplies of weapons to the heroic
ukrainian armed forces an action that
may very well have helped change the
course of the biggest european war for
80 years and because of the speed and
urgency of what you did everybody
involved in this government to get this
economy moving again from july last year
in spite of all the opposition
all the nay says we have
and will continue
to have
that economic strength to give people
the cash they need to get through this
energy crisis that has been caused by
putin's vicious war
and i know
that liz
trusts and this compassionate
conservative government will do
everything we can to get people through
this crisis and this country will endure
it and we will win and if putin thinks
that he can succeed by blackmailing or
bullying the british people then he is
utterly deluded
and the reason we will have those funds
now and in the future is because we
conservatives understand the vital
symmetry between government action
and free market capitalist private
sector enterprise
we're delivering on those huge manifesto
commitments making streets safer
neighborhood crime down 38
in the last three years 13 790 more
police on the streets building more
hospitals and yes we will have 50 000
more nurses by the end of the decade and
40 more hospitals by the end of
50 000 by the end of this parliament i
should say 40 new hospitals by the end
of the decade putting record funding
into our schools and into teachers pay
giving everybody over 18 a lifetime
skills guarantee so they can keep up
skilling throughout their lives three
new high-speed rail lines three
including northern powerhouse rail
colossal road proud programs from the
pennines to cornwall the rollout of
gigabit broadband up over the last
three years i am proud to say since you
were kind enough to elect me from seven
percent of our country's premises having
gigabit broadband to 70
today and we are of course providing the
short and the long-term solutions for
our energy needs and not just using more
of our own domestic hydrocarbons but
going up by 2030 to 50 gigawatts of wind
power that is half of this country's
energy electricity needs from offshore
wind alone a new nuclear reactor every
year and looking at what is happening in
this country the changes that are taking
place that is why private sector
investment is flooding in more private
sector more venture capital investment
than china itself more billion pound
tech companies sprouting here in the uk
but in france germany and israel
combined and as a result
unemployment as i leave office
unemployment down to lowe's not seen
since i was about 10 years old and
bouncing around on a space hopper my
friends and
on on the subject of
on the subject of bouncing around in
future careers
let me say that i am now like one of
those booster rockets
that has fulfilled its function and i
will now be gently re-entering the
atmosphere and splashing down
invisibly in some remote and obscure
corner of the pacific
and
like cincinnatus
i am returning to my plow
and i will be offering this government
nothing but the most fervent support
this is
i'll tell you why this is a tough time
for the economy
this is a tough time for families up and
down the country we can and we will get
through it we will come out stronger the
other side
but i say to
my fellow conservatives it's time for
politics to be over folks it's time for
us all to get behind liz truss and her
team and her program
and deliver for the people of this
country
because that is what the people of this
country want that's what they need
and that's what they deserve
i'm proud
to have discharged the promises i made
to my party when you were kind enough to
choose me winning the biggest majority
since 1987 the biggest share of the vote
since 1979 delivering brexit delivering
our manifesto commitments including by
the way including social care reforming
social care helping people up and down
the country ensuring that britain is
once again standing tall in the world
speaking with clarity and authority
from ukraine to the orcas pact with
america and
australia because we are one whole and
entire united kingdom whose diplomats
security services and armed forces
are so globally admired and by the way
as i believe as i leave i believe our
union is so strong that those who want
to break it up they'll keep trying but
they will never ever succeed
thank you to everybody
behind me in this building
thank you to all of you in government
thank you everyone who's helped look
after me and my family over the last
three years including
including dylan
the dog
and i just say to my party if dylan and
larry
can put behind them their occasional
difficulties then so can the
conservative party
above all thanks to you the british
people to the voters for giving me the
chance to serve
all of you
who work so tirelessly together
to beat covid to put us where we are
today
together we have laid foundations that
will stand the test of time whether by
taking back control of our laws or
putting in vital new infrastructure
great solid masonry on which we will
continue to build together
paving paving the path
of prosperity now and for future
generations
and i will be supporting liz truss and
the new government every step of the way
thank you all very much thank you and
goodbye thank you
[Applause]
now of course the new prime minister of
this trust is thoughts to be drawing up
plans to deal with the cost of living
crisis that could see 100 billion pounds
worth of support the emergency package
is expected to include a freeze for
energy bills for homes and businesses
until january next year and possibly
until 2024. now it's thought that energy
suppliers will be able to take out
government-backed loans to subsidize
those bills so let's bring in our
business presenter ian king for his
analysis on on that proposal uh good
morning to ian so uh i spoke to paul
johnson from the ifs the other day and
he said that although he hates that idea
of a policy might be the only thing left
open to the government
yes that's right i mean the government
has had various choices it's really
chiefly as to whether it goes for
targeted support by helping the most
vulnerable households and businesses or
whether it opts for blanket support now
the current government's uh support in
place is a kind of mixture of the two
because bear in mind that we've got this
uh 400 pound flat rebate to household
energy bills due to be paid later in the
year there are also council tax rebates
for less well-off households and there's
also targeted support via the benefit
system that comes to a total of some 37
billion pounds that's what's on the
table at the moment so as to say it's a
hybrid of blanket and targeted support
what liz trust and her team look to have
come down on though on the side of is
some sort of blanket support and that's
why you're getting these enormous
costings of up to 100 billion pounds
being thrown around now what we don't
know is how the government would pay for
this whether it would be simply
government borrowing or whether it would
be uh borrowing by the energy companies
themselves by the industry with state
guarantees either way a big increase in
government borrowing is implicit in that
and you can see what the bond market
thinks of that because government uh
bond yields that's uh government i o
yields have been rising very steadily if
you take 10-year gilts 10-year
government ious well the yield on those
has risen from 1.7 to the beginning of
august to just under 3
today so that tells you what the market
thinks investors are looking for a
premium for lending to the uk government
so as i say we think that liz trust is
going to come down in favor of some big
form of blanket support now there are a
lot of problems with that the key one
amongst them is that there's no
incentive in this for households or
businesses to save energy and that is
something that obviously higher prices
incentivizes people to do it encourages
people to spend less on their energy you
wouldn't get that with a blanket support
scheme and accordingly some energy
analysts are saying well this could end
up resulting in rationing of power
because as i say there will be no uh
incentive for anyone to save money also
important in this a big support package
for businesses who've had absolutely
nothing from the johnson government so
far
we're being told that potentially 40
billion pounds alone could be spent on
supporting uh uh businesses but in in
total in general it looks as so liz
trusted government is going to come down
in favor of freezing energy prices at
the current price cap level of 1 971
obviously they're due in october to rise
to
3549 pounds it doesn't look as though
that is going to happen under what
mistrust is proposing
all right ian king and the city for us
thank you
now boris johnson won an atc majority
back in 2019 with constituencies which
had been labor for generations they
finally turned blue for mr johnson now
they included tony blair's pharmacy in
the northeast sedgefield from where our
chief northern england correspondent
greg milam senses this
they have a history with prime ministers
in this part of the world but just like
everywhere else the talk is of what the
next one will do about the issues
causing a creeping anxiety
it was different when their mp was pm
and brought world leaders to the pub and
in truth liz trusses big moment past the
lunchtime crowd by at the dunn cow inn
not that they don't care here
i don't think it's going to she's going
to be any good for the working class
i think it's going to be
a north south divide even more so than
it was and i fear i saw fear for the nhs
i feel for the people that
are living from day to day
and
i'll worry about the gas and electricity
are really worried
three years ago a victorious boris
johnson came to pull a pint at the
cricket club to celebrate the tories
demolishing the blue wall of once safe
labour seats like this one
the local newspaper front page back then
reflected that tory tidal wave across
the north today's tells a very different
story the business community here in the
north calling on liz trusts to deliver
what boris johnson promised here three
years ago to prevent what they say is a
coming disaster for communities like
this
it's already arrived for some this
community project's been forced to close
because of spiraling costs the
communities are all struggling and it's
it's real life this is what happens on
the ground now and its founder hardly
reassured by the change in number 10.
she said already that she's going to
take a week to come out with what she
thinks is her plan that concerns me
because there's a lot of people who need
that information sooner
businesses have closed too those
surviving like betty's boudoir say they
have to have hope
we're in a
state of not knowing what's going to
happen over the winter time and
everything everybody's worried
everybody's concerned and we can feel
that with business i do like the idea
that she's a lady and that that's good
good for us women
but um i just hope she's strong enough
to cope with the job
they've seen prime ministers come and go
here but rarely has this community so
many communities felt so vulnerable and
so in need of some certainty greg milam
sky news sedgefield
we're watching sky news today and still
to come we'll be asking the political
commentator
sam friedman about the transfer of power
from one prime minister to the next
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm stuart ramsey and i'm sky's chief
correspondent
well there's a real sense now that
people are beginning to expect that this
whole airlift is coming to an end and
they're really really desperate
we saw snatchbox going in grabbing
people and putting them into trucks
[Music]
you either live and recover
or you die
okay so that's like a wall that's the
war yes
we help you understand the world with us
over the past 24 hours the soldiers have
been attacked on a number of occasions
[Music]
it's really sending a clear message that
venezuela is eager for change
[Music]
to take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
they were convinced the united states
will become hooked they were right
the enormous explosion it's just come
down i think it was a monster just
landed in between us
the information on this could bring down
the entire network not just in iraq and
syria but across the world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the inspiration behind our product came
from
understanding how big of a problem
livestock meat and emissions were
global insight
made local
invest in your future sky news financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
[Music]
invest in your future sky news financial
report sponsored by interactive investor
hello again from downing street as we're
covering the transfer of power from
trust let's bring in now sam friedman
who worked with liz trust at the
department for education where he was a
senior advisor on school sam freeman
good morning thanks for being with us
now first of all tamara tells me that
you were right in your prediction and
you got the margin of victory just about
spot on
thank you very much
how are you able to get it so right
i just assumed that the polls would
overestimate the level that trust would
win by by the same that they
overestimated the level johnson would
win by they struggle a bit to get the
tory membership pulled correctly uh so i
just thought it would be a bit closer
than the polls were suggesting
and of course you worked uh with mr us
at the department for education i mean
what was she like there in in terms of
being open to new ideas i mean is she
one of those people that you can give
new ideas to she pretty set on what she
wants to see done
uh she has very strong ideas of her own
um she uh she's very strong-minded uh
she's very interested in policy unlike
boris johnson um and uh
and and hangs on to her opinions
tenaciously but she does listen she does
engage with advisors um and she will she
will change her mind if the evidence is
there for her to do so but it sometimes
took quite a long time to persuade her
to change her mind on things she is she
is uh she is resilient and sticks to her
views
mr um i apologize i can't quite hear
your response uh to my previous question
but i'll just carry on anyway now you
say that she does listen to advice from
those around us so how do you expect her
to run the um
the operation out down the street
well it looks already from what we know
that she's going to run a much smaller
number 10.
she's appointed her political team
already
and they're going to be people who are
very loyal to her people who've worked
for her before she's cleared out all of
boris johnson's
advisors her cabinet as well she's
picked people who are very loyal to her
she's not going to have people in that
cabinet who backed other candidates
particularly and so it looks to me like
she's intending to govern very much from
the center government very much with the
team around her of people she trusts and
believes in and
and that does mean that does risk as a
lack of diversity of thought coming into
that bubble and there's a risk she's
only going to get advice from people she
already agrees with
yeah and one of the dangers then i'm not
having that kind of lack of diversity of
thought when it comes to making policy
and of course thinking that we're in
such a consequential time for politics
for policies in place
there's some really big crises obviously
going on at the moment and it's
important if you're in uh downing street
not to fall into a kind of group think
where you think you found the right
answer straight away and you pursue that
answer without anyone challenging it and
saying wait a minute so you know we're
hearing at the moment about the plan for
energy and maybe they're going to add uh
the cost of energy now they're going to
get people paying it back over 10 or 20
years i hope there's somebody in downing
street saying wait a minute that's going
to go down like a lead balloon with the
british public we might need to think
about this differently if there aren't
people expressing those um kind of
different views and and critiques uh
then then they're going to have a
problem
okay sam friedman uh from advisor who
worked with liz trust in the department
for education do appreciate your time
and analysis this morning thank you
thank you
all right that's almost it from me our
sky news today is uh we've seen boris
johnson give his final speech as prime
minister he is now in scotland on his
way to balmoral to formally tender his
resignation having served three in a bit
years behind that door in number ten a
consequential prime minister who in his
verse has got brexit done got the
country through the pandemic but his
critics will say perhaps didn't live up
to the promises that he made and of
course will be viewed very differently
by those who want to see him out of
office we'll have plenty more of course
from downing street throughout the day
here on sky news as we await liz trust
arriving back in london
following meeting the queen at balmoral
where she will give her first address to
the nation as pm
[Music]
this is sky news today live from downing
street it's 11 o'clock
this is it folks boris johnson finally
bows out promising to get behind the new
prime minister in a defiant final speech
i am now like one of those booster
rockets
that has fulfilled its function and i
will now be gently re-entering the
atmosphere and splashing down invisibly
in some remote and obscure corner of the
pacific
a fond farewell from downing street
staff as boris johnson leaves number 10
for the last time
he's now on his way to balmoral to meet
her majesty the queen and formally hand
over the reigns to his successor
liz trust is to begin her first day as
prime minister facing an energy crisis
but promising a hundred billion pound
energy price freeze that could last
until the next election
i'm in warrington looking at some of the
big challenges facing the new prime
minister as she begins her first day in
the job
well we'll have all the latest from here
and in balmoral as the keys to number 10
are handed over and the new prime
minister begins to form her government
[Music]
a very good morning from downing street
where boris johnson has said his final
goodbyes this morning promising to get
behind the new prime minister liz truss
every step of the way he's now on his
way to balmoral to meet the queen and
formally tender his resignation in his
final speech as prime minister mr
johnson described himself as a booster
rocket that has fulfilled its function
championing his administration's
achievements highlighting brexit the
vaccine rollout and the response to the
war in ukraine
well this is
this is it folks thank you everybody for
coming out
so early this morning
in only a couple of hours i will be in
balmoral to see her majesty the queen
and the torch will finally be passed to
a new conservative leader
the baton will be handed over in what
has unexpectedly turned out to be a
relay race they changed the rules
halfway through but never mind that now
and through that lacquered black door a
new prime minister will shortly go to
meet a fantastic group of public
servants the people who got brexit done
the people who deliver the fastest
vaccine rollout in europe and never
forget
70
of the entire population got a dose
within six months faster than any
comparable country that is government
for you that's this conservative
government
people
who organized those
early supplies of weapons to the heroic
ukrainian armed forces an action that
may very well have helped change the
course of the biggest european war for
80 years and looking at what is
happening in this country the changes
that are taking place that is why
private sector investment is flooding in
more private sector more venture capital
investment than china itself more
billion pound tech companies sprouting
here in the uk
that in france germany and israel
combined and as a result
unemployment as i leave office
unemployment down to lowe's not seen
since i was about 10 years old and
bouncing around on a space hopper my
friends and
on on the subject of
on the subject of bouncing around in
future careers
let me say that i am now like one of
those booster rockets
that has fulfilled its function and i
will now be gently re-entering the
atmosphere and splashing down invisibly
in some remote and obscure corner of the
pacific
and
like cincinnatus
i am returning to my plow
and i will be offering this government
nothing but the most fervent support
this is
i'll tell you why this is a tough time
for the economy
this is a tough time for families up and
down the country we can and we will get
through it we will come out stronger the
other side
but i say to
my fellow conservatives it's time for
politics to be over folks it's time for
us all to get behind liz truss and her
team and her program
and deliver for the people of this
country
because that is what the people of this
country want that's what they need
and that's what they deserve
together we have laid foundations that
will stand the test of time whether by
taking back control of our laws or
putting in vital new infrastructure
great solid masonry on which we will
continue to build together
paving paving the path
of prosperity now and for future
generations
and i will be supporting liz truss and
the new government every step of the way
thank you all very much thank you and
goodbye thank you
well boris johnson's last speech as
prime minister there and this trust
shortly to succeeding we understand that
she has just
touched down her aircraft has just
touched down in aberdeen aberdeen
international in summers you can see for
yourself some very foggy some very
difficult conditions but uh there it is
list trust landing now boris johnson is
on a separate flight his plane has
already landed and we understand he is
on his way to balmoral to tend to his
resignation to her majesty the queen
list trusts following by road shortly
afterwards where after a brief
interregnum when interestingly uh the
queen
holds executive power between prime
ministers for a minute or two uh this
trusts will accept the invitation to
former government and become the next
prime minister we'll
be up in balmoral and aberdeen in a
moment or two but uh let's talk now to
our deputy political editor sam coats
and uh sam as i mentioned there let's
trust shortly formally to become prime
minister once that happens we're going
to see a very different style of
governing aren't we from the previous
incumbent that's right but liz trust
will be britain's 56th prime minister
halfway through a parliament and it's
going to be a massive change if the
rhetoric of the people who have been
helping her prepare for this moment
lands uh stands up uh to reality this
afternoon we she will give a speech
giving the first taste of what a liz
trust premiership uh will be like when
she is prime minister and then she will
begin
her cabinet appointments and what her
allies say is that this is going to be a
very different type of premiership to
the one that's just ended now yesterday
we may have seen liz trust pay tribute
to her friend boris johnson we may have
heard boris johnson uh just behind us a
few hours ago talk about all the
achievements that he succeeded in doing
but there is a feeling amongst people
around liz trust liz trust herself that
there needs to be quite a sharp change
in the way this government is uh this
government conducts itself the
priorities that a trust government will
pursue and number one once we've dealt
with the energy uh
cost massive energy cross increase for
which we're expecting a policy where
they will cap wholesale bills
announced possibly as soon as this week
we will see a singular focus on growth
whereas boris johnson was talking about
levelling up the word that i think liz
trust most wants to be associated with
is growth and there will be a huge
packet we will see tax cuts we will see
infrastructure plans we will see all of
the things that tory prime ministers
bluntly for the last 12 years in downing
street said that they wanted to pursue
she believes that she's found the right
cocktail the right mixture of plans and
people to actually push through
a big change to the way the british
state she's a government because that is
quite a gamble because everyone's
talking now about things beyond her
control the markets the people who buy
uk bonds that the billions the trillions
that are invested in the united kingdom
if they lose confidence if they see
inflation still soaring if they see
growth not happening then she could be
in trouble well look dermot you've
touched on the risk there's nobody here
in the westminster uh in this square
mile that doesn't underestimate the
challenges ahead you're right
liz truss is promising growth at a time
where a lot of forecasters a lot of
economists are saying that there could
be a recession she's coming into power
after a very fractious battle with the
conservative party and so she's got to
do it with a majority that many of the
mps of the conservative party something
uh something of a civil war for recent
months so she's got to uh she's got to
contest with that and you're right we're
looking at
120 billion pounds of borrowing the
international market could end up being
the ultimate judge and juror of the liz
tress premiership and she will be hoping
that they're not also the executioner
okay thanks very much indeed for the
time being some coast side deputy
political editor there as i said we're
going to head uh north now to scotland
and first of all to balmoral where boris
johnson is on his way by road from
aberdeen airport to balmoral to meet her
majesty the queen our royal
correspondent rihanna mills is there as
well now this uh rihannon is a is a
carefully choreographed process of the
resignation and then the anointing of
liz trust as prime minister
it is but we're so used to it happening
where you are aren't we all of this kind
of exchange of power happening within
just a couple of hours as the cars to
and fro between number 10 and buckingham
palace this year of course it is
completely different and a complete
change from throughout the queen's 70
year reign all of her 14 prime ministers
have always been appointed at buckingham
palace but it was decided last week
purely from a practical perspective that
rather than the queen heading down to
london which we were told in the summer
she was expected to that she didn't mind
doing that instead it was decided that
the outgoing and incoming prime
ministers would instead be making that 1
000 mile round trip up here to balmoral
now has to be said we are currently
keeping our eyes peeled because we were
told that boris johnson was due to
arrive here at about 10 past 11 i think
both for number 10 and buckingham palace
one thing that they have had to factor
in that they normally don't have to
factor in when it comes to these
handover processes is the good old
scottish weather and arrangements
already had to be changed this morning
because they were anticipating that
potentially a helicopter could be used
to transport both boris johnson and liz
trust from aberdeen airport
here to balmoral castle instead they're
having to travel by car so at the moment
we're still waiting for boris johnson to
arrive likely with carrie johnson who we
saw both them getting off that plane at
aberdeen airport a journey of about an
hour 45 minutes uh when they're using
that police convoy so we wait for them
to arrive in terms of the practicalities
the logistics may be different but when
it comes down to the formalities of the
day it's going to be very much business
as usual just as we would see
inside buckingham palace so boris
johnson arrives he resigns formally of
course so much made the fact he hadn't
used that word resign when he said he
was stepping aside
a couple of months ago and he will then
recommend that liz trust is called to
form an administration the queen will
then ask her to form a new government at
that moment she becomes the new prime
minister now i'm very lucky to have
louise tate with me who was the former
scottish communications secretary to the
queen and louise this is all very
carefully choreographed and it will also
be very important that there are people
there to meet boris johnson and carrie
johnson when they arrive for this
important final meeting who are those
people likely to be
i think no different to what we would
see expect to see in london in
buckingham palace there'll be probably
the duty private secretary
possibly a lady in waiting the equity
they'll be there to meet the cars on
arrival and then there'll be handshakes
perhaps and then taken inside through
the portico inside the castle
for all of us it couldn't feel more
different than standing on the mall
seeing the cars turning and throwing we
are somewhere that is much more remote
much more rural but it is a place that
the queen loves spending time and
ultimately she was here spending her
summer holidays
indeed as she does every year joined by
many members of her family um who spend
time here throughout the year not just
not just in the summer
so it is very important for the cleaners
but it's very a place where she still
continues the
business of state the red boxes that's
always happened continues to happen
um and it is the place that she probably
up until perhaps moved to windsor that
she spent the longest time in one place
yeah
in terms of the queen you were saying
there duty always comes first we're
currently showing pictures now of liz
truss making her way here of course
usually um the queen would have to get
the private secretary to call liz trust
to tell her to come for an audience that
of course isn't happening today but the
sense of that relationship that liz
trust will now build um with the queen
is probably one of the most sorry though
that relationship for liz trust that she
will start to build today with the queen
is so important one of probably the most
important relation relationships of her
premiership i would imagine so for all
of our um
the queen's previous prime ministers
they have openly said it's been one of
the most important relationships they
ever had she's a great confidant they
can speak freely um there is an
understanding that that those
conversations will remain within that
room
and that's same with most audiences that
these conversations remain i'm just
going to get you to pause there and step
down for me a bit luis because we can
see now that boris johnson and carrie
johnson are arriving here
at buckingham palace
not at buckingham palace at balmoral
and they will now be driven the very
short distance just a couple of minutes
up to the front
of balmoral castle
where we anticipate that a camera is
waiting and we will see
the moment that they will be as louise
said let me move louise around here as
louis said we will see the moment that
boris johnson is met by
usually the queen's equi and also her
principal private secretary who is
edward young always the queen has
a private secretary with her because as
louise was mentioning the official
duties of sovereign of monarch continue
right throughout this summer break
here in scotland let's bring louise
back in hopefully we will see some
pictures from outside the front of of
balmoral what do you think that boris
johnson and carrie johnson can expect
when they arrive at the front of of
balmoral as they're welcomed into the
entrance because they have been here
before haven't they yes they have been
here before i believe yeah well i think
the the wonderful thing about driving at
burma is that drive up and just getting
a sense of
the granite splendor of balmoral castle
because it it is a castle but it's quite
an intimate castle all the time
and it's a place they have seen before
but
perhaps in different in different
weather conditions the atmosphere it is
a very place of
atmosphere and drama and we're seeing
louise now pictures of boris johnson uh
being met by sir edward young edward
young here and also said edward they're
shaking the hand of carrie johnson as
well
and then
they are welcomed inside and always we
were talking about this earlier often
there is
a moment to kind of pause there in the
entrance wall as
the private secretary and others talk to
those who are about to have that
audience with the queen about how things
are likely to happen yes i mean it's
understandable let's just give everybody
a moment just to chat and acclimatize
and just perhaps explain the logistic
steps what will happen next and they'll
be a brief informal chat and then at the
right to appropriate time the
prime minister will be invited by the
equity to join him to come into the
drawing room for his audience with the
queen and
it's worth saying for the prime minister
this is
the important moment where he
he resigns he has that that time
with the queen that final moment
but also in recent years we have seen
spouses invited in i'm told that there's
a buzzer in the room that the queen may
press to then allow carrie johnson to
come in as well and the queen is
particularly good at trying to put
people at ease you said oh yeah yes i
mean that's that's well understood i
think she would probably begin by asking
about the journey i'm not sure i'm
speculating but um these are just things
to ease into the into just what's
happening today and you know
is everything how's your journey been
quite understandable very human
conversation at the forum
perhaps the more formal business begins
i would imagine louise thank you very
much there is still plenty to talk about
and in the next few moments no doubt
boris johnson will be welcomed into the
drawing room for that final conversation
with the queen the moment where he will
formally resign as prime minister where
he will tell the queen that liz trust
should be invited to form a new
government it has been quite a couple of
years for boris johnson if you think
about the conversations that
him and the monarch must have had during
the pandemic sometimes remotely over the
phone
which was of course a change from the
usual weekly audiences that many prime
ministers had and today another complete
change another history-making moment as
the queen is due to say farewell to her
14th prime minister and shortly welcome
her 15th
okay rhiannon thank you very much indeed
back with you very soon as the 15th
prime minister
arrived shortly after boris johnson
in balmoral
she landed liz truss of course we're
talking about she landed at aberdeen
airport shortly after mr johnson's
aircraft and we understand is on her way
by road as i say carefully choreographed
operation this there is only uh a few
minutes at the very most when there is
no prime minister when in actual fact
her majesty the queen holds executive
powers once boris johnson has resigned
and invited her majesty to arsenal's
trust to former government she will be
close behind but they will not meet
together she will then be ushered in and
asked to form a government by her
majesty let's check in with james
matthews who's at aberdeen airport where
as we saw earlier james can conditions
are pretty tricky to get those planes
down um let's try on her way we
understand
yeah she is now uh dermot uh the convoy
has just left aberdeen airport so she's
on our way about an hour and a half from
here to balboa but you talk about
careful choreography i can tell you
dammit the elements in the northeast of
scotland will be will decide how things
go down when it comes to traditional
it's been more functional than
traditional and when i say functional i
mean just
because she was delayed for some
considerable time i reckon about 20 to
25 minutes watching on the flight radar
her
raf aircraft was 12 000 feet in the air
circling above aberdeen
aberdeenshire because aberdeen airport
was shrouded in missed nothing was
landing you could hear the helicopters
north sea helicopters hovering unable to
land and the new prime minister was
unable to get down herself so it was
circling above aberdeen should i count
it
uh digitally on flight radar something
like four government u-turns before she
even started eventually however the mist
lifted she was able to get down the two
raf jets are parked on the runway ready
for the return journey of the xpm and
the future pm down south later today
i suppose one of the complications is
because she's late you know part of the
choreography and all this was to
compress the time that the queen had to
deal with this whole situation she has
mobility issues so now that this trust
has been delayed that will extend the
whole process which i suppose doesn't
sit quite well with uh the original
choreography but
these are the hitches
of
the modern day the modern day anointing
of a new prime minister when it all
comes down to functionality rather than
tradition as we know it
okay james we'll be back with you for
the departures james matthews they're
live for us at aberdeen airport well
let's talk now about one of the
thorniest diplomatic issues that liz
truss will have to wrestle with because
in northern ireland she faces the twin
challenges of a standoff with the
european union and trying to
re-establish power sharing between the
stormont
administration's fierce rivals well
let's go live to storm and now our
senior island correspondent david
blevins is there and david talking about
the protocol first of all this is an
issue of course that liz trust has been
intimately involved in as foreign
secretary
that's right and this morning again in
his farewell speech we heard boris
johnson talk about having got brexit
done but as far as northern ireland is
concerned brexit isn't done because the
northern ireland protocol the brexit
trading arrangement that created a
border in the irish sea to avoid there
being a need for one on this island is
the reason the dup has not returned to
the power sharing government here three
months after the election they want liz
trust to honor her promise to scrap that
protocol altogether but in doing so she
risks a trade war with the eu the uk's
largest trading partner and it's the
last thing the uk needs in the middle of
a cost of living crisis now remember it
was shin fein who won that election they
believe there are more pressing concerns
more pressing need to get storming back
and that is the fact that you needed
evolved government to support people
through a cost of living crisis that's
the quandary for liz trust does she
stick to her promise and scrap the
protocol or does she seek some kind of
negotiation
remember before he became prime minister
boris johnson said there would never be
a border in the irish sea he changed his
mind when he became prime minister and
she just might change hers to dermot
okay david manny thanks david blevins
live for us there in storm well let's
talk more now about some of the huge
domestic challenges faced by prime
minister liz trust my colleague greg
milam is in warrington greg
yeah good morning dermot from uh
warrington where we're looking at some
of those big challenges particularly
here in the north that are facing uh the
new prime minister warrington in many
ways is is typical of the nation as a as
a whole and i think we can give you some
detail on that uh now uh gross household
domestic income what people have left to
spend after they've paid their tax and
their key bills
was just under 21 000 pounds last year
that's compared to just over 21 000 for
the uk as a whole
housing here is slightly more affordable
than nationally with the average cost
8.3 times earnings compared to 10.1
nationally and that that figure often
skewed by the high prices in parts of
london overall prices in warrington rose
at 10.1 percent in the year to july
that's exactly the same as the national
figure
but real wages fell four percent in the
year to april compared to three percent
for the uk as a whole and 25 percent of
households in warrington will be living
in fuel poverty by october that's
spending 10 percent or more on energy
that's compared to 32 nationally of
course depending on what happens on
those those energy bills politically
here labor has controlled the council
pretty comfortably since 2011 but the
conservatives have been narrowing that
gap in in recent years there are two
westminster seats here uh warrington
north has been held by labour since it
was created in 1983 warrington south
traditionally more marginal
uh the conservatives gained that from
labour in 2019 and that's of course when
boris johnson made those promises to
people in the north and the midlands
that he would represent them better
appealing to warrington man
as it was described back then working to
man uh people who felt they've been left
behind and believed they could trust the
conservatives then well we could speak
to a warrington man carl oaks who runs
for quetzal business solutions we have a
new prime minister carl
business is obviously small businesses
very concerned like the rest of us about
what's happening just first of all
explain what what you do for small
businesses in this part of the world
good morning so our role is to help out
to arrange loans and funding so when a
small business goes to a bank
and a bank says no which is getting more
and more common that's when we step in
so our role is to
aid small businesses with their cash
flow and try and reduce some of their
stress and hassle have you heard
anything from from liz trust
that reassures you reassures those small
businesses that there are
that there's something ahead to look
forward to
not really the the policy noise that she
did make
was around corporation tax and around
lowering corporation tax but if you're a
small business you've actually got to
survive and get to that point for it to
be a benefit
i think the absence of tangibles and the
absence of financial facts
actually as what's worried small
businesses
if there is action on energy we know
that the energy cap doesn't apply to
small businesses but if there is action
on energy prices
how essential is that how much would
that be welcomed by the kind of
businesses you're talking to
i think when you think about the
environment that we're in now surrounded
by bars and restaurants and casual
dining
i think
people having
even a little bit of money in their
pocket would help in terms of footfall
in terms of keeping bars and restaurants
alive so i think just that in isolation
would be a huge benefit we heard a lot
from boris johnson obviously leveling up
this talk of spreading equality around
the country a bit more that was three
years ago what have you seen here
have you seen anything here that
suggests that as that has happened has
started to happen that there's optimism
here
no not really i think um as a small
business ourselves we operate across the
country so we do spend time in the
southeast we do spend time in london so
i think we're fairly well placed to
kind of comment on that and i would say
i think there's been assurances and
promises but very little in the way of
delivery we heard a lot from from liz
trust about cutting taxes you mentioned
corporation tax income tax cuts
is that something that for a business
that is that is looking at the next year
wondering how they're going to get
through with with fewer people coming
through the doors that there is
something there that is a
is helpful
i think the reality from a small
business perspective is is intervention
that will add value now
so i think again let's point to bars
restaurants retail i think if you think
about the cost of rates if you've got
business premises i think something like
that
in the short term would boost confidence
far more than any assurances down the
line and just one thing what one thing
would you like to hear from liz trust
today i'd like to hear that
small businesses are going to be
supported through the storm so that
perhaps we can make some money when the
sun comes out
and do you think that i mean do you
think have you had a sense from from
this campaign that's gone on for a long
time that um
she understands the north that she
understands the issues that are
confronting people here no not really i
think that um
there's been some comments and perhaps
some sound bites that uh are aimed at um
pleasing us but
it probably sounds more like we're being
placated than pleased if i'm honest so
uh the the devil's in the detail and
let's see
comparing her to boris johnson and what
we've seen over over three years you did
say to me earlier you thought she
perhaps would get down to business a bit
more perhaps than rishi sunak would have
done would have would have taken this
seriously is that a fair assessment i
mean do you do you have hope that there
is something there that she could
deliver i think that um liz truss is far
more likely to try and help in the short
term
by way of a direct comparison to rishi
sunak i think rishi sunak was
was concerned that we kept kicking the
can down the road
so i think he was more along the lines
of let's just suffer it now so that we
can protect tomorrow whereas i do think
liz trust is the more likely person to
try and help in the short term i
mentioned warrington man it was wigan
man workington man it was it was uh
working class rugby league towns
where people had voted for brexit felt
they've been left behind and that that
did the job in 2019 do you sense that
those people who took that bet in 2019
would would do so again
come the next election
no and and i think there are perhaps
some emotional reasons as well as
economic reasons behind that i think a
lot of trust has been lost
in the conservative party for various
reasons so
no i i i think there's going to be a lot
more consideration this time around
before promises are believed okay carl
oaks uh thanks very much for talking to
us this morning on some of the view from
here in uh here in warrington that issue
of leveling up that was
of course the promises made by boris
johnson the promises to repay that trust
is now for liz trust to deliver on those
back to you dermot
okay greg many thanks greg milam there
live for us in warrington and you are
watching sky news today live from
downing street coming up next i'm going
to be discussing the new prime
minister's formidable in tray as well as
her predecessor's legacy with the former
conservative party chairman eric pickles
lord pickles
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back let's leave westminster for
a moment or two and the family of olivia
pratt corbell the nine-year-old girl who
was shot and killed inside her own home
in liverpool last month has released a
statement let's find out more about it
with ashna horinak who's in liverpool
for us tell us about the statement ashna
just over two weeks ago that olivia
pratt corbell was shot at her home in
the dove court area of the city and
today we have heard from her father for
the first time john francis pratt who
has paid tribute to his daughter and
says words can't express the pain we are
going through after olivia was so fully
snatched away from us those responsible
need to know what they have done olivia
was a real bright spark who knew her own
mind had no problem making friends and
love to laugh and make people laugh
olivia's death cannot be in vain and we
want people to feel safe and be safe he
says that can only happen if we all come
together and make sure there is no place
for guns or those who use guns on our
streets or in our communities alongside
that statement released by olivia's
father it was also a video that he has
released to the public it shows him and
the nine-year-old girl a little bit
younger in this video at a christmas
market in liverpool city center
and she can be seen on that fairground
ride with her father holding on to him
and smiling it was 10 30 in the evening
on the 22nd of august when a masked
gunman entered olivia's home he shot
olivia's mother in the wrist a bullet
which then traveled and then struck
olivia in her chest killing the
nine-year-old girl ever since then there
has been an extensive murder
investigation that is continuing to
happen merseyside police the officers
investigating her death made four
arrests of four men on sunday the key
one being a 34 year old man who has been
arrested on suspicion of murder and of
attempted murder three other men have
also been arrested they are facing
allegations of assisting an offender but
the key to all of this is evidence
police are appealing
yet further for the public to come
forward yet more information to try and
piece together
the events that led up to the tragic
death of olivia a plea that has been
echoed by her father john francis pratt
today who has pre-paid tribute to his
daughter who loved to laugh and whose
life was cruelly cultured
ashley many thanks for your night there
in liverpool for us well uh
let's return to politics in the
installation of a new prime minister uh
i'm here in downing street live and i'm
joined now by lord eric pickles the
former cabinet secretary and of course
former conservative party chairman very
good to talk to you lord pickles
well-known
from the perspective of uh putting the
party back together again trying to get
some form of unity reestablished because
as we've all seen it's been a bruising
summer votes of no confidence in the
sitting prime minister mass resignations
then a seemingly interminable leadership
contest and a lot of bad blood spilled
what does this trust have to do to
reunite the party
well i think liz trust is going to be
judged on just one thing and that's our
ability to be able to
uh control the spiraling costs of
energy if she doesn't get that right no
matter how
close the conservative party gets
together no matter how many
interesting ideas she has she won't be
able to do anything else
so
largely the
the
the set and the program and the style of
the new prime minister will be set by
what she brings out on thursday
that is absolutely huge and it's
interesting what you say so the doubters
within the party and there are
many of them they're acquired at the
moment but you think they will then be
convinced if they see liz trust landing
something that will that will last and
will really help people out
yes i mean it's uh
in many ways you've got to turn the
telescope the other way around
uh the future of the party the future of
this government the future is this
country depends on how we react to this
unofficial declaration of economic war
by uh by mr putin
isn't as all we're acting to in response
to the vigorous of the market this is
this crisis hasn't occurred because
because russia thinks we're soft and
rishi thinks that if they squeeze us
economically that we will allow him to
do what he wants in trying to recreate
the soviet union so in a time of
of virtual war we've got to protect the
most vulnerable we're going to protect
those on low incomes we've got to ensure
there's social cohesion within within
the nation
and as you're pointing out there lord
pickles what a task that is
you've described it is this trusts the
woman then to match it is she the one to
sort it out what tell us more about your
assessment of her character and her
abilities
well this is a pretty happy day for me
because
she was one of the young candidates that
came in when i was
chairman of the conservative party um
from my associations with over the years
she is a formidable person
people i think have underestimated her
at their costs
i certainly found that she was always on
top of a brief
that um as you know most of the
big business of good muslim
in cabinet committee and sometimes
you'll have cabinet ministers that will
turn up there and we'll just read the
brief of their officials she was never
like that she always was interested in
the argument she always wanted to make a
point
but she's actually also quite a good
listener
well i mean you point out there some of
the qualities that apparently uh the
previous prime minister or shortly to be
previous prime minister did not have
that attention to detail that reading of
the contents of the red boxes how do you
think boris johnson if he had got to
stay would be matching up to this huge
challenge
well i'm sure he i'm sure he would have
done i'm sure he would have um
one thing about boris is he was always
always very good in a crisis
i think we need to thank him for
uh altering the vaccines and i don't
think that would have happened without
him i think he understood the nature of
um
of the threat
that
the russian invasion of the ukraine
but unfortunately uh
you know
he is flawed and he's been rather
brought down by some very silly parties
and some very
silly spinning and it's a tragedy
because he's got a lot to give uh to uh
the country i'm sure
that he his public life is not over and
he and he will be able to give
something back uh to the country
although probably not through downing
street
okay but but through parliament you
think he could have another senior
position ahead of him
yeah
he is
a force of nature
i think you'd be foolish to write him
off uh off now um there are very few
successful second acts in politics
um perhaps churchill is is the exception
to the rule in terms of going back to
the top job but certainly i would have
thought that uh
that boris johnson knows an awful lot to
to to to offer the country
well you talk about uh how formidable
his trust is so we talk about the size
of the challenges ahead she therefore
obviously needs a formidable team around
her and
if you add in mr johnson there there are
many abilities and plenty of experience
uh cabinet experience that she is not
going to have available to her for
various reasons do you think that is a
mistake and i'm talking about what
michael gove dominic rob and of course
the challenger rishi sunak
well i think she needs to get the very
best people around her
i think um loyalty is one thing but she
what she really needs to be able to have
our people who are
able to deliver because what we are
going to need is a lot of what my old um
uh my bookwork master called application
we clearly people who can get things
done and get things done
uh quickly and that does mean that you
need to draw from people who didn't vote
for you as well as people that didn't
vote for you
and you need to offer the and a
friendship i'm sure she's she's big
enough and
and uh
intelligent enough to do that
well just briefly on that law pickles
when you're talking about delivery and
the ability to get things done you're
really talking specifically are you
about one person michael gove
i'm a big fan of michael uh uh
i mean he effectively kind of just ruled
himself out i i think he said you want
to to serve or i may be uh mistaken
uh but uh nobody will be happier than
myself to see uh michael uh back in
government
lord pickles always great talking to you
thank you very much indeed eric pickles
there of course former party chairman
amongst many of the jobs he held in
government now then the new prime
minister as discussed is thought to be
drawing up plans to tackle the cost of
living crisis that could see at least
100 billion pounds of support for
consumers the emergency package is
expected to include freezing energy
bills for homes and businesses until at
least january next year and possibly
until 2024 it's also expected that
energy suppliers will be able to take
out government-backed loans to subsidize
people and businesses built
let's talk about the huge economic
challenge then with our business
presenter ian king he joins us from the
city and uh ian crucial to to this whole
project if we can call it that is the
view of the city of the of the
international investors in united
kingdom plc
well that's absolutely right dermot and
the financial markets have been uh
telling you very clearly over the last
uh six weeks or so just what investors
think of the prospects for the uk
economy the pound has sold off pretty
sharply yesterday on monday it hit a
two-year low against the us dollar now
the u.s store is pretty strong across
the piece right now but nonetheless that
was pretty disconcerting
gilts meanwhile uk government bonds uk
government ious will yields on them in
other words implied borrowing costs
they've also been rising if you take for
example the 10-year guilt will yield on
that stood at 1.7
at the beginning of august it's now
closer to three percent it's just shy of
three percent as we speak in other words
that's an implied increase in government
borrowing costs and a lot of that boils
down to what the government is going to
have to do to tackle these higher energy
bills now the big debate going on in liz
truss's team is whether they go for a
targeted approach helping the most
vulnerable households and businesses or
whether they go for blanket support what
we've got at the moment the existing uh
proposals unveiled by rishi sunak of
course when he was chancellor costing
some 37 billion pounds by the way dermot
well that's a it was kind of a hybrid
you've got a flat 400 pound rebate to
household bills that's due later this
year there's also a rebate on cancel tax
bills for less well-off households and
there's also targeted support through
the benefit system so it's a kind of
hybrid system now what we think liz
truss's team is going to come down in
favor of is blanket support which as you
say would encourage the household energy
suppliers to cap prices that would
probably be at the existing level of
1971 pounds you wouldn't get an increase
to uh
3549 pounds asses uh due to be uh coming
in in october that would obviously
require the household energy companies
to be operating at a loss so you're
looking at some sort of backstopping for
them either by state-backed loans or
indeed government borrowing outright we
don't know the fine details of that but
either way implicit in all of that is a
great deal more government borrowing if
it's not if it's all if it comes down to
this sort of private sector solution
well essentially that's going to have to
be repaid in over the next 15 years or
so via a levy on household bills and
that effectively would equate to a big
tax increase so it's not likely to be
very popular further down the line so
the government may just decide in fact
to hike up government borrowing now one
big drawback derma with all of this is
that there is no incentive for
households or businesses to actually
start rationing their energy use to try
and reduce their energy
consumption because obviously at higher
prices there's a big big incentive for
people to do that and a lot of industry
analysts are suggesting well if you just
go for this blanket support for
households and businesses with no
incentive via the pricing mechanism to
conserve energy will potentially you
could be looking at rationing at some
point this winter and that is something
that is certainly being on the minds of
a lot of european governments right now
as they uh throw money at the problem as
well now as i say we have yet to get a
firm costing as to how much this is all
going to be i mean the number being
banded around is as much as a hundred
billion pounds uh 40 billion alone to
support vulnerable businesses and if
that was true well i mean that would be
vastly more expensive than the
government support that was given to
businesses during the furlough scheme
during the pandemic it would also be
significantly higher than some of the
money that is being thrown at this
problem by european governments for
example germany's latest package of
support comes to a total of some 65
billion euros so it would be appreciably
ahead of that and that partly reflects
the fact that the uk is just that bit
more dependent on imported gas than some
of our continental european counterparts
now there's another kicker to this derma
which is that quasi-kartang likely to be
the incoming chancellor is also likely
to step up moves to try and reform the
way the energy market works and one
reason that we have had these big
increases is because of what's known as
marginal pricing whereby household
energy is priced at effectively the most
marginal supplier which tends to be gas
rather than cheaper renewables and
accordingly uh the that's that is why
the electricity market is
in the views of some people broken boris
johnson's government pledged to try and
tackle this but never really got
anywhere with it it's likely to be a big
big priority for quasi-kartang as he
goes into number 11 downing street
trying to break up this relationship
between wholesale gas prices and the
electricity market but that would also
require a great deal of intervention in
terms of how contracts for uh energy
supplies are drawn up that's a lot of
work involved in that which is why i
think liz trust is thinking in the short
term of just going for this big package
of blanket
ian thanks for explaining all that so
clearly and cogently in king our
business presenter there let's talk more
now with our deputy political editor
sam coats and sam talking about the the
scale end of this challenge particularly
on energy and the cost of living crisis
and just to refer back to what lord
pickles
was telling me a few minutes earlier
about
how she heals the party how his trust
heals the party he says it's through
this mechanism as well it's kind of one
huge shot but it solves a lot of
problems if she gets it right i was very
struck eric pickles saying that her
premiership will be defined by what she
does over the energy price conundrum and
i think on this specifically we're
learning quite a lot about liz trust
because it was only august the 16th so
barely what three weeks ago the liz
trust was saying it would not be right
to quote throw money at the problem
without dealing with the root causes
and suggested uh that there would be no
short-term fix if she became prime
minister now she's likely to throw about
a hundred billion pounds plus at the
problem uh and it's gonna take some time
to do the fundamental fixes to the
energy market that ian king was talking
about but there does seem to be a one
big unresolved question about liz
truss's energy plans and ian referred to
it and that is the question of whether
or not it is all paid for by borrowing
so future generations or whether or not
there's some attempt to claw it back in
time through uh energy bills now you can
see liz trust being cautious about
anything that could be branded a tax
rise but if the markets see liz trust
embarking on a plan to cost 100 billion
pounds over this year and then president
putin still inflicting his cold war in
2023 and 2024 so an open-ended uh
commitment to spending on a vast scale
after the covert pandemic then maybe
those are the circumstances in which
borrowing costs could go up and there
could be some nervousness in the city
there's something else to throw in there
about the price cap
the talk is that it'll be at the level
it has been set now which people are
already hurting because of this price
cap and it is of course the summer even
under this price cut people are going to
get into difficulties absolutely you
hear a lot about uh marginal price
reform uh
on the kind of economic side there's
potentially only marginal benefit
politically for spending 100 billion
pounds because people will be hurting
exactly as you say because of what's
already happened so potentially liz
trust might not reap a huge benefit
from these vast sums she's preparing to
spend because actually people are poorer
than they were at the start of the
parliament when they elected this
conservative government and with a
recession coming and more energy price
challenges ahead it's hard to see how
people won't really be feeling the
squeeze over the next couple of years in
those circumstances she can spend all
she wants and it sounds pretty much like
she's prepared to spend as much as any
sitting prime minister you know in the
last 70 years
and not necessarily
find that the voters are flooding her
with thanks okay sam for the time being
thank you very much indeed deputy
political editor sam coats there let's
just look at the latest pictures coming
to us from the northeast of scotland uh
location of bowel moral of course where
her majesty the queen unable to travel
to london because of ongoing mobility
issues and that is that the small
motorcade carrying boris johnson and his
wife carrie who we sure saw a few
minutes ago about half an hour ago
entering the grounds of balmoral castle
being ushered in to see her majesty the
queen tendering his resignation which
now has presumably being accepted he is
prime minister no more and shortly to be
installed or having just being installed
is liz truss
who will be approaching those grounds
not entirely sure whether she has
arrived yet in the interim the
interesting constitutional point is of
course that there are a few minutes when
uh there actually is no prime minister
and therefore executive power reverts to
her majesty the queen uh we'll update
you on that process as soon as we hear
more about it but let's talk then about
the imminent installation of this trusts
as uh britain's new prime minister if it
hasn't already happened she'll be the
third female prime minister of course
all of them conservative after meeting
as she meets her majesty the queen in
balmoral so are we finally getting to a
place where a female prime minister
isn't seen as unusual if it isn't
already and what else can we expect from
her new government let's uh discuss that
much much more now with catherine hadden
a senior fellow at the institute for
government good to talk to you catherine
harden though well let's uh we'll talk a
bit more about the third female prime
minister all of the conservatives as
i've pointed out but just just tell us
what you think the difference will be
between a trust administration and a
jonathan johnson administration in terms
of the way they conduct themselves
well we're already hearing a certain
amount of change uh in the working of
number 10 and remember for boris johnson
how his number 10 was organized whether
it was serving him well whether it was
serving the rest of government well that
was a big issue so we kept hearing about
resets you could argue that this is yet
another reset of that number 10 this
time without boris johnson there but
also actually quite a lot of his staff
will have already left number 10 uh and
liz truss's new team will be installing
themselves so there could be some big
changes at the center to try and
organize in a better way and that's
quite usual for a prime minister that
they often react to the previous
incumbent uh and tried to say that i'm
going to do things completely
differently
so i think there'll be a change of tone
in in in that respect a change of
organization a bit also um i guess we're
still waiting to see what kind of prime
minister she's going to be um you know
we heard a very brief bit from her
yesterday but
that full speech later today is probably
going to be the first clue where we get
a sense of how does she want to govern
what is the kind of language that's
going to typify that and and most
importantly as you were just discussing
what are the key policies at the heart
of it
yeah and the implementation of those
policies we hear from prime minister
after prime minister we heard it of
course from boris johnson the
frustrations that they have about
the decisions taken by prime ministers
and then them not actually happening
pulling levers and there's no one
seemingly at the end of them do you
expect a shake-up then in the way that
the downing street as a whole operates
the people around liz truss yeah i mean
in a sense it's a frustration for those
of us on the outside because the same
problems we keep talking about in terms
of how government operates and
it isn't as easy of just saying this is
a problem of the civil service they've
got to get their act together which
often is what happens government is a
huge huge organization when you take
into account the size of public services
you know the levers that ministers have
to control them
and and also what you've got to do in
terms of delegating that power it's a
massive operation it's very complicated
to deal with but we know a lot about how
to do it successfully we know you need
decent lines of accountability you need
good reporting structures good data
and also you need clarity from ministers
and this is one of the things that she's
got to make sure that from the get-go
her government is delivering if she's
going to have a smaller center which is
what she's talking about
does that mean that she is delegating
more to cabinet ministers are we going
to see cabinet ministers more empowered
than perhaps they had been under boris
johnson how is liz trust going to react
then if things start to go wrong and she
wants to claw back that power for
herself so it's a really tricky
balancing act it's much easier to talk
about it than to get it um
you know than to do it in practice but
she she kept talking about delivery i
think that's the key test that we're
going to have to look out for
and catherine just really really briefly
diversity whatever political cue you are
we understand it in the the top four
jobs no white men
yeah and another female prime minister i
mean all of this is really important we
still haven't had a female chancellor of
the exchequer that's another sort of
important glass ceiling you might talk
about
i do think we'll see more diversity uh
certainly in this cabinet we won't see
about all those all important junior
ministerial positions where the more
people are brought through the pipeline
so so lots to watch out for the more the
better catherine hardin really good
talking to uh catherine hadden there
from the institute for government you're
watching sky news today live from
downing street coming up one prime
minister leaves another one about to
arrive
[Music]
this is sky news today live from downing
street it's 12 o'clock
boris johnson bows out at balmoral
promising to get behind the new prime
minister in a defiant final speech
i am now like one of those booster
rockets
that has fulfilled its function and i
will now be gently re-entering the
atmosphere and splashing down invisibly
in some remote and obscure corner of the
pacific
this truss lands at aberdeen airport and
is due to be appointed prime minister by
her majesty the queen in the next few
minutes
she begins her first day facing an
energy crisis but promising at least a
hundred billion pound energy price
freeze
and that could last until the next
election
i'm in warrington looking at some of the
big challenges facing the new prime
minister as she begins her first day in
the job
also ahead new video is released of
olivia pratt corbell as her father says
her death cannot be in vain
and a man in his 20s is shot dead by
police in south london after a car chase
[Music]
a very good afternoon from downing
street where boris johnson has said his
final goodbyes promising to get behind
the new prime minister liz truss every
step of the way
and in the last hour he's been to bound
moral accompanied by his wife carrie to
meet her majesty the queen and formerly
tender his resignation
well a bit earlier he left downing
street for the final time as prime
minister and in his last speech he
described himself as a booster rocket
that has fulfilled its function
championing his administration's
achievements highlighting brexit the
vaccine rollout and the response to the
war in ukraine
well this is
this is it folks thank you everybody for
coming out
so early this morning
in only a couple of hours i will be in
balmoral to see her majesty the queen
and the torch will finally be passed to
a new conservative leader the baton will
be handed over in what has unexpectedly
turned out to be a relay race they
changed the rules halfway through but
never mind that now
and through that lacquered black door a
new prime minister will shortly go to
meet a fantastic
group of public servants the people who
got brexit done
the people who deliver the fastest
vaccine rollout in europe and never
forget 70 of the entire population got a
dose within six months faster than any
comparable country that is government
for you that's this conservative
government
people
who organized those prompt early
supplies of weapons to the heroic
ukrainian armed forces an action that
may very well have helped change the
course of the biggest european war for
80 years and looking at what is
happening in this country the changes
that are taking place
that is why private sector investment is
flooding in more private sector more
venture capital investment than china
itself more billion pound tech companies
sprouting here in the uk
that in france germany and israel
combined and as a result
unemployment as i leave office
unemployment down to lows not seen since
i was about 10 years old and bouncing
around on a space hopper my friends and
on on the subject of
on the subject of bouncing around in
future careers
let me say that i am now like one of
those booster rockets
that has fulfilled its function and i
will now be gently re-entering the
atmosphere and splashing down invisibly
in some remote and obscure corner of the
pacific
and
like cincinnatus
i am returning to my plow
and i will be offering this government
nothing but the most fervent support
this is
i'll tell you why this is a tough time
for the economy
this is a tough time for families up and
down the country we can and we will get
through it we will come out stronger the
other side
but i say to
my fellow conservatives it's time for
politics to be over folks it's time for
us all to get behind liz truss and her
team and her program
and deliver for the people of this
country
because that is what the people of this
country want that's what they need
and that's what they deserve together we
have laid foundations that will stand
the test of time whether by taking back
control of our laws or putting in vital
new infrastructure great solid masonry
on which we will continue to build
together
paving paving the path
of prosperity now and for future
generations
and i will be supporting liz truss and
the new government every step of the way
thank you all very much thank you and
goodbye thank you
that was boris johnson's farewell here
in downing street about half past seven
this morning well our deputy political
editor sam coats was uh listening to
that speech and is now going to bring us
up to date on what's happened at
balmoral boris johnson is no longer
prime minister the baton relay of
british politics as boris johnson said a
few hours ago right here is very much
underway in the last few seconds we've
had a message uh from uh the queen it
says the right honourable boris johnson
mp had an audience with the queen this
morning and tended his resignation as
prime minister and first lord of the
treasury and which her majesty was
graciously pleased to accept so as we
speak uh the monarch in balmoral with
all power at her fingertips for another
few minutes until liz trust comes in and
she is appointed uh prime minister
by the queen and then i think things are
going to start moving quite quickly um
right now we know that plans are
underway already for changes inside the
building behind me liz trust is planning
to slim down downing street the key
change that she's thinking of there is
to actually remove quite a lot of the
civil servants that are involved in
delivery in making things happen uh
under boris johnson's premiership she's
got a much smaller team a much younger
team that are gonna deliver her plans
then after that we're going to see the
cabinets start to arrive now
liz trust has been pretty much nailed on
to be prime minister for about three
weeks now so she has a lot of plans
already set so don't expect this to last
long into the night i think boris
johnson i think liz trust uh will
appoint people pretty quickly we'll see
them in quite short order uh come up
down the street we know who these senior
officers of the state are likely to be
quasi-cuatang going into the treasury so
allah braverman uh will replace pretty
patel uh in the home office ben wallace
uh will be uh continuing uh i think in
the defense department james cleverly uh
her ally
uh will go into the foreign office i
mean as you point
all allies what about this issue of
reaching out across the divides which
that bitter campaign opened up and
illustrated for us doesn't she have to
do some healing within the party offer
some of them some big jobs there are
some people briefing mostly anonymously
to exactly making that point theresa
may's former chief of staff gavin
barwell however has gone public with
exactly that point in the last few
moments he says that liz trust risks
repeating boris johnson's mistake of
favouring allies and it will be one of
the least experienced cabinets in me in
modern times at the top think
quasi-quieting james clevery cleverly so
ella breverman versus jeffrey howe lord
carrington and willie whitelaw i think
that actually not all of those figures
under thatcher were quite as experienced
perhaps as gavin barwell uh makes out
but there is definitely a feeling
amongst some bits of the sunnah camp
inside parliament that she does need to
potentially do more than we think she's
going to do from all the leaks of what's
going to be in her cabinet uh
to reach across the party and heal this
device in terms of the challenges the
challenge ahead it was interesting
during the course of the campaign how
the penny really dropped they have
talked and talked an awful lot about a
wide range of things and it has focused
down in the last few weeks on this huge
cost of living crisis at its center the
energy crisis do nothing and millions go
into poverty within in a matter of
months it looks as if uh liz trust this
week will set out a ginormous plan to
try and help people uh hundreds of
billions of pounds of borrowing in order
to cap the wholesale price of energy in
other words be able to fix business and
household energy build
we've learned quite a lot from the her
decision to do that just a few weeks ago
she was saying caps don't aren't
appropriate she was saying short-term
fixes don't work she was saying throwing
money at the problem doesn't work she is
already proving herself to be something
of a more flexible uh politician than
perhaps she comes across in the way she
likes to present herself as a
conservative who will govern as a
conservative that's what she said uh
when she was chosen to be the next prime
minister yesterday but actually in the
opening decisions it does appear as if
she is able that she is willing to do
more uh when her back is against the
wall uh in order to help families
perhaps even if some of those solutions
do rub up against some of the
conservative principles that we've heard
at espoused uh over the last few weeks
wow well on a plate uh sam thank you
very much indeed for the time being well
uh let's just check in if formerly liz
trust is prime minister as you know the
whole process is taking place in
balmoral the uh queen's summer residence
because of her mobility issues her
majesty unable to travel to buckingham
palace where this process normally takes
place boris johnson has officially
resigned in that resignation has been
accepted by her majesty the announcement
read out by sam a few moments ago liz
truss is shortly behind boris johnson
for her audience with her majesty uh
let's check in then on the progress of
that process with our royal
correspondent uh rhiannon mills and
rhiannon do we know uh when if the uh
the kissing of hands as it's called
although i know that doesn't actually
take place
if when that has happened
so yesterday it was anticipated that we
were due to see liz truss
arrive here at balmoral around quarter
past 12 about 20 past 12 for that
all-important audience it has to be said
that liz trust definitely has had the
more rough side of the weather when it
comes to arriving here in scotland we
know there was some difficulties with
her plane landing at aberdeen airport
because it was so foggy but we do know
that she is on her way here now in a car
and we're in that kind of no man's land
at the moment where the unusual
situation where at the moment we don't
technically have a prime minister so
executive power rests in the hands of
the queen and because of that i think
despite the fact that it's happening
here in scotland rather than down at
buckingham palace there was still this
need to make sure that the process
happened as quickly as possible or at
least is seen to happen as quickly as
possible so yeah liz trust won't be too
far behind uh boris johnson and of
course the queen now has graciously
accepted his resignation we've just had
that notice through from buckingham
palace and then it's up to liz trust now
to form a new government and as you said
the kissing of hands as it's recorded in
the court circular will happen where the
queen invites liz trust to form a new
government and it's at that moment that
she will officially become prime
minister now joining me here is louise
tate who was the former communications
secretary to the queen here in scotland
and we've already seen how this process
of the arrival happens with boris
johnson and carrie johnson we'd expect a
similar thing had to happen wouldn't we
with liz truss yes i think you we've
seen this very similar um arrangement of
buckingham palace and i think that
arrangement has just been replicated up
here and it's a very similar process i'm
sure it will be the queen's duty private
secretary who seems to be so edward
young i believe and the equity who will
meet this trust and her husband on
arrival and then they'll be taken inside
through the portugal because it is worth
reminding ourselves this is history in
the making every one of the queen's 14
prime ministers up until this point has
always been appointed at buckingham
palace there was some surprise that it
was going to happen here at balmoral but
there is nothing unconstitutional about
it and ultimately the queen still right
throughout her summer break continues
her duties doesn't she you've seen that
place this is this is a continuation of
the queen's formal constitutional role
she continues to perform her head of
state duties here at balmoral that's
well documented the red boxes and so
forth it is
how the business of head of state has
done and this is a continuation of that
and it is exactly a replica pretty much
what happened bucket powers it's just
happening here at balmoral because
earlier we saw her private secretary
edward young a very important man who
kind of private is in in in the shadows
um but he this morning presumably the
red box would have been on her desk this
morning for her to look as as usual i'm
pretty certain yeah i can't imagine why
it wouldn't
but it isn't unusual as well for prime
ministers to come here to balmoral we
were talking earlier about how actually
it's a really important
summer moment for every prime minister
to be invited to spend some quiet time
with the queen yes yes and it is
traditionally around this time of year
it's uh it's it's not uncommon for it to
be this up the forum the first weekend
in september um and this year has been
you know different because the
circumstances are different so there is
it's not a precedent for this situation
but it's certainly not unusual for a
prime minister to come and visit her
majesty and spend some time here at bomb
now members of the public are allowed to
kind of look outside and go into the
grounds here at balmoral i did it
earlier in the summer it's you
immediately get that sense of of how
remote it is how it's a place that the
queen feels that she can come away to to
escape in some ways that presumably will
maybe change the tone of those meetings
today despite the formalities being the
same
um
i'm not sure i i i think you know that
this is a place where the queen is very
very at home um it is her home
and i it might feel slightly less formal
perhaps but i'm guessing i i
i think it'll just be a very
still
everyone making sure that everyone's put
at ease understands what's about to
happen next
and so that everyone feels confident
that each stage of the process they're
looked after and understands what
they've expected to to do louise thank
you very much for now we are still
waiting for liz trust to arrive of
course in the car alongside her likely
to be her husband hugh o'leary because
we know that carrie johnson arrived with
boris johnson and that has become
customary that while those
formal audiences happen with the
outgoing and incoming prime ministers
i'm just potentially hearing a car
behind me no nothing to worry about the
moment while the private kind of
one-to-one happens with the outgoing and
incoming prime minister the spouse is
then invited in at the end so i think
this is likely to be the first time
that liz truss's husband will meet the
queen as louise said to the queen always
very adept at making sure that everyone
feels at ease in her company gordon
brown also described that how after that
kissing of hands that formal moment you
become prime minister happens he then
sat down with the queen and had a little
bit of a more business-like discussion
of course plenty for liz trust to
discuss and i think very important for
many people today to see the queen
people have been concerned about her
health seeing her many as a symbol of
stability continuity and that's exactly
what she's doing today carrying out one
of the most important constitutional
roles
okay really
keep listening for the crunch of those
tires on the gravel we'll be back with
you when liz trusts arrives and if you
scan the qr code on your screen you can
listen to the latest episode of the sky
news daily podcast with neil paterson
who's been gathering reaction with the
dailies team to list trusts winning the
conservative leadership race you can
subscribe to the daily free wherever you
get your podcast from
and you're watching sky news today
coming up
i'm in warrington looking at some of the
big challenges facing the new prime
minister as she begins that first day in
her new job
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm stuart ramsey and i'm sky's chief
correspondent
well there's a real sense now that
people are beginning to expect that this
whole airlift is coming to an end and
they're really really desperate
we saw snatch squads going in grabbing
people and putting them into trucks
you either live and recover
or you die
okay so that's like a wall that's the
war yes
we help you understand the world with us
over the past 24 hours the soldiers have
been attacked on a number of occasions
[Music]
it's really sending a clear message that
venezuela is eager for change
we've been crushed
to take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
they were convinced the united
[Music]
exposure states just come down i think
it was a monster just landed in between
us
the information on this could bring down
the entire network not just in iraq and
syria but across the world
[Music]
hot
and here we can see
liz truss
leader of the conservative party and
soon to be the new prime minister of the
united kingdom arriving
at val morrell castle making that short
drive up the driveway where in just a
matter of moments she will be met
by
the queen's equi lieutenant colonel tom
white and also the queen's principal
private secretary sir edward young and
the process that formal process the
handover of power is in a matter of
minutes
going to be
complete
joining me now is uh louise tate let's
just move louise next to a microphone so
that we can
talk about what we're expecting to see
in the next few moments we've already
seen this play out with boris johnson
and carrie johnson arriving earlier you
can see there uh the equi the principal
private secretary and members of the
household waiting inside that covered
entrance hall and
so they will
drive
this portico
and
shortly get out for what is going to be
a very important first meeting
of course um
it's a very dramatic moment that you
said rihanna on the weather has really
um learned to send some sense of drama
to the occasion um and it's very it's
not on typical this part of the world
um but i think it has just added to the
atmosphere uh balmoral is a very
atmospheric place
and i think that just
emphasizes that to be honest the weather
it'll keep the midges perhaps in the
insects away from which this part of the
world is famous especially the midges
and we were saying despite the fact that
this is for the first time not happening
at buckingham palace
everything all the logistics the
planning the formalities
run exactly to order and here she is liz
trust stepping out shaking the hands
there of lieutenant colonel tom white
and being met by the principal private
secretary edward young and the acura and
sir edward young they play a very
important role now don't they in making
sure that both liz truss and her husband
hugh o'leary are very aware of what
happens now it can be intimidating i
suspect meeting the queen for that first
time with the best will in the world you
know it's helpful to have just a
reminder of what's going to happen no
matter how accomplished you are i've
seen it many times
what happens next um so yes they're well
well looked after by senior officials in
this case we've got the equity and the
principal private secretary that's
perfectly normal
for the prime minister and
as you can see they will be taken inside
there will be perhaps a few moments of
informal discussion
um before the equity comes and we'll
take this trust in to meet with the
queen for her audience louise thank you
and yeah this is the important moment we
know boris johnson has already resigned
we know that the queen has graciously
accepted his resignation and now liz
trust will walk into the drawing room on
the ground floor at balmoral castle and
have her moment with the queen the queen
will ask her to form a new government
and at that moment the kissing of hands
as it's described just simple handshake
at that moment liz truss will finally be
prime minister i can hand you over now
to greg milan who is in warrington to
get reaction there
yeah good morning from from warrington
where we're looking at some of the
challenges facing liz trust now as prime
minister particularly uh here in the
north we're in the new state-of-the-art
warrington market which is very nice and
warrington is if you like a pretty
typical example of of the nation as a
whole and we have some some numbers that
lay that out for you gross household
domestic income what people have to
spend after they've paid tax and key
bills was just under 21 000 pounds last
year here that compared to just over 21
000 pounds for the uk as a whole
housing is slightly more affordable than
nationally with the average cost 8.3
times earnings compared to 10.1
nationally and that that national fair
often skewed by the high prices in parts
of london overall prices in warrington
rose at 10.1 percent in the year to july
that's the same as the national figure
but real wages here fell by four percent
in the year to april compared to three 3
for the uk as a whole
25 of households in warrington will be
living in fuel poverty by october that
is spending 10 percent or more on energy
that's compared to 32 nationally
depending of course on what happens with
with energy prices and politically labor
has controlled the council here in
warrington pretty comfortably since 2011
but the conservatives have been
narrowing that gap in recent years there
are two westminster seats here uh
warrington north held by labor since its
creation in 1983
warrington south traditionally more
marginal
the conservatives gained that from labor
in 2019 with that that surge in the old
red wall states and so many issues for
the new prime minister to deal with one
of them the issue of the nhs and social
care dave thompson from the warrington
disability
partnership is is here with us morning
dave um so many issues as we were saying
there for the new prime minister the nhs
and social care among them and you were
telling me some of the stories you've
been hearing in recent days just about
how critical that situation is for
people
it is greg and people just
just about managing groups of people who
yesterday
a year ago were just about managing and
today with all the energy and fuel
crisis and cost of living and now tips
over the edge only last week one of our
uh our workers got a phone call from a
personal assistant that we support uh
who was supporting a disabled man and
when she got to his house she found that
he'd not eaten for two days
he'd had to use the money he had to put
into the gas and electric meters to keep
uh his powered wheelchair uh a bed
electric bed and he had a breathing
apparatus as well so if you imagine not
being able to eat or face actually sort
of the things that keep you alive
and this is the things that people can
be facing going forward the prime
minister's got a huge job because
disabled people in the main in past
strategies have been completely missed
because we get welfare benefits in in
the main but some of these welfare
benefits have now been taken into
account for people's social care costs
it's when social services are assessing
your ability to pay and contribute to
that care that could have been a year
ago two years ago well that did not take
into account today's energy costs did
you hear anything in in the leadership
campaign
that reassured you if you like that
those sort of issues are are going to be
addressed no not at all we heard lots
about people on universal credit but
lots of people who are just in that just
about managing bracket and not on
universal credit these are people who
are today having to face those major
decisions of food or energy
what do you want to hear when liz trust
speaks to the nation that she will later
today what if there's one thing you want
to hear from her what would it be it's
protecting those who are most vulnerable
and and when she talks about protecting
those women we don't want to simply hear
universal credits we want to hear about
disabled people older people
people with long-term health conditions
and it's that additional cost of living
with a disability and not just that it's
a support for the charities that support
them our energy costs have gone
threefold in the last six months and and
charities will literally be not able to
support people so without that the
critical sort of fallback then is on
social care and healthcare and that's
when the system will fall apart i'm
saying as well that you as a charity
you're still a business we know
businesses are being hit by the energy
price rises all these other costs of
inflation what what is the impact on you
as an organization
again fuel costs where we got three vans
on the road delivering we we set up a
business and to the charity 10 years ago
that contributes over a third of our
income to the charity that's that's what
we generate ourselves from the surplus
or the profits from the the busy sound
of the charity so that the cost of that
has gone up the cost of heating the
buildings have gone up the shops have
gone up uh the staffing costs have gone
up over the years um and social services
and the grants that we get from health
and social care have just not kept pace
and the expectation that we as a charity
could continue to pay that that cover
that gap i think is just not going
forward just not going to be viable
this was one of those seats in 2019 that
the conservatives won with with the
promise of leveling up we've had three
years of that where is warrington where
are those towns in the north now on on
that picture are you seeing any any
sense of equality being spread around
the country
i've been fortunate greg to actually be
on the leveling up fund in wellington
the town deal fund i can see the
difference that money has made and it
has made a difference and it will make a
difference going forward uh with the
whole health and social care academy uh
training much needed social care
assistance for tomorrow uh the health
and well-being center in warrington town
centre which will open next year um and
the leveling fund too we just put a bid
in for that and one of them is a center
for excellence around disability sports
so yeah there is somebody coming into
the town and we're really thankful of
that but it for me it's not just about
the leveling up fund it's about the
government strategy now about this
energy fuel costs and cost of living
crisis it's got to be now not in april
next year
okay dave thompson thanks very much we
wish you the best of luck to you and
your your team as i mentioned we're in
the new state of the art market here in
in warrington a lot of new businesses uh
that have moved in here from locations
elsewhere the old market for example
and we can um show you uh john cross and
sons family butchers since 1860 but new
in here john morning to you um
we've just been talking about these
these issues that so many businesses are
facing and now the new prime minister is
facing tell us a little bit about you
how you're being affected by in
particular the the issue of energy
prices yeah i certainly um from a
business perspective he's obviously
increased our overheads but from our
customers i think they're living in fear
there's so little disposable income
that's because the gas and electric
shooting up and we've noticed a
significant
um down turn in our customers
regular customers which is the backbone
of our business
which is a bit disconcerting
so
you know we
we
what would seasonally be an upturn for
us going into the autumn in the winter i
have a great deal of reservation
that we're going to get to the level of
trade we need to
new prime minister what's your view on
what what she will offer yeah well you
know you've got to she's got to back up
what she said she's going to do um you
know i i i mean we're in a
a a time in this country where we need
strong leadership so she's got to back
that up with actions um you know i mean
i'm just not going to turn things around
overnight obviously but
you know people
i think
we've been through a very difficult part
we covered and no governments but you
know that i've faced that before
but the some of the things we're being
faced with now we've got more control
over and i think people want to see
something done a bit sooner rather than
later and you have any optimism having
seen that that leadership campaign do
you have optimism that what was talked
about then will have an impact i mean
for you but also for those customers
that you say you're seeing who are
struggling yeah i think she's got to
she's got to put people have got to have
their faith restored
because i think the worst thing that
happened with the partygate scandal was
the the british public were lied to
and blatantly lied to
and i think they've got to do a lot to
get people back on their side
and how warrington we know one of those
seats that was targeted to the you know
we've just been talking about leveling
up and and the attempt to spread
equality do you think those who put
their faith in in the conservatives back
in 2019 maybe you'd always voted labor
have got what they wanted out of that
yeah well i mean warrington's always
been a very divided
you know labor in the north of the town
conservatives in the south
but i think
yeah i think at the moment i would say
there's a lot of
people disillusioned with the
conservatives so she's got a big job on
her hands
to turn this round
john well thanks very much we'll let you
get back to it uh an uncertain time for
the businesses who moved to this market
it opened in 2020 actually it stayed
open during lockdown because it was uh
because it was serving food and it's
pretty thriving today as you can see but
some uncertain times for the businesses
here and for those uh using them as well
we'll have more from warrington uh
during the course of the day but for now
back to you
greg many thanks greg marlon there and
you're watching sky news today coming up
a new plea from the family of olivia
black corbell the nine-year-old who was
shot dead in liverpool
[Music]
welcome back to downey street where as
we speak a new prime minister is being
installed but of course she because of
course it is liz trust is not here yet
she's in balmoral where that process is
taking place her majesty the queen
accepted boris johnson's resignation as
prime minister about half an hour ago
and liz trust is now being invited to
form a government she will then leave
balmoral and travel back down to london
here to downing street to make a speech
some time later this afternoon uh our
deputy political editor sam coats is
here with me and in that speech itself
already we want to hear from this trust
what is she going to do about the cost
of living crisis her premiership as some
have said this morning will be defined
by how she responds to soaring energy
prices that could bankrupt millions of
households in a matter of weeks if you
remember the energy price cap at the
moment is at 1
971
could go up to around uh 3500
early next year and then all the way up
to 5000. now we understand that uh liz
trust plans to freeze energy prices uh
at around 2500 that will be the cap uh
that she sets but she will also uh have
uh keep in place uh the
400 pound rebate uh that uh rishi sunak
promised the universal rebate uh for
everybody taking the price to not that
much more than the 1900 cap that is
coming in
imminently so liz trust wants to be able
to say this week that she is going to be
able to keep in place energy prices at
their current level at all just slightly
above uh their current level at a cost
uh it is expected of around
90 to 100 billion pounds so we now have
the first concrete details
of liz truss's energy plan there's one
really important thing here which is
there's been a debate all morning
there's been a debate bluntly i think
amongst liz truss's team about whether
just to borrow that money to compensate
people to shield them from the higher
excesses of the energy plan or whether
or not to uh put in place a plan which
would just simply see energy companies
borrow that money on favorable terms and
then have to
pay it back probably through higher
energy bills i understand that latter
option is not the case this will not see
energy price bills energy bills go up in
subsequent years amounting to something
like the kind of tax that liz trust
would say that she's against instead it
looks like this plan is just going to be
paid for straight out of borrowing uh
itself the markets i think will be uh
very interested in exactly the way uh
that this happens and how liz trust is
to make sure that if pleasant president
putin keeps in place uh a long-term uh
war and you know cold war as it were
again as it were against europe uh how
to make sure she's not on the hook for
hundreds of billions of pounds year
after year after year but that in
essence is liz truss's plan on day one
of a uh capping energy prices at about
2500 pounds
keeping the universal payment of 400
pounds and using those two things
together to claim the energy bills uh
for the next few months will not be that
much higher than the amount that she
inherited already of course a hell of a
lot higher uh than most people saw just
one year ago fascinating extra detail
sam thank you very much indeed sam coats
our deputy political editor there now
well away from politics
and the family of olivia pratt corbell
the nine-year-old girl who was shot dead
inside her own home in liverpool last
month have appealed for people to come
forward with information about who
killed her let's go live to liverpool
skies
is there well tell us more about what
we've been hearing from the family ashna
well it was just over two weeks ago now
that nine-year-old olivia pratt's
corvell was shot at her home in the
dubcot area of the city and today we've
heard for the first time from her father
john francis pratt was issued a tribute
to his daughter in which he says
we words can't express the pain we are
going through after olivia was so
cruelly snatched away from us those
responsible need to know what they have
done olivia was a real bright spark who
knew her own mind had no problem making
friends and loved to laugh and make
people laugh he goes on olivia's death
cannot be in vain and we want people to
feel safe and be safe and that can only
happen if we all come together and make
sure there is no place for guns or those
who use guns on our streets or in our
communities now following on from that
tribute issued by olivia's father is
also a video that he's also issued to
the public it shows olivia with her dad
at a christmas market in liverpool city
center
when she appears to be a little younger
she can be seen hugging him and she's
smiling in that video it was 10 30 on
the 22nd of august in the evening in
which a masked gunman entered olivia's
home and he fired a bullet that went
through into the wrist of olivia's
mother it then passed through her wrist
and entered olivia's chest killing the
nine-year-old girl officers here at
merseyside police who are investigating
olivia's death have made four arrests on
sunday including a key arrest a 34 year
old man arrested on suspicion of
attempted murder and attempt of
attempted murder
but also
um on suspicion of murder itself three
more men who have also been arrested on
suspicion of assisting an offender
police though continue their appeal for
more information from the public they
say they need to piece together together
the events that led up to the tragic
death of nine-year-old olivia they say
so far the appeal from the public has
been successful they have received an
immense amount of information but still
they need more that is a plea that has
been echoed today by olivia's father who
has paid tribute to his little girl who
loved to laugh and his life was
tragically cultured
okay ashley many thanks sasha mahinak
live there in liverpool let's return now
to the handover of power here in downing
street actually taking place in balmoral
let's look at who could be working in
the new top team under prime minister
liz truss well her cabinet is rumored to
include quasi quater as chancellor
sweller bravo man as home secretary
james cleverley
foreign office therese coffee perhaps
in hell fun jacob rees-mogg maybe as
business secretary uh former sky news
presenter and political editor anna
bolton joins us now for his assessment
uh and of course liz truss always said
she wants to hit the ground running a
lot of our top team already thought to
be in place
yeah i think those top four great
officers of state including the
premiership itself
they are do seem to be nailed on as
you've just said dermot and
interestingly it'll be the first time
ever in british history and remember
this is our 56th prime minister uh that
there has not been a white man in any of
those top four uh offices uh that is
certainly a sign of the diversity at the
top of the conservative party
we did you remember get a a putative
list at the weekend a well brief list at
the weekend of other cabinet
appointments and i think it's clear as
often happens in reshuffles that that
hasn't necessarily gone according to
plan uh for example sanji javid uh has
said that he doesn't want to serve in
the cabinet uh nadine doris has also
said she wants to go to the back benches
and of course uh we never quite clear
what was going to happen to pretty patel
well she said yesterday she's standing
down michael gove is another person
who's standing down doesn't look like
there's going to be a job for dominic
raab
and not quite clear i think in the
second tier below the great offices of
state quite who's going there therese
coffee as you say is being tipped to go
to health
not quite clear whether she's going to
go there yet we're hearing kit malt
house
might be going to education interesting
one i've heard although hasn't been
confirmed is that penny morton
uh who came third of course amongst the
mps in their preferences for the new
leader of the tory party uh suggested
she may become leader of the house which
i think would certainly be a popular
appointment uh with mps some people even
saying
she might be given the post of deputy
prime minister but we have to wait and
see and of course the big thing is how
long this is all going to take
because
we know that liz trust wants to hit the
ground running she wants to get
proposals as what she's going to do
about soaring energy prices through a
cabinet as soon as possible
but she can only do that once it's all
been appointed
okay adam many thanks adam bolton
well now on police have shot dead a man
in his twenties after a car chase ended
in south london offices say they were
pursuing a suspect vehicle last night
police apparently deliberately collided
with the car to force it to stop
bringing the pursuit to an end in
stretch hill
residents reported hearing gunshots and
a police helicopter in the sky above
there's a massive bang that's i thought
a neighbor's
roof had fallen off or something there's
a rule that
i think it was like boom like something
that maybe it bounced us and i looked
out the back window to see somebody had
fallen and straight away i didn't really
notice it before but straight away i
could hear the helicopter very close in
the air and that's not terribly unusual
for around here but it suddenly was like
you know just felt more intense so it's
usually very fairly calm around here so
it's a bit of a shock
well our crime correspondent martin
brunton joins me now live martin what
more details have you got about the
pursuit and the incident itself
well the
police watchdog the independent office
for police conduct has taken over
this investigation and their
investigators have been here
since last night working through the
night probably about to hand over to a
new team and the kind of thing they're
trying to establish is you know vital
things like was there a weapon a
non-police weapon
retrieved from the scene what was the
reason for the police pursuit those are
the vital questions um that will be
asked how many officers were involved
how many shots were fired and trying to
establish as closely as they can
the exact circumstances and what
prompted
the shooting were any shots fired at the
police now
i don't have answers to any of those and
i think at this stage
investigators aren't absolutely clear
they will have got
last night's initial statements very
brief statements from the officers
involved
but it may take some longer time to
establish exactly what happened
the facts according to the police are
that this happened just before 10
o'clock last night police had pursued
a vehicle from lambeth so sounds as
though it was heading south probably
hadn't traveled very far
they came to this road here
police rammed the car or um
not clear how violent uh that was
but they brought it to a halt
according to witnesses
the officers got out asked the driver to
get out
and
according to another witness the car
moved towards the police cars and then a
shot or shots were fired
there's no official identification of
the man who died but there is a name on
the street
friends of the man they think was the
victim here who died have been talking
about their um how distort they are how
they recognized him from the car number
plate the car still here
they say he was on his way to see
friends and they are like his family
completely puzzled and shocked about
what happened here last night
okay martin brunt in stratum in south
london thank you very much indeed
confirmed that it has officially
happened liz trusted now
officially prime minister of the united
kingdom let's show you the formal moment
when it happened
there it has been confirmed her majesty
the queen asking liz trust to form her
next government that is her 15th prime
minister the kissing of hands as you can
see there is actually a handshake taking
place in balmoral of course because of
the queen's ongoing mobility issues
confirmed thereby her use of that
walking stick but that is the moment
when liz truss
became the new prime minister of the
united kingdom it'll take her a little
while then to travel back here to
downing street to take over at number 10
itself and our deputy political editor
sam coats is here with me to talk us
through the scale then of the the task
the tasks that await her britain has its
56th prime minister liz trust the
longest serving member of the cabinet
has succeeded boris johnson in a contest
that few foresaw just a few months ago
liz trust outwitted her political foes
and her political friends to assume this
job uh becoming prime minister up in
balmoral in the last few minutes taking
on an in trade perhaps bigger than any
prime minister maybe since margaret
thatcher maybe since the second world
war
with conflict and strife
abroad
challenges at home
as we're at this perilous point with the
british economy within hours she has to
form a new government that her allies
say will mark a radical departure even
from the work of boris johnson and then
within days she's got to set out a bold
and far-reaching plan that will see her
help households all across the country
deal with this phenomenal rise in the
basic cost of living with the sharp
increase in energy
and what a contrast it's going to be to
just a few days ago those weeks of the
summer the long summer when boris
johnson referred to himself in his
farewell speech there as a as a booster
that comes back to earth you could use
another space analogy and say he's been
like
like a satellite in space orbiting
pointlessly that we lost contact with
the government has been doing nothing
now it's going to be all over as much as
it can for the last seven weeks nobody
would deny that effectively the british
government has been on hold where the
conservative party chose a successor to
boris johnson but if you were being a
bit more honest dermot you would
actually say that because of the scandal
that has engulfed boris johnson's
premiership across the final months that
has not been a clean single focus of
prime minister
for the prime minister because of the
multiple challenges remember we spent
months talking about parties we spent
months talking about the conduct of
boris johnson and those around him so it
would be wrong just to say that there
has been distraction in the last few
weeks there have been months and months
of
turmoil in the heart of government that
has acted as a distraction in a
parliament that has seen
i mean really some of the most
far-reaching events of our lifetime uh
with a pandemic
dealing with the aftermath of brexit the
leaving of the single market and the
customs union so huge administrative as
well as political challenges uh and then
more recently the far-reaching
consequences
of the war in ukraine uh which is having
uh a which is causing a blight both on
households and for businesses already uh
having to come to terms with so many of
those challenges that's why there has
been an accumulation of problems uh now
all landing uh on liz truss's in tray
she will be back in a few hours time
here for the first time to walk in
through that door as prime minister
giving us a speech that will set out the
direction of travel that would put
finding growth getting rid of that
anemic uh uh economic improvement that
she thinks has been at the root of
british problems for the last 20 years
she will put finding that at the heart
of her mission but first she's got to
deal with energy bills what about boris
johnson we heard him in that speech i
referred to talking about going quietly
in effect but you were here when i
interviewed lord pickles former party
chairman about an hour ago he said he
thinks he's boris johnson's got another
big political job in him he said not
perhaps in downing street what do you
think his ambitions boris johnson's
ambitions are
boris johnson has always been a master
communicator and i think what was
fascinating about his early morning
speech this morning is that he basically
did two completely contradictory things
he pledged to throw his loyalty behind
liz truss urging all conservatives to do
the same but he couldn't help himself
could he do that he couldn't help just
hint that he would be like cincinnatus
who went back uh to plow his fields and
then of course scholars fifth century bc
roman general who became dictator for 15
days to to help out the roman empire and
then went back to his farm and then
returned to help put out a rebellion so
the returning aspect of that perhaps
hinting some some of his ambition but so
long as he's an mp people will turn to
boris johnson uh he just attracts
attention uh tv cameras follow him so do
crowds of people who elected him in 2019
giving him something of a personal
mandate about which he and his allies
always used to talk uh having uh
inherited the crown at this point is
difficult enough for liz trust uh but
with the big political beast of boris
johnson looking down
over
her shoulder on the comments back
pensions it's just that bit harder
she has an ability to perhaps influence
though his political trajectory doesn't
she in terms of this parliamentary
inquiry the standards inquiry into
whether he misled parliament
or not that is getting underway there
are some key appointments a key
appointment has just taken place on the
conservative side now liz trust said
during the hustings that she wasn't a
great fan of this inquiry into boris
johnson but if it continues
and finds him guilty of misleading
parliament so it is in the position then
what to perhaps cost him his seat
um it is remarkable that boris johnson
was slung out by his own party a matter
of weeks ago because they
did not think he was a fit prime
minister that he
was bringing the office into disrepute
because there's a series of scandals
culminating of course uh in the decision
not to take swift enough action against
uh chris pincher
but now if you listen to liz trust she
talks to boris johnson as her friend
she welcomed him and thanked him uh
yesterday as she accepted the leadership
um she is not doing what many expected
which is to put a bit of distance
between him uh and her indeed she is
inheriting many and keeping many of the
key people in cabinet that also worked
around his cabinet table so in some ways
it looks like this is more continuity
it's just in the policy direction this
trust looks like she's going to go in a
sharply different uh direction forrest
johnson's political future is an
interesting one though that uxbridge
seat in west london that he inherits
that's going to be very hard to keep uh
whether the uh committee uh uh that now
has one more uh favorable conservative
to boris johnson on it that it did 24
hours ago whether that uh finds in his
favor or not it's not just before we go
to our top of the hour great just uh
talk us through again that breaking line
you got on where you think liz truss is
going to put the price cap the frozen
price cap in terms of one of her her
first actions as prime minister so what
we're hearing is that liz trust will set
the price gap as 2 500 pounds uh the
amount people will pay in practice lower
than that because of the 400 pounds uh
universal benefit that rishi sudak
agreed and then uh
and that will
for the next few months cushion people's
pain although of course bill's a lot
higher than they were the key detail
appears to be that that
help will not then be clawed back
through higher energy bills in future
but instead paid for by borrowing by
taxation uh passed on to future uh
generations as it were uh liz trust
doing what she said at the start of the
campaign that she wouldn't some might
call it a sticking plaster some say it's
um cash without reform uh but
nevertheless a big moment this week and
the big question then
who
pays about what the money markets make
of that the international money markets
well uh as we go to that break as i
mentioned there let's uh remain on that
picture from earlier this hour in
balmoral her majesty the queen the the
very moment that she is asking liz
trusts to form uh next government to
become her 15th prime minister much more
reaction coming up
[Music]
[Music]
this is sky news today live from downing
street it is one o'clock
this trust is formally appointed prime
minister as she has traveled to balmoral
to meet her majesty the queen
earlier boris johnson finally bowed out
promising to get behind the new prime
minister in a defiant final speech
i am now like one of those booster
rockets
that has fulfilled its function
and i will now be gently re-entering the
atmosphere and splashing down invisibly
in some remote and obscure corner of the
pacific
liz truss begins her first day facing an
energy crisis but promising a hundred
billion pound energy price freeze that
could last until the next election
i'm in warrington looking at some of the
big challenges facing the new prime
minister as she begins that first day in
the new job
also ahead new video is released of
olivia pratt corbell as her father says
her death cannot be in vain
and a man in his twenties is shot dead
by police in south london after a car
chase
[Music]
a very good afternoon from downing
street where liz truss will be returning
as the new prime minister in the next
few hours she traveled to balmoral this
morning accompanied by her husband to
meet her majesty the queen and formerly
to be asked to form her majesty's next
government the handover of power would
normally take place of course at
buckingham palace just down the road
from downing street but her majesty has
remained at balmoral as summer residence
because of her ongoing mobility issues
boris johnson and his wife carrie made
the same journey to balmoral a bit
earlier than liz trusts where he then
tended his resignation
and earlier mr johnson left downing
street for the final time in his last
speech as prime minister mr johnson
described himself as a booster rocket
that has fulfilled its function
championing his administration's
achievements they included brexit the
vaccine rollout and the response to the
war in ukraine
well this is
this is it folks thank you everybody for
coming out
so early this morning
in only a couple of hours i will be in
balmoral to see her majesty the queen
and the torch will finally be passed to
a new conservative leader the baton will
be handed over in what is unexpectedly
turned out to be a relay race they
change the rules halfway through but
never mind that now and through that
lacquered black door a new prime
minister will shortly go to meet a
fantastic group of public servants the
people who got brexit done
the people who deliver the fastest
vaccine rollout in europe and never
forget 70 of the entire population got a
dose within six months faster than any
comparable country that is government
for you that's this conservative
government
people
who organized those prompt early
supplies of weapons to the heroic
ukrainian armed forces an action that
may very well have helped change the
course of the biggest european war for
80 years and looking at what is
happening in this country the changes
that are taking place that is why
private sector investment is flooding in
more private sector more venture capital
investment than china itself more
billion pound tech companies sprouting
here in the uk
that in france germany and israel
combined and as a result
unemployment as i leave office
unemployment down to lows not seen since
i was about 10 years old and bouncing
around on a space hopper my friends and
on on the subject of
on the subject of bouncing around in
future careers
let me say that i am now like one of
those booster rockets
that has fulfilled its function
and i will now be gently re-entering the
atmosphere and splashing down invisibly
in some remote and obscure corner of the
pacific
and
like cincinnatus
i am returning to my plow
and i will be offering this government
nothing but the most fervent support
this is
i'll tell you why this is a tough time
for the economy
this is a tough time for families up and
down the country we can and we will get
through it we will come out stronger the
other side but i say to
my fellow conservatives it's time for
politics to be over folks it's time for
us all to get behind liz truss and her
team and her program
and deliver for the people of this
country
because that is what the people of this
country want that's what they need
and that's what they deserve
together we have laid foundations that
will stand the test of time whether by
taking back control of our laws or
putting in vital new infrastructure
great solid masonry on which we will
continue to build together
paving paving the path
of prosperity now and for future
generations
and i will be supporting liz truss and
the new government every step of the way
thank you all very much thank you and
goodbye thank you
that was boris johnson very early this
morning in downing street we are taking
out to the latest pictures from balmoral
uh that car or certainly uh a car nearby
carrying the new prime minister liz
truss
she arrived in balmoral as you can see
pretty murky conditions there she
arrived by aircraft at aberdeen
international airport then by road to
balmoral to be received by her majesty
the queen
to be formally asked to form
the government for her majesty and
become her majesty's 15th prime minister
a span that goes all the way in fact
to winston churchill boris johnson's
hero you can see there with uh look at
that the water there you can see there
the conditions
in the northeast of scott and we
understand that her aircraft coming in
had to circle for a bit and find an
opportune moment to get down on the
ground we know that she's returning
there
immediately and will then come back to
london now this is the time scale as we
understand it at the moment this trust
is then as prime minister expected to
make an address
here in downing street outside if the
weather conditions held up here in
central london in westminster or inside
downing street itself setting out her
stall as the new prime minister our
political correspondent joe pike is here
with me and you know what an entree as
they say and it is this energy crisis
this cost of living crisis that is front
and center it certainly is derma and i
think the fact that we already have a
pretty good idea of who this trust's
cabinet
is partly because of those crises coming
down the line incredibly fast she does
seem to have given the nod to a lot of
uh senior
allies for example quasi-cua saying as
chancellor sweller braverman as home
secretary james cleveland as foreign
secretary partly so they could use the
last three weeks of august to start
getting ready for their roles and get
ready for a package of support on cost
of living and energy which we expect to
announce later this week perhaps
thursday or friday certainly in the last
hour or so my colleague
sam coates has been firming up our
understanding of what is in that package
certainly looks like a cap around two
and a half
grand that is for an average household
per month that is significant but
strange that perhaps two days before
we'd expect to hear this from the prime
minister or account minister in the
house of commons we're already
understanding what the government wants
to do big question still over what
support there will be for businesses
businesses that are struggling and one
thing we do know is that the government
want to pay for this by borrowing that
may be the key dividing line because
labour of course at the heart of their
pitch for a cap on the price freeze was
the idea of a windfall tax on the
profits of oil and gas companies so a
bit of a difference there which we may
hear a lot more of in the commons
tomorrow at pmq's or in the later weeks
that's the politics of it all let's uh
talk about some of the well i suppose
the tradition of it and that is what has
taken place in balmoral earlier today
starting this morning the fact that this
is happening in balmoral uh the first
time i think for nearly 140 years since
lord salisbury went through the same
process with queen victoria and
illustrating then i suppose the
strangest of the times the fact that her
majesty can't travel she has these
mobility issues exactly in law salisbury
dermot i wasn't a huge fan of obama when
he went up to meet a queen victoria he
compared it to
siberia certainly the fact that the
monarch's health the monarch's mobility
is a priority over the prime minister
and former prime minister having having
like a journey is is uh significant and
it's also the start i think of an
important relationship that liz trust
will have because as prime minister as
all her
14 predecessors have had
this this weekly audience with the queen
sometimes in person sometimes over the
phone which historians certainly
say is a very important relationship
partly because of the confidence held
ben pimlott
one historian saying the
monarch is the constitutionally
sanctioned councillor and therapist the
only person a prime minister
can talk to whose confidence they know
will not be abused a very important
relationship of somebody who has seen
politics and crises for decades and
perhaps can provide some context and
advice even though you and i will never
know the content of those private
discussions okay joe for the time being
many thanks well let's concentrate more
now on
some of those economic challenges we've
just been discussing and the markets
have been making their own judgment
already about liz truss's economic plans
deutsche bank said what it calls a large
unfunded fiscal expansion significant
cuts to tax or rises in spending all of
which seem to be in this trust's plans
could damage investors confidence the
economic backdrop for the new prime
minister is extremely challenging to say
the very least gas prices of course
rose again yesterday our economics and
data editor ed conway has his analysis
so what are the main economic challenges
facing the new prime minister let's just
go through some of them some of them she
can control some of them she can't
including starting with this this shows
you wholesale gas prices so energy
prices and what you can see is just how
much they have ramped up uh in the last
few years and indeed the last few months
just look up to nearly a record high uh
just recently and it's been bouncing
around what with what's happening in
russia and ukraine that is something
that's feeding into all of our bills
obviously and we're starting to see that
now and the concern is if that stays
high it's even higher bills in the next
few months so that's the start and
that's undoubtedly going to be the big
thing that she has to deal with but it
feeds of course into our pockets this is
one measure of that this shows you our
household disposable income basically
once you've adjusted for inflation for
all the things we have to spend money on
this is how much things are growing so
anything above the line shows it's
growing we're getting better off the
feel good factors rising anything below
the line well that's bad news we're
shrinking and look at what's happening
in the next few years look red red bar's
there you can see we're gonna have the
biggest fall in our disposable income on
record so that we've ever seen that's an
enormous thing for liz trust to have to
deal with as is this next shot it's
showing you kind of a similar thing but
just displaying it in a different way
the higher this line is the higher our
real earnings so you can see they go up
and up and up then you've got the
financial crisis down a bit and starting
to go up just recently but look at
what's happened uh what's going to
happen in the next few years the
forecast from the office of virtual
responsibility that's going to go down
quite a lot
and you're talking about it being next
year the same level that it was in 2003
that's two lost decades of earnings
growth incredibly depressing there it's
not all bad news it's worth just taking
a step back and looking at some other
big statistics and no doubt liz trust is
going to be shown all of these things
how the uk compares with other countries
around the world on unemployment the
higher these bars are the higher the
unemployment rate so the fact that the
uk's are well middle of the pack
relatively low that's good news okay so
unemployment is good it's a good story
at the moment growth gdp growth ideally
you want that bar to be higher but the
uk middle of the pack certainly not the
worst but here's one you don't want to
be high look at that red bar we're going
to show you inflation look the uk has
the highest inflation rate in the g7 no
one quite knows why but the uk really
does have suddenly high inflation it's
expected to go even higher uh in the
next few months and all of this means
there's probably less capacity for liz
trust to deal with the thing that she
really wants to deal with which is this
the tax burden in the uk forecast to
head up to the highest level that we've
seen
since the 1940s
she wants to bring that down but what
with everything else she has to do what
with all of these other challenges
there's a big question as to whether
she's going to be able to do that
conway there with his analysis we'll be
getting much more on the economic
challenges and the financial reaction in
just a moment or two but uh first to
bring you the latest shots of the two
aircraft that have arrived at aberdeen
airport today that was the first one
containing boris johnson and his wife
carrie he arrived there as prime
minister he leaves there as a backbench
mp
arrived in fairly murky conditions it
must be said conditions have cleared up
a little bit he flies off and uh as he
told us in his speech earlier this
morning his farewell speech asked prime
minister to return to earth as a booster
rocket that's done its job to then land
in some quiet part of the pacific and
offer his uh fulsome support for the new
prime minister just to let you know if
you scan the qr code on your screen you
can listen to the latest edition of the
sky news daily podcast with neil
patterson he's been gathering reaction
with the dailies team to liz trust his
anointment as the new prime minister and
you can subscribe to the dailies you
probably know free wherever you get your
podcast from now as i said much more
reaction to the financial side of this
change over and what we know about liz
trust's plans
the plans
are thought to include
something major to tackle the cost of
living crisis that could see at least
100 billion pounds of support offered to
consumers and businesses the emergency
package is expected to include freezing
energy bills for homes and businesses we
understand it's something like the level
of two and a half thousand pounds until
january next year maybe longer than that
could go on until the next election in
2024 if it is then it's expected that
energy suppliers will be able to take
out government-backed loans to subsidize
bills or indeed that the government may
just borrow the money our business
presenter ian king joins us now from the
city and in all eyes on how the markets
are going to react and are reacting to
the appointment of liz trust
yes that's right well i'm in uh the
markets for the last six weeks or so
have been telling you what they think of
the uk's economic prospects because
obviously the pound has been selling off
in fact on monday yesterday it hit uh
its lowest level against the us dollar
since the 23rd of march 2020 which of
course is the day that boris johnson put
the uk back into into its first covert
related lockdown as for guilt government
ious gut uk government bonds will the
yield on those which is the implied
borrowing cost well that's been rising
very sharply if you take 10-year uk
government guilt the yield on those was
1.7 at the beginning of august right now
it's just shy of 3 so that is implying a
very big increase in government
borrowing costs and this is the key
question as regards the government
support for households and businesses
with higher energy bills now there's
there was a lot of conflicting uh
reporting in this morning's newspaper
some people suggesting that it would be
paid for out of government borrowing
other newspapers news outlets suggesting
that in fact it would be a private
sector scheme whereby the government
would be backstopping bill uh loans that
were made by the banking sector well as
our colleague sam coats has been
reporting in the last hour or so it
looks as if it's going to be funded out
of general taxation now implicit in that
is a very big increase in government
borrowing now is that necessarily going
to tip the uk into a into an
inflationary spawn and a big debt spiral
not necessarily if liz truss and her
incoming chancellor who we think will be
quasi karting can convince investors
that this is the lesser of two evils
that this is something that potentially
could get the uk on a path back to
growth fairly swiftly well it may not
necessarily go down all that badly
however the institute of fiscal studies
impeccably uh neutral of course and
independent well they've made clear they
think this is a pretty bad idea for a
couple of reasons first of all if you're
going to give blanket support for
households as we think is going to
happen with an all-round energy price
freeze at around the level of the price
cap right now 1 971 pounds well
essentially you're going to be throwing
an awful lot of money taxpayer money at
households who don't necessarily need
financial support so that is one issue
the other is that by taking away the
pricing discipline you're going to
remove the incentive for both households
and businesses to ration energy and so
there are other schemes that have been
kicked around i mean for example the
germans have said that they're they're
going to backstop with taxpayer money a
certain amount of energy for every
household but then after that you have
to meet higher costs on your own that of
course is an incentive for people to
save energy and indeed german energy use
has fallen by some 26 percent since the
spring so that's the german approach for
example in france of course we know
emmanuel macron has already uh frozen
energy prices that has come at vast
expense to the french taxpayer he spent
12 billion euros alone buying up shares
in the energy provider edf that the
government didn't already own so there
are various models being kicked around
it looks as so the order of support that
is going to be coming from the trust
administration if that number is correct
100 billion well that is sharply higher
than the kind of numbers that we're
seeing in the eurozone for example
germany's energy support packages so far
have totaled some 65 billion euros so
this is a very very big bazooka indeed
potentially that the trust
administration would be firing to
support households and businesses don't
forget the johnson government gave no
support to businesses with their energy
bills whatsoever so there'll be a lot of
interest in the business sector
particularly among some of those
energy intensive users the manufacturing
sector the steel companies for example
the construction sector the sort of
support that they'll be getting in
particular as well but it looks like a
big dramatic move as things stand
okay ian many thanks for that analysis
in king our business presenter there in
referring to the trust administration
that administration being formed as we
speak as this trust makes her way back
from balmoral where she was invited to
form a new government by her majesty the
queen
just what under an hour ago or so let's
go live there our royal correspondent
rhiannon mills is there and of course as
we say rhiannon liz trust has been asked
to form the
her majesty's new government she's the
next prime minister and boris johnson
resigned offered his resignation shortly
before that talk us through what you've
been seeing there this morning
so it was around 20 minutes ago that we
saw the new
15th prime minister for the queen liz
truss in a car leaving balmoral castle
after having that all-important audience
with the queen the moment where the
monarch formally asks her to form a new
government the moment that liz
liz trust said yes was the moment that
she officially became the prime minister
that's all now being confirmed by
buckingham palace so in essence that
important handover of power is now
complete the queen has carried out her
official duties all be in a rather
different way here at balmoral rather
than at buckingham palace but that
process is now complete there's also
been as is customary a photograph
released of the moment the moment
described as the kissing of hands no
kissing involved actually a handshake or
a simple bow or a curtsy louise tate who
was the former communications secretary
to the queen here in scotland joins me
now we were taking a look at that
photograph weren't we uh louise now the
first thing that stood out to me was the
fact that the queens seem to be dressed
less formally but you weren't surprised
about that no not really no not at all
um i think that's indicative of when the
queen is here at balmoral we've had
official photographs before where
perhaps she looks slightly less formally
attired tired um she was wearing a skirt
in the balmoral tartan which we've seen
many times on the prince of wales he's
known as the duke of los angeles but
we've seen it of course on the duke of
edinburgh uh quite a few times but yes
that's what stood out to me is that that
was traditional fun moral attire for her
majesty yeah the first time that we've
seen her since she arrived at aberdeen
airport at the end of july and i think
for some there has still been discussion
about her health we know that she wasn't
able to travel to london because of
mobility issues some reassurance today
that we have seen her and again it's
that sense of duty comes first yes
things have to change
she still wants to carry on though
doesn't she absolutely she made that
pledge very early in her reign and i
don't think that that uh wish has been
diminished in the least and i think
we've seen evidence of that today her
determination to carry on with the her
role as head of state
uh in accepting resignation of one prime
minister and then formally asking the
next one the incoming prime minister to
form a government yeah
it's interesting it is absolutely
tipping it down here so hopefully you
can hear us uh over the rain
that audience took a little bit longer
than we thought it would this trust
leaving slightly later you wonder what
the queen was looking out the window
thinking well i can't send them out in
that quite yet but it is a really
important first meeting yes there's that
formal moment the kissing of hands but
then time for more
discussion i suppose and the starting
and forming of a very important
relationship for liz trust of course we
can only speculate because we've already
spoken about these meetings these
audiences are kept very confidential but
it is it's it's going to be one of the
key
um
things for for the new prime minister is
establishing that role with that
relationship with the monarch and
getting a feeling and understanding and
just how that relationship's going to
evolve and develop and
it's going to be an incredibly valuable
one for both her majesty and the new
presidency louise thank you very much as
louise was alluding to that it's a
really important relationship two very
powerful individuals who in some ways
can only appreciate between themselves
exactly what it feels it can be lonely
at the top as some have described the
queen also in the past has explained how
her prime ministers during those weekly
audiences can sometimes unburden
themselves she's talked about the fact
that she is there to be consulted to be
encouraged and to warn when it comes to
that new prime minister i think of
course as we've talked about a great
deal there are challenges ahead for liz
trust we wonder whether those were were
discussed in that audience also liz
trust of course now forming her cabinet
it's the queen who does the final
official signing off of that maybe there
was a discussion about that but also i
think for some out there at these times
of political uncertainty cost of living
crisis difficult time for families there
will be a sense of reassurance that
today we have seen the queen again
carrying out her official role and that
very important constitutional duty
and thanks for talking us through it all
rhiannon mills our royal correspondent
live for us in balmoral
well good afternoon from in contrast to
very sunny warrington uh where we're
looking at some of the issues facing the
new prime minister particularly here in
the north warrington is a pretty typical
town uh reflecting much of the national
averages across the country also
crucially it was one of the the two
seats here taken by boris johnson and
the conservatives in 2019 breaking that
that so-called red wall of course with
promises to uh voters uh in the north
much of that was focused on this issue
of leveling up that we hear uh so much
about have they delivered on that well
we can ask sylvie morton who's the
assistant director of mykador regional
development uh consultancy sylvie thanks
for talking to us on on sky news this
afternoon
on that issue leveling up we hear a lot
about it obviously was a lot was
promised to constituencies like this in
2019 first of all what do you understand
it means what do people understand that
actually means to them a lot of people
don't understand what it means and
there's never been a very clear
definition of what leveling up was or
should be
so i think
leveling up in our view with increasing
productivity and it's increasing
productivity across the country to
increase prosperity for everyone when
you look at local levels there are still
so many disparities
and by leveling up
we are going to share that prosperity
for the whole of the uk
during the leadership campaign we
variously heard that leveling up would
be ditched liz trust saying she would
double down on on leveling up what did
you hear in that leadership campaign
about
what constituencies like this can expect
from from the new prime minister well i
would say the campaign was
i didn't listen to it that much
basically because i think the campaign
is not what it was about
what it's about is actually carry on the
big agenda items which are going to make
a difference
so what we need with this new prime
minister is actually leadership and
focus on delivering up because that is
what is going to deliver
we've seen here and across the country
government jobs have been moved out to
to regions we've seen billions of pounds
people have talked here to us today
about
some of the the projects that have
received money as a result of that of
that new agenda
you think that's not enough that's not
going far enough that's good
but that's not enough
basically what we need with leveling up
is a lot more devolved local authority
local authorities like this down in
warrington they know their area better
they know what needs to be done the
problem is that they haven't got a
resource they've been starved of money
for the last 10 years there's no money
left and there's no resource left to
actually put in place all these plans
which could make a difference
what does that do though practically
because you hear that a lot that people
say that power should be devolved to
local authorities particularly on things
like education after the age of 16 to
get people the the training vocational
training what difference practically
would that make somewhere like this
that would make people
at local authority level a lot more
hands-on and being able to develop more
resource and and
really help rather than having you know
being tied to government policies which
may not be applicable equally across all
the different areas
on energy so much talk about cost of
living and the price is rocketing and we
may hear in the next few days something
to tackle that what do you hear in
communities like this about the impact
that's having and the fear of what might
come next on that
it's fear it's it's drama and it's uh
and it's all realistic because people
are already struggling now before
october before january and that goes for
both
individuals and families and communities
but also what is kind of overlooked is
the effect that the energy crisis has on
business
businesses are not subjected to
do not
are not beneficiary from the price cap
and their costs are going open up and up
so we have the a big threat of
businesses especially small businesses
having to to close down basically
because they won't be able to sustain
the costs
and
that's snowballing into job losses and
and so on and making things worse we're
expecting to hear from the new prime
minister in the next few hours
what is if there was one thing you
wanted to hear
from her as the country's new leader
what would that be
uh one thing
unfortunately there's not one thing
there's three things in my view
there's definitely deal with this
cost of living crisis and it's not on
the energy it's everything and it's
actually supporting people to get
through that
help with the energy crisis and support
businesses to get through that which
will support the economy all together
and the biggest thing is keep that
leadership and that focus on levelling
up and help us and help local
authorities to deliver that leveling up
for the uk okay we'll see what she does
say later on sylvie thank you very much
uh for talking to us um
that the view from here in warrington it
was boris johnson who made those
promises in 2019 it is now for liz trust
to deliver on them to uh communities
like this one we'll have more from
warrington during the course of the
afternoon but for now back to you
wilfred in the sky news center
greg thanks so much uh you're watching
sky news and still to come a new plea
from the family of olivia pratt corbell
the nine-year-old who was shot dead in
liverpool
[Music]
welcome back this morning boris johnson
left downing street for the final time
after delivering a speech outside number
10 in which he promised fervent support
for his successor and likened himself to
a booster rocket returning to earth
let's bring you that speech now in full
thank you thank well
well this is
this is it folks thank you everybody for
coming out so early this morning
in only a couple of hours i will be in
balmoral to see her majesty the queen
and the torch will finally be passed to
a new conservative leader
the baton will be handed over in what
has unexpectedly turned out to be a
relay race they changed the rules
halfway through but never mind that now
and through that lacquered black door a
new prime minister will shortly go to
meet a fantastic group of public
servants the people who got brexit done
the people who deliver the fastest
vaccine rollout in europe and never
forget
70
of the entire population got a dose
within six months faster than any
comparable country that is government
for you that's this conservative
government
people
who organized those prompt early
supplies of weapons to the heroic
ukrainian armed forces an action that
may very well have helped change the
course of the biggest european war for
80 years and because of the speed and
urgency of what you did everybody
involved in this government to get this
economy moving again from july last year
in spite of all the opposition
all the naysayers we have
and will continue to have
that economic strength to give people
the cash they need to get through this
energy crisis that has been caused by
putin's vicious war
and i know
that liz trusts and this compassionate
conservative government will do
everything we can to get people through
this crisis and this country will endure
it and we will win and if putin thinks
that he can succeed by blackmailing or
bullying the british people then he is
utterly deluded
and the reason we will have those funds
now and in the future is because we
conservatives understand the vital
symmetry between government action
and free market capitalist private
sector enterprise we're delivering on
those huge manifesto commitments making
streets safer neighborhood crime down 38
in the last three years 13 790 more
police on the streets building more
hospitals and yes we will have 50 000
more nurses by the end of the decade and
40 more hospitals by the end of
50 000 nurses by the end of this
parliament i should say 40 new hospitals
by the end of the decade putting record
funding into our schools and into
teachers pay giving everybody over 18 a
lifetime skills guarantee so they can
keep up skilling throughout their lives
three new high-speed rail lines three
including northern powerhouse rail
colossal road proud programs from the
pennines to cornwall the roll out of
gigabit broadband up over the last
three years i am proud to say since you
were kind enough to elect me from seven
percent of our country's premises having
gigabit broadband to 70
today and we are of course providing the
short and the long-term solutions for
our energy needs and not just using more
of our own domestic hydrocarbons but
going up by 2030 to 50 gigawatts of wind
power that is half this country's energy
electricity needs from offshore wind
alone a new nuclear reactor every year
and looking at what is happening in this
country the changes that are taking
place that is why private sector
investment is flooding in more private
sector more venture capital investment
than china itself more billion pound
tech companies sprouting here in the uk
but in france germany and israel
combined and as a result
unemployment as i leave office
unemployment down to lowe's not seen
since i was about 10 years old and
bouncing around on a space hopper my
friends and on on the subject of
on the subject of bouncing around in
future careers
let me say that i am now like one of
those booster rockets
that has fulfilled its function
and i will now be gently re-entering the
atmosphere and splashing down invisibly
in some remote and obscure corner of the
pacific
and
like cincinnatus
i am returning to my plow
and i will be offering this government
nothing but the most fervent
support this is
i'll tell you why this is a tough time
for the economy
this is a tough time for families up and
down the country we can and we will get
through it we will come out stronger the
other side
but i say to
my fellow conservatives it's time for
politics to be over folks it's time for
us all to get behind liz truss and her
team and her program
and deliver for the people of this
country because that is what the people
of this country want that's what they
need
and that's what they deserve
i'm proud
to have discharged the promises i made
to my party when you kind enough to
choose me winning the biggest majority
since 1987 the biggest share of the vote
since 1979 delivering brexit delivering
our manifesto commitments including by
the way including social care reforming
social care helping people up and down
the country ensuring that britain is
once again standing tall in the world
speaking with clarity and authority
from ukraine to the orcas pact with
america and
australia because we are one whole and
entire united kingdom whose diplomats
security services and armed forces
are so globally admired and by the way
as i believe as i leave i believe our
union is so strong that those who want
to break it up they'll keep trying but
they will never ever succeed
thank you to everybody
behind me in this building
thank you to all of you in government uh
thank you everyone who's helped look
after me and my family over the last
three years including
including dylan
the dog
and i just say to my party if dylan and
larry
can put behind them their occasional
difficulties then so can the
conservative party
above all thanks to you
the british people to the voters for
giving me the chance to serve all of you
who work so tirelessly together
to beat covid to put us where we are
today
together we have laid foundations that
will stand the test of time whether by
taking back control
of our laws or putting in vital new
infrastructure great solid masonry on
which we will continue to build together
paving paving the path
of prosperity now and
for future generations
and i will be supporting liz truss and
the new government every step of the way
thank you all very much thank you and
goodbye thank you
boris johnson's last speech as prime
minister there much more
from downing street on downing street
coming up and now to other developments
in the family of olivia pratt corbell
the nine-year-old girl who was shot dead
inside her own home in liverpool last
month have appealed for people to come
forward with information about who
killed her skies ashna hoiyanai joins us
now live from liverpool and ashna tell
us more about what the family have been
saying
well it's just over two weeks ago now
that olivia pratt corbell was shot at
her home in the duffcoat area of the
city of the first time today we have
heard from her father john francis pratt
who has issued a tribute to his daughter
on behalf of him and his family he says
in a statement provided to the public
words can't express the pain we are
going through after olivia was so
cruelly snatched away from us those
responsible need to know what they have
done olivia was a real bright spark who
knew her own mind and had no problem
making friends and loved to laugh and
make people laugh he goes on olivia's
death cannot be in vain we want people
to feel safe and be safe that can only
happen if we all come together and make
sure there is no place for guns or those
who use guns on our streets or in our
communities
well as well as that tribute from
olivia's father he's also provided a
video that shows
him and his daughter at liverpool city
center's christmas market a few years
ago in which olivia can be seen hugging
her dad
and smiling along the way it was 10 30
on the 22nd of august in the evening
when a masked gunman forced his way into
olivia's home he shot olivia's mother's
wrist that bullet then went straight
into olivia's chest killing the
nine-year-old girl ever since her death
there has been a huge outpouring of
grief from the community here
in liverpool but alongside that
merseyside police launched an extensive
murder investigation which is very much
ongoing the latest of which was four
arrests that merseyside police con
conducted on sunday the perhaps the most
important one being the arrest of a 34
year old man arrested on suspicion of
murder and of attempted murder but in
addition to that three separate arrests
three men are facing allegations of
assisting an offender they are still
being questioned by police
and remain in police custody but all the
while police here are appealing for yet
more information from the public
they say that their appeal for
information has been immense people have
been incredibly forthcoming with
information to assist in their
investigation but they still need more
that is a plea that has been echoed by
olivia's dad john francis pratt today
who has paid tribute for his dearly
loved daughter
thanks ashna horinak there in liverpool
now on police have shot dead a man in
his twenties after a car chase ended in
south london police say that they were
pursuing a suspect vehicle last night
and the police deliberately collided
with the car to force it to stop
bringing the pursuit to an end in the
streatham hill area and people living
there reported hearing gunshots and a
police helicopter overhead
there's a massive bang that's i thought
a neighbor's
roof had fallen off or something there's
a rule that
i think it was like boom like something
that maybe it bounced us and i looked
out the back window to see someone had
fallen and straight away i didn't really
notice it before but straight away i
could hear the helicopter very close in
the air and that's not terribly unusual
for around here but it suddenly was like
you know just felt more intense it's
usually very fairly calm around here so
it's a bit of a shock
and our crime correspondent martin brunt
is there on the scene so martin what
more do we know about the incident
the investigators are still here they've
been here overnight and they're from the
independent
office for police conduct so that's the
police watchdog that took over the
investigation as soon as it was known
that a man had been shot by police we're
waiting
for an update from the iopc but there
isn't any
yet but the sort of things that they
will be trying to establish as soon as
possible is
the identity
firstly of the man who died
we are pretty sure we know who that man
is and i'll say a bit more about that in
in a second um they'll want to know
whether there was any non-police weapon
that was uh that was found at the scene
how many police fired their weapons how
many bullets were fired
the reason for the car being pursued by
the police
those are all the key questions that
the investigators will be hoping to
answer as soon as possible now the facts
according to the metropolitan police
are that uh police were pursuing a
suspect vehicle we're not sure what the
suspicion was about it they traveled
from lamberth so rath further north uh
but traveling south uh here they
probably hadn't gone very far
the car was
cornered if you like in this street here
it was rammed by the police to make it
stop
and then there were shouts from police
according to witnesses asking the driver
of the car to get out
the driver apparently failed to do that
the driver's car moved towards the
police vehicles according to a witness
reported in the evening standard and at
that point it appears a shot was fired
there are there's a clear
shot of a sort of clear view of a
gunshot
a bullet hole in the windscreen
of the suspect's car police haven't said
whether anybody else was in the car we
don't think there was and that bullet
hole appears to be
on the windscreen
by the driver's side of the front of the
car now
we spoke earlier
about the identity of of the man who
died uh it hasn't been officially
confirmed but we did speak to and we can
listen to her now pastor lorraine jones
burrell
from the dwayne simpson foundation which
steers youngsters away from gang culture
she has been talking to the friends of
the man who died many of them who are
gathered here and this is what pastor
lorraine told us
he was on his way to one of the friends
of friends is here
he's still waiting for him to come only
to hear that
their friend chris
has been killed
in cold blood
by a bullet
and that bullet
has been fired from a police officer
there has to be answers
because this has caused a massive
massive ripple effect of distrust
fear and
trauma amongst the violence that we're
dealing with
we've got to deal with the police as
well now
these are the questions
there are
at least one relative of um
of the man who died here at least the
mother of the man's girlfriend and uh we
may be able to talk to her uh in a short
while um
lorraine pastor lorraine also told us
that the man who died chris was about to
be a father so his girlfriend uh is
carrying his child and it's quite clear
from talking to pastor lorraine who
represents the wider community here that
there is a huge amount of shock sadness
anger
and
the family are looking for answers about
to what happened here last night
okay martin brunt in south london thank
you very much
and you are watching sky news coming up
we're going to be discussing the ways in
which liz truss's government could be
very different to that of boris johnson
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm stuart ramsey and i'm sky's chief
correspondent
well there's a real sense now that
people are beginning to expect that this
whole airlift is coming to an end and
they're really really desperate
[Music]
we saw snatch squads going in grabbing
people and putting them into trucks
[Music]
you either live and recover
or you die
okay so that's like a wall that's the
war yes
we help you understand the world with us
over the past 24 hours the soldiers have
been attacked on a number of occasions
[Music]
it's really sending a clear message that
venezuela is eager for change
[Music]
to take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
they were convinced the united states
would become hooked where we're right
[Music]
the information on this could bring down
the entire network not just in iraq and
syria but across the world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
withdrawal
[Music]
the inspiration behind our product came
from
understanding how big of a problem
livestock meat and emissions were
well now this truss will arrive here
later in about two hours two a bit
hour's time in downing street as the new
prime minister and she will be under
immediate intense pressure to form a
government equipped to deal with the
cost of living crisis also a struggling
nhs as we all know plus the continuing
conflict in ukraine and that's not all
well joining us now from westminster is
dr catherine hadden a senior fellow at
the institute for government uh good to
talk to you again dr hadden and i say
that's not all in terms of
what's in her in trade there's strikes
inflation problems in education
social care the list goes on i mean any
one of those issues let alone that
combination would be enough to to engulf
to overwhelm any government any prime
minister they've got to really get to it
get to work as quickly as possible
yeah absolutely i mean it's just hitting
them crisis after crisis i mean the one
benefit that she's got is that this is
something that we have seen in advance
you know people know that this is coming
certainly in terms of energy prices
rising inflation
um and many of the other aspects that
you talked about so there has been able
to be some thinking about it she's not
in the same position as boris johnson
when he thought he was coming in and
brexit was going to be the defining
issue instead it was covid
that dominated much of his premiership
um but she has to hit the ground running
you know there's very little time
to
sit back and think well what are we
going to do already people are looking
immediately for that energy support
package with you know being told that
will be announced this week that doesn't
give you a lot of time to to think about
dealing with it and it is
it's a very difficult political
situation because this isn't just some
abstract economic debate this is
people's lives you know the public the
voting public are feeling this right now
and looking ahead to winter
so that is something they will be very
closely watching the government on
and it is the scale of the spending that
potentially is ahead that support
package well it's been put into three
figures in terms of billions 100 billion
plus yet liz trust also sticking at this
point with her pledge to cut taxes to
spark growth
yeah and it's difficult to think how
she's going to square that circle um you
know when you
talking about the energy support package
people are throwing around the figure of
100 billion you add in the tax cuts as
well that's even more money out of the
public purse you can compensate for that
with growth but we haven't really seen a
plan for how to do that and one of my
colleagues writing this week said the
problem with any of these growth
strategies is that they chop and change
all the time and so businesses just
don't have that kind of certainty so
it's a big promise to say to the public
that you're both going to fix the
economy and throw lots of money the way
of the public and it's going to be you
know a huge impact on the public
finances to do so so government
borrowing is going to be up uh these are
you know astronomical numbers that we're
talking about but then so is the rise in
energy prices that we're talking about
and it is something that's not going to
be just this autumn this winter people
are already talking about high energy
prices through next year into next
winter let alone as you say other major
problems we already knew we had like
fixing the nhs dealing with social care
huge huge issues
dr haddon catherine hadden uh thank you
very much indeed catherine hadden there
from the institute for government and uh
as dr hadden was saying there are a huge
number of issues of problems on the
entree for the new prime minister about
to enter that door here at number 10
downing street just let me talk you
through the timings as we know them
there is expected to be some pretty
severe weather over this area later this
afternoon but uh as it stands now in
this weather liz trusts will speak
outside that door just after four
o'clock we expect maybe inside if the
rain intervenes stay with us
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is sky news live from downing
street where later this afternoon we'll
see the new prime minister liz truss
miss trusts accepted the queen's
invitation to form a government at
balmoral this lunchtime
she's now on her way back to westminster
to appoint her cabinets and get straight
to work
the top item on her agenda the cost of
living crisis a 100 billion pound plan
to freeze energy bills is set to be
announced later this week
[Applause]
meanwhile a farm farewell for boris
johnson from downing street staff as he
promises to give his full support to his
successor
i am now like one of those booster
rockets
that has fulfilled its function
and i will now be gently re-entering the
atmosphere and splashing down invisibly
in some remote and obscure corner of the
pacific
well we are expecting liz trust to
arrive here in downing street just after
4 pm and make her first speech as prime
minister we will of course have live
coverage throughout the afternoon
[Music]
a very good afternoon from downing
street where we are awaiting the arrival
of the new prime minister liz truss
miss trusts visited balmoral this lunch
time where she accepted her majesty the
queen's invitation to form a government
she followed her predecessor boris
johnson to the estate in aberdeenshire
and mr johnson formally submitted his
resignation to the queen just before
midday
so liz trust is now on her way back to
westminster to get straight to work and
she's already begun appointing her
cabinet of course as she tries to get to
grips with some of the challenges facing
the uk of course chief among them the
cost of living crisis later this week
it's expected that miss truss will lay
out a plan to freeze energy bills at
around two and a half thousand pounds a
year for the average household is what
we're hearing are deputy political
editor sam coates is with me we'll talk
more about some of those details as we
understand them in a moment or two but
first on the fact that the drift the
stasis the two months of nothing
happening at this crucial time for the
uk and its economy it's over liz trust
has so much ground to make up
that's right two months where the
government effectively switched off
because there was a leadership contest
underway coming off the back of let's be
honest about eight months where there
was so much turmoil to the end towards
the end of boris johnson's time in power
that less than should have been got done
was actually achieved so yes liz trust
needs to press the reset button and will
show that she wants to get on with the
business of governing and that's going
to happen pretty quickly this afternoon
she will deliver her first remarks as
the 56th prime minister of the united
kingdom uh just uh until we're behind us
just after four o'clock and then we'll
get on we'll hear the cabinet
announcements fairly soon after that
but because liz trust was effectively a
shoe-in in this race you could tell she
was gonna win from the polling from
talking to mps um pretty much since the
back end of august she's been planning
for this moment i'm told by her allies
that she has a pretty much worked up
plan to go when it comes to the cabinet
i think we know quite a lot of the
appointments uh that are gonna
the people that are gonna occupy the
great uh offices of state so
quasi-quatting her long-time ideological
ally and neighbor uh in southeast london
will be her chancellor uh james
cleverley who worked with her in the
foreign office will be her foreign
secretary uh ben wallace uh will go to
the defender will stay in the uh defense
department so ella braverman another uh
leadership contender who i think
impressed her uh impressed liz trust
will now become the home secretary but
within each of the entries of each of
those secretaries of state and hence liz
trust there is an enormous amount to do
setting uh uh starting with the problem
of energy price increases due uh to
raise exponentially millions of people
if nothing is done uh fed to fa set to
face poverty within a matter of weeks
now we understand uh that liz trust has
been drawing up plans on that now what's
interesting about the plans that liz
trust will outline maybe as soon as
thursday so very different from the
kinds of things she was saying just six
weeks ago where she foreswore um
large-scale expensive short-term
sticking plaster interventions
button-brown economics but dermot that
looks uh like the kind of thing that she
may be forced to reach through reach for
given the scale of the crisis uh we're
looking at some kind of way of trying to
keep bills around the 2 500 pound mark
for households for the average household
perhaps cushioned with the 400 pounds uh
that rishi sunac was going to give with
this all paid for through borrowing
rather than clawing it back through
energy prices that's energy bills in the
future that seems to be the shape of
that package but liz trusts his ambition
doesn't stop there the reason that the
change of prime minister really matters
is because she wants to change the whole
direction of government she believes
that boris johnson made a mistake that
he didn't prioritize growth she's going
to correct that mistake with a series of
measures tax cuts and then reforms in a
infrastructure bill that could uh uh we
could find out details of as soon as
monday uh in order to correct that
mistake so this isn't continuity however
much you recognize the faces around the
cabinet take table later this afternoon
you should recognize several of them
jacob rees-mogg and others this is a
different direction for britain than the
one crucially the people voted for in
the 2019 general election
so we've got tax cuts
billions to be spent on that coupled
with the 100 billion plus to support
people through the energy crisis
there are factors beyond her control
beyond the uk's control then the
international money markets their
attitude uh this level of spending and
potentially this level of borrowing
that's right i think let's be honest liz
trust has three audiences she needs to
please and you touched on the first one
and we haven't really had a conversation
about the money markets being uh judge
and jury of a british prime minister
since the 1970s but i think with um
interventions in the hundreds of
billions perhaps year after year now
that conversation is coming back the
next audience uh that she's going to
have to satisfy uh are the ones over
there in parliament conservative mps a
very fractious um uh uh conservative
party leadership contest nasty at points
lots of bruised people could some of
them rebel could some of them stymie her
plans particularly on growth and then
the third audience that liz trust is
going to have to appeal to is of course
the voters we saw snap polling last
night suggesting but broadly by a margin
of two to one uh voters at large are
skeptical about liz trust you might be
the longest serving cabinet minister ian
boris johnson's government uh and
pre-previous governments but she is a
bit more of an unknown quantity for many
of the public and they don't yet like
what they see of course the big energy
announcement and the big reforms she's
planning are an opportunity for her to
introduce herself to the country she
could use that window to turn herself
into a success okay sam for the time
being thank you very much indeed our
deputy political editor sam coats there
let's talk more now about uh the process
that has unfolded in terms of this
handover of power it all took place at
balmoral as you know the queen's estate
where she spends her summers unable to
travel to buckingham palace to accept
boris johnson's resignation and anoint
liz trust because of her mobility issues
they travel to see her on separate
aircraft let's go to aberdeen airport
now and talk to our correspondent james
matthews who can talk us through their
their comings and goings and some of the
difficulties thrown up by the conditions
there
[Applause]
yeah conditions very harsh conditions i
have to say
which dictated
some of this morning's tradition
uh liz trust in particular she had
trouble getting her plane into aberdeen
airport if you looked at the flight
tracker because the mist had descended
uh that falcon aircraft was circling
aberdeen for something like 15-20
minutes before the mist lifted and she
was able to land so that involved
something of a delay in getting to
balmoral boris johnson didn't have any
such trouble he was on the road rather
quicker in a convoy towards balmoral
from this airport
and thereafter of course liz truss uh
went to the castle for an audience
with her majesty you can see just on the
taxiway behind me uh the falcon aircraft
waiting to take less trust back on her
journey south weather conditions okay at
the moment i mean throughout the mist
and everything else planes were taking
off so we're not anticipating any great
delay in terms of the journey back over
the border
she is due to arrive here at aberdeen
airport fairly shortly but
you know there was a lot of planning
clearly that went into this event it was
uh fairly unique in its own way there
was discussion about a helicopter trip
from here to balmoral but that was
discounted and they will be
counting thanking the lucky stars that
they did discount the helicopter because
early this morning because of that mist
uh helicopter pilots at aberdeen who
know a thing or two about putting
aircraft in the air in tricky conditions
they were rushing to get here before the
mist descended they realized the
problems that that was going to
involve so you know in terms of
the tradition of all this the function
actually of how this
unfolded was key to events it has
ultimately
worked out albeit with some hedges with
some delay unless trust as the new prime
minister is now heading to this airport
and will julie head back to towards
downing street she's no stranger of
course to scotland having lived here she
lived as a youngster in paisley when her
dad took a job at the paisley college of
technology so on that road trip along
the a93 she had the opportunity to look
at the land that she will govern
and to reflect perhaps uh on her
childhood
as a youngster at one point she played
margaret thatcher
in a school play her mentor
uh
of course the other woman in her
political life is nicola sturgeon and
much discussion
uh there's much discussion about
the chemistry and the politics between
these
constitutional debate you'll remember
that theresa may and her first full day
in office she went to visit nicola
sturgeon boris johnson went to see her
in his first week as prime minister no
such meeting on the horizon between liz
cross and nicola sturgeon and one does
wonder
how they will progress particularly on
the issue of scotland's constitution so
we'll see in time how that plays out but
much concern and indeed nicholas surgeon
said nicholas trust would be a disaster
as a prime minister
liz strauss
dismissed nicolas sturgeon as an
attention seeker who would be ignored so
one wonders how the two of them will
come together in terms of
progress on the key issue north of the
border of scotland's constitutional
future india ref 2
possibly on the horizon of course
depending on what the supreme court
decides in october
okay james matthews at aberdeen airport
thank you very much indeed well let's
concentrate now then on what happened to
the occupants of those incoming aircraft
after they landed and their occupants
headed off to balmoral boris johnson and
his wife carrie first traveled then to
balmoral for that audience with her
majesty the queen to offer his
resignation let's talk to our royal
correspondent rhiannon mills who
witnessed it all for us up there in a
fairly soggy as we can see for ourselves
a fairly soggy balmoral and talk us
through how it was sequenced as i say
boris and carrie johnson arrived first
i think it was always going to be
fascinating to see how this played out
for 70 years the handover has always
happened at buckingham palace
but today despite the fact that both the
outgoing and in-going prime minister had
to do that one thousand mile round trip
to balmoral and despite the best efforts
of the weather everything once again ran
seamlessly and we now have completed in
essence the queen's role in that
handover of power as he said boris
johnson and carrie johnson arrived first
for the moments when boris johnson
formally submitted his resignation to
the queen and at that moment he then
asked her to call liz trust to form a
new administration now as is customary
we don't get a photo of the outgoing
prime minister but we do get a photo of
the incoming prime minister meeting the
queen and going through that process of
kissing of hands as it's described in
the court circular no kissing involved
more a handshake a bow or a curtsy i
think what will be striking to many is
that the queen maybe isn't dressed as
formally as we normally see her speaking
to those though who are very familiar
with how she would normally be dressed
when she's here at balmoral say that
it's very standard to see her there in
her twin set her cardigan her knitted
top and also that tartan skirt so that's
fairly standard but also i think it's a
really important moment where after so
much discussion about the queen's house
we were also able to see her carrying
out her official duties of course for
liz trust this is just the start of what
are going to be many important meetings
with the queen the prime minister every
week holds a audience with her yes the
queen hands over political power to
her government to her prime minister but
it is still her role she is still to be
encouraged to walk to be encouraged
warned and to advise when it comes to
those meetings with the prime minister
many of those who have gone before liz
trust have talked about the importance
of that relationship how in many ways it
is completely unique compared to other
relationships they form within that
premiership because they can say
whatever they want in the room and they
know that it won't go anywhere else the
queen herself has often talked about how
she finds it
quite reassuring that prime ministers
feel they can unburden themselves and
sometimes she is able uh to offer advice
it has to be said the audience with the
liz trust went on for a little longer
than we anticipated you wonder whether
the queen was looking out the window and
thinking well i can't possibly uh quite
send them out in that way there just yet
but also of course many things that the
queen may have well wanted to talk to
that to liz trust about political
uncertainty at the cost of living crisis
and also her choice of cabinet because
the queen ultimately has to rub a stamp
all of those new members of the cabinet
and tomorrow we are expecting a privy
council meeting to be held by the queen
where she will hand over seals of office
where liz trust will take that oath of
first lord of the treasury or be at this
time it's not going to happen in person
the queen we expect will carry out
remotely uh over computer in some way
well we've sent you out in those
conditions sir rhiannon we thank you for
it rhiannon mills our royal
correspondent there at balmoral well as
ryanlin was telling us as we all know
top of the prime minister's agenda is
the cost of living crisis and liz trust
is expected to set out a plan to tackle
energy bills later this week now we
understand at sky news that the plan is
going to freeze the energy price cap at
something around two and a half thousand
pounds a year it's going to stand at
about 1
900 pounds at the moment just before we
discuss that more let's uh show you
those live shots from aberdeen airport
um well not very dramatic at the moment
but we're told that uh somewhere there
the uh plane that is going to carry liz
trust prime minister liz truss back to
london is about to depart clearly uh not
in our camera shot though um but um yeah
that's all that's what we're hearing and
in terms of the timings then that she'll
be here roundabout here in downey street
round about four o'clock and if the
heavens don't open uh in a way that
you've been seeing in balmoral liz
trusts will go to the lectern which just
a few hours earlier boris johnson made
his
speech from his final address as prime
minister liz trust will have that
lecture outside number 10 downing street
as prime minister britain's 56th prime
minister and the 15th
and uh queen elizabeth the second and
she will make some remarks of course if
the heavens do open we understand it
will be a little bit later and we'll be
inside downey street oh i see so uh that
is the the convoy the small convoy
carrying the cars in which one presumes
the the middle car the range rover is
the one carrying liz truss and her
husband to the aircraft as i say uh
coming back here
to london
to address the nation to address her
party and indeed assam coats our deputy
political editor was pointing out to
address the international money markets
very very worried now very concerned
about the piles financial and economic
situation facing the united kingdom and
i'll get back then to what we understand
about the support that she's going to
offer perhaps as early as this week the
support that liz trusts and her newly
formed governments are going to offer to
consumers when it comes to the energy
price cap at the moment it's set at the
at the still uh rather large about 1 900
1 970 pounds for the average household
that is expected to rise in october to
above 3 000 pounds 3 300 or something
like that we are told that the plans
being formulated at the moment after it
to be
put somewhere around about two and a
half thousand pounds as you can see
there let's trust under entourage some
of the bags no doubt plenty of work
being done on that flight
back to london many of the cabinet
positions as we understand them already
decided particularly for those top jobs
quasi-quarten a friend a long-time
friend political ally and indeed close
neighboring greenwich in south london to
be appointed as chancellor of the
exchequer and we'll be covering all that
for you throughout the late afternoon
and evening and james cleverly again
another supporter in as foreign
secretary suella bravamanda expected to
take over from pretty patel at the home
office and a raft of other appointments
um we've got
our views and our whispers about who may
take those places and we'll be talking
about those throughout the rest of the
afternoon as we await the takeoff of
that aircraft carrying prime minister
liz truss
back to london and back to number 10
downing street live coverage throughout
the afternoon right here on sky news i
think we're going to leave those shots
now and talk about their financial and
economic situation
with our business correspondent
ian king ian um we'll stay on the stay
in the shop there as we
see an aircraft leave an airport um
tell us in about this package as i've
laid out there thinking their price cap
for consumers around about two and a
half thousand pounds
obviously as our business presenter
you're hearing from many many businesses
what about us what are we going to get
because
we are passing on these huge increase in
costs we're passing it on in the form of
inflation to consumers
absolutely german and that is a key
concern really with this package now
there's been a lot of briefing overnight
as to what form it may take whether this
was going to be uh simply loans made to
the energy sector that would be
guaranteed by the government and then
would have to be repaid over the next 15
years a form of higher taxation if you
like it appears that the government has
ruled that out and is going to go for a
straightforward increase in public
borrowing by which it's going to keep
the energy price capital around the
current level which is as you say is 1
971 pounds now the overall figure uh
that's been quoted that is two and a
half thousand pounds but when you take
into account the fact that the
government is already committing to a
flat rebate per household of 400 pounds
this autumn there's also talk of doing
away with green levees that would keep
the energy uh price cap roughly at the
same sort of level that it is right now
and as i say the suspicion is and uh our
colleague sam coats has been reporting
this this lunch time is going to be
funded out of general boring now that is
a big increase in public borrowing
probably around 100 billion pounds or so
and as you say there are concerns in the
financial markets about an increase in
government borrowing and you've actually
seen that reflected over the last six
weeks or so with government bonds uk
government guilds government ious and
the implied borrowing costs on those
guilts has risen quite significantly at
the beginning of august uh the 10-year
guilt was uh yielding 1.7 percent it's
currently uh just under uh one three
percent so a big increase in implied
government borrowing costs but it's not
necessarily clear that the government
would be punished by the markets for
this if investors can be convinced that
this is going to stave off a recession
potentially help the uk to resume
growing uh reasonably quickly than it
would have been otherwise and that may
go down reasonably well with markets and
it's worth pointing out actually derma
that today there's been a guilt auction
and uh there was plenty of demand the uh
cover was uh two and a half times there
were two and a half times as many bids
for gilts that were actually being
auctioned and that is something that the
government will take comfort from but it
is worth pointing out that there are
critics of a blanket uh freeze in energy
prices not least from the independent
institute for fiscal studies which has
pointed out that basically if you do
this blanket form of relief you're going
to be helping a lot of households well
off households who don't really need
this sort of support from the taxpayer
that's one concern the other is that you
take away the incentive for households
and businesses because we think that
there's going to be support for
businesses too something that boris
johnson's government didn't do and that
is potentially going to take away the
incentive for households and business is
to save save energy and that is
something that other governments
particularly in germany for example have
been looking at in their response to
higher energy prices and there's one
more concern that is well worth
reporting as well which is how the bank
of england would react to this because
make no mistake this would represent
fiscal stimulus and that is something
that at a time when the bank of england
thinks there's excess demand in the
economy anyway well it would probably
have to raise interest rates in response
to that so that is uh something else
that would be worth uh considering also
worth pointing out to actually derby you
mentioned there quasi carteng likely to
be the incoming chancellor well he had
an uh editorial piece in the financial
times yesterday in which he was clearly
trying to signal to financial markets
that uh liz trust would be responsible
with the uh with the public finances
that there wouldn't be some help for
leather uh increase in public borrowing
although uh clearly there is uh it's
implicit in this government response
that we're hearing i should also say by
the way given that we've been talking a
lot about energy prices
the uh price of wholesale gas has
actually fallen back today on the
commodity markets obviously yesterday we
had a big big increase in the price of
wholesale gas which reflected uh the
decision of russia to cut supplies
through north stream one pipeline into
europe well actually the wholesale gas
price has come off pretty sharply today
and it's back at levels that it was on
friday afternoon
ian i'd be really interested in a quick
take on you on the other part
of liz trustee's spending agenda and
this is the issue of cutting taxes to
get growth now there isn't a government
in the world that says that it doesn't
want to have higher growth what is list
trusses magic formula going to be that
no one else has found
well the two key things that the two key
campaign pledges that she made dermot
one is not to go ahead with the big
increase in corporation tax in the next
financial year that rishi sunap was that
was going to take the rate of
corporation tax from 19
to 26 now she actually hasn't that
increase hasn't come through yet liz
trust saying that she wouldn't go ahead
with that the other of course is to
reverse mr sunac's increase in national
insurance contributions that went
through earlier this year uh that was
one and a half quarter percent for both
employers and his often employees and is
often forgotten for employers as well
she's promised to reverse that pretty
quickly that would amount to a big piece
of fiscal stimulus richie sinat was
looking to raise a lot of money from
that measure although it's worth
pointing out that when he subsequently
came in with other measures to support
households with the cost of living he
actually effectively unwound uh that
increase for anyone earning less than 50
000 pounds a year or so anyway so it
looks effectively like a potentially
quite a big handout a big piece of
fiscal stimulus and as i say that is the
sort of thing that may concern the bank
of england's monetary policy committee
fascinating ian many thanks ian king our
business presenter i want to talk now to
the conservative mp analyst trust
supporter alec shelbrook very good to
talk to you mr shelbrook we're not
looking at you at the moment because
we're staying on those pictures of your
new leader aboard her aircraft about to
depart for london and downing street and
tell me this so you've talked before
about just how
terrified voters are how terrified
consumers are about the challenges the
economic challenges facing them how
terrified are you about this new
government and this new prime minister's
ability to deal with them
oh good afternoon and i think that um
what you've seen um being said over the
recent hours and yesterday evening is
exactly why i've always been such a firm
supporter of liz trust because she never
ruled out um anything during the
leadership campaign there were comments
made but nothing was ruled out because
ultimately the prime minister is
somebody who looks at the policy looks
at the pragmatic solutions that need to
be taken and turner says this is the
best route forward and i think it's also
important to note that the prime
minister hasn't just been talking about
um how we help people with their bills
she's also been talking about supply
side reform energy security and that
storage facilities
yeah well a lot of that is long term
we're talking about immediately the here
and now the right now people this very
day and tomorrow and for weeks and
months to come who can't afford to put
enough food on their table who when
winter really hits hard can't afford to
heat their homes
yeah i mean certainly um when we await
the full details but certainly what
you're seeing is immediate action as she
said within the first week of um
becoming prime minister because as you
quite rightly um outlined i i said this
um back in may april in fact it was
stuff i was picking up on the doorstep
in the first part of this year that
people had genuine fear about how they
were going to pay their bills and since
then um obviously the price cap has gone
up to where it is today
obviously the previous government have
put in a lot of fiscal support which i
understand it's going to remain and so
what we're now saying is what the prime
minister appears to be saying is that
it's not going to get any worse um and
that there's going to be the step into
that and i think the important point of
this is is that when i was listening
just a moment ago to ian king i and the
markets i think the important point is
is that will allow people to plan their
finances far more strategically if you
take my situation i can pay my bills but
i'm doing that by taking money out of
the retail economy and i think that the
more we have to take out the retail
economy to pay our bills the more chance
of recession the more chance the job
losses the more chances of a lack of
income tax and taxation coming in and so
one way or another the government's
going to be faced with extra borrowing
that's a very very good point want to
concentrate now though on the internal
workings and the healing that has to
take place within your own party as we
look at that aircraft about to carry liz
trust the new prime minister back to
downing street we know that she's
already put in place
a lot of her cabinets a lot of those
positions already filled she's got a lot
more work to do though she goes down
through the ranks those ministerial and
junior ministerial roles does she have
to show in what she does there who she
appoints and where she appoints them
that she is addressing the whole party
because we know amongst umps that many
of your colleagues did not support liz
trust
but i think fundamentally the prime
minister support from day one came
across all wings of the party um i was
the first public backer of hers and and
the second public backer was deanna
davidson a good friend a good colleague
of mine but we are on different wings of
the party and if you look at the prime
minister's key supporters they came from
all wings of the party so this isn't so
much a conversation about sunac
supporters over trust supporters it's a
conversation about will she bring in all
aspects of the conservative which is a
wide coalition of the right to try and
ensure that the best jobs done for the
country but be under no illusion what
will drive the prime minister more than
anything else is can the minister desire
point deliver on the agenda we have to
deliver
that is the point that is the question
and uh we i wait to see the answer alex
shelbrook always good talking to you
thank you very much indeed as we
continue to concentrate on the aircraft
on the tarmac there waiting clearance to
take off in the merc not as murky as
those when it landed as james matthews
our correspondent there was telling us
aboard that plane prime minister liz
truss her husband and her entourage as i
say awaiting clearance to make their way
back to london and to downing street
where she's going to make her first
speech as prime minister our deputy
political editor sam coates is here with
me and uh sam talking about i talked to
alex shelbrook there about the process
we already know a lot of that has been
completed it hasn't been confirmed but
certainly in terms of her key
lieutenants her top team many of those
appointments in place
yes she'll be wanting to get her
government uh off the ground a little
bit faster than the jet that we're
looking at that's still on the tarmac um
i think that uh her plan is to try and
get most of the cabinet done today
because she had that two weeks at the
end of august where essentially she knew
she was gonna win allies of liz trust
tell me that she's got a pretty much
worked up plan for government and as a
result she's
going to be able to do more than some of
the incoming prime ministers that we've
seen in the last five or six years that
have of course been a few of them uh
she's going to be able to get those
appointments out of the door um
and so while the top names i think have
been in place really actually uh for
more than a week questing james
cleverley uh sawella breverman for the
uh treasury uh for the foreign secretary
job and uh for the home office uh i
think there's still just a little bit of
work going on down at the lower end of
the cabinet table the times reporting uh
there's a bit of a tussle over the
attorney general job uh at the moment uh
and and right down to the final
positions there to be filled uh i think
that's the conversate kind of
conversation that's going on at the
moment now alex shelbrook when you were
uh was talking to him was talking about
how liz trust comes from a sort of uh
has been trying to bring together a wide
breadth of support in her team and i
think she's actually done that
the question is whether or not actually
those people in the sunac team uh feels
sufficiently like she's reaching across
to them some of them worry that she's
being a little bit petty with the way
that she's going about some of these
appointments but
whilst i do hear some grumbling from
tory mps who back richie sudak who are
not willing to say so publicly but are
willing to say privately that they're uh
unhappy and a bit uh nervous about the
direction of travel it is a minority and
i would expect at this stage things uh
to be relatively calm within the
conservative
ranks i think that the kind of
conversations i was having uh at
lunchtime today with tory mps perhaps
you weren't natural bedfellows uh of l
it's just much more centered around
whether or not the administration that
she's going to run is going to be
as it were uh ready uh to
uh to deal with the massive challenges
uh that uh everyone is facing um and in
particular liz truss has already made
one big decision and you can see just
there uh the jet uh starting to taxi
along the runway of uh aberdeen airport
the big decision that she's made is a
bit of a a restructure inside of downing
street uh which kicks out quite a lot of
uh the civil servants quite a lot of the
older uh more experienced hands uh who
were advising boris johnson uh instead
she has uh opted to bring uh those
figures around her
that she's known for a long time that
are loyal to her many of them many of
them under 35
so quite young
quite um
with relatively little government
experience and they are the people that
are going to be in charge of delivering
for her at this point where she has so
many different challenges so the one
thing that we do know as she starts her
journey back to london her journey back
to westminster is that effectively uh
she's not going to have as much uh
support from people uh who are veterans
of those
of the complexities uh surrounding
pulling the levers of power that kind of
thing i think is the thing that's just
causing a tiny little twinge of doubt a
little bit of um a little bit of worry
amongst some uh tory mps but i think
that she's got a fair win behind her in
the parliamentary party judging by the
conversations i was uh having uh this
lunch time the tory party's never in
huge hue and cry at the point of a
reshuffle uh many tory mps still just
hoping that the phone call comes from
downing street uh even for a lower
ranked ministerial job over over over
the next 36 hours indeed and then as we
watch uh the plane starting to move if
this trust has a fair win behind her she
should be back in downing street on
schedule and uh we've just had a flurry
of rain here transferred itself
from balmoral and
if the reign persists we understand the
list trust will
make that speech inside number 10 if not
she'll be out here where we're standing
in front of that lecture and that a few
hours ago boris johnson made his final
speech as prime minister one question i
want to put you i mean there's so much
facing liz trusts sam and something
that's gone away but we know it will
come back the nhs that's a huge target
task it's had its winter crisis during
the summer the ambulance is piling up
the
waiting lists that millions upon
millions
on those and yet she's sticking the
the pledge she made during the hustings
was to take what 13 billion from the nhs
that national insurance rise
and put it into social care whoever gets
that job of health secretaries got quite
a task we expect that by the way to be
her very close friend uh therese coffey
who could well also uh acquire the title
deputy prime minister and i think by
having a deputy prime minister as health
secretary it shows that liz trust is
going to make the nhs a priority the nhs
i think it's fair to be said despite
those despite that apparent pledge
during the leadership campaign we didn't
hear a great deal about it over the six
seven eight weeks
of the uh of the contest but here's the
problem for the nhs and actually it's a
problem right across public services
which is although you can put more money
into the nhs and boris johnson did i
mean that's why he did the national
insurance rise that liz trust is gonna
uh is going to reverse and budgets have
nevertheless gone up even though uh
we're expecting liz trust to reverse
that national insurance rise even though
budgets have been going up for the last
few years inflation has been eating into
the ability the purchasing power of the
nhs so in effect
inflation at eight nine ten eleven
twelve percent possibly rising to twenty
two percent is going to have every bit
the same effect uh making it harder for
the nhs to do its job so we're going to
get very soon back to a call for the nhs
to have more money get more cash and you
pointed out what liz trust said uh
during a leadership contest which was
that actually some of the money
earmarked for the nhs to bring down
those waiting lists um will actually go
possibly a little bit quicker than
expected uh across to sort out the
social care system which she uh
identified as the problem with the nhs
um now
the thing about the nhs is that voters
have a personal relationship with it
they understand they can feel how well
the service is doing whether it's
treating them and their family and their
friends effectively or whether there are
problems and whether or not
that plan uh
survives contact with the very harsh
economic realities of the nhs as
currently constitutional is currently
funded and has it currently works well
that i think is going to be a very big
task because if liz trust is going to
prioritize growth
then she's not putting quite the same
store on
on things like public services labor
no doubt they will want to run the next
election campaign pointing out all of
the failings of the uh uh of the nhs
under a conservative government uh and
the squeeze on school budgets uh and
that and the problems that uh social
care uh is facing and on and on in
the challenges of public services and
it's that inflation that's the thing
that's making their budgets and that's
the point isn't it
even if the price cap is bought in and
it's held
that doesn't attack inflation that means
people's real wages are falling we're
seeing all this industrial action
already many in the public sector now
even nurses threatening to go on strike
there could be well maybe not quite a
winter of discontent ahead when it comes
to industrial action but some big big
problems there
there is a incredibly um uh
good strong following win for liz trust
amongst tory mps hoping it goes well but
there is no doubt that she is taking up
into potentially uh turbulent conditions
uh with all uh of the uh challenges with
inflation with industrial action public
sector pay and so much else that i think
will she will have there we go wheels up
at 14
39 uh we'll
time that flight back to london as it
disappears very quickly shows you excuse
me
just how low the cloud is and she comes
back to all those troubles
that's right uh and i think that uh
i i think liz truss uh will be glad to
uh now be uh on the way underway in her
journey back to london this will be the
moment where uh there are final final
preparations uh for uh for her speech
will be putting the final finishing
touches to the speech that we expect her
to make just in front of that big black
door uh in front of downing street uh in
pretty much an hour and a half uh i
think that she will be uh just keeping
abreast of some of the uh tussles going
on at the lower end of the cam a race uh
of people to stay inside her cabinet uh
and she'll also be across the energy
plans and it's worth pointing out this
massive energy plan which as eric
pickles was telling you earlier will
define her premiership um only put
together i think in the last two
or so weeks key details only decided in
the last week or so
and what that means is uh first of all
it's very different the kind of things
she was contemplating just four six
weeks ago i think we're getting a very
clear impression of liz trust as perhaps
a more flexible politician than some of
her rhetoric uh would imply but also
this is the thing that's going to define
her and it's done at breakneck speed so
she's got to get it right and that's
going to bring together um all the
expertise necessary from the treasury
from the business department uh experts
in in industry and those advising her at
the moment so uh
this will be the thing if she is as good
at detail as some of her allies like
james cleverley and simon clark claim
she is this is the thing that she's got
to get right so that families don't go
bust this winter and the markets
continue to have confidence in her and
her government okay sam well let's talk
more now then about families about the
effect of the cost of living crisis
right now on families and
how liz trusts intends to address that
my friend my colleague greg milam is in
warrington uh so-called red war
constituencies
and uh greg tell us some what the
expectations are there for liz
truss's leadership
yeah good afternoon from uh from
warrington we're in warrington's state
of the art new market actually i'm
looking at some of those uh big issues
that liz trust will face as prime
minister particularly uh here in the
north we've been talking already about
nhs and social care the the issues
facing businesses and the cost of living
of course but what about what the youth
and young people are expecting from this
uh new prime minister tom jowett is from
uh warrington youth zone um tom thanks
for talking to us first of all tell us a
bit about what you do because it's quite
striking just how much
need you've identified in the community
here yes so we offer a state-of-the-art
youth provision and so that's across a
seven night a week 365 days a year
where we look at breaking down the
barriers for young people in terms of
engagement so we offer 20 activities a
night as a standard minimum that's from
sports arts music recreation but then we
also look behind the scenes of that
looking at young people who suffer from
mental health illnesses and building up
emotional health and wellbeing support
for young people trying to break down
any barriers that young people have to
engage
within the youth zone or within society
and we really want to work with schools
with partners with the council to build
on those facilities you said to me you
opened a new centre in july and 5 000
people have signed up since since july i
mean that says a lot about the need
that's there yeah so we've had over 5100
members join after since july so the
need for young people to come to
facilities like ours is absolutely
critical now we're part of a bigger um
operation so we part one side which has
14
youth zones within the country they're
all around the north west
down in london up in carlisle so there's
over 50 000 young people that we engage
with every week
across all those facilities so it's
massive yeah i know liz trust visited
one of those sites or has visited one of
those sites young people generally don't
tune in to political races i guess but
what have you seen in in what we've
heard over the last few weeks
about
what what this new prime minister needs
to do for young people in this country
we just need to make young people a
priority at the end of the day they're
taking our jobs and they're going to
fulfill what i do now what you you're
doing so we need to put them at the top
of our list the end of the day we've
just had kovid we've just come out of
corvid where for two years they were
kind of held back from doing everyday
childhood things um whether you were
seven whether you're nine or even up to
fifteen sixteen they've had a really
difficult time so if we can support them
integrating back into
the communities build up them social
skills
and allow them to develop in whatever
aspect they want to develop in then
surely that's something that we we
should all be back in and all be
contributing towards because they're the
future um we're doing abbott now but
they're going to take over from us and
if we don't look after them
who knows what the future will hold yeah
we've heard a lot over the years about
the promises made to communities like
warrington
um traditionally labour that went
conservative last time or one of the
seats here what have you seen in terms
of young people in in warrington in a
traditionally northern town of the kind
of needs that exist at the moment young
people need us more more than ever um so
it's really important that we keep
providing those facilities we've just
had a holiday club for young people
through the summer
and we offer it's called a half project
so that's on the back of the marcus
rashford campaign
where we provide free holiday club care
as well as a free meal
that's all summer for four weeks four
days a week where they come to us and
we've had over 500 young people engage
with us within that program so the need
is real that's 500 young people who are
on free school meals who've needed our
access
every all through the summer
to make sure that they've got somewhere
to go something to do and that we're
giving them nutritious meals and that
they're getting involved in activities
so the need is is absolutely critical
and that's just a a drop in the ocean of
young people that we really want to
engage and reach and so yeah it's it's
real it's there it's something we need
to act on immediately thomas good work
thanks very much for talking to us
that's the view of the the youth
community as i say we're in the new
market here it opened uh
state-of-the-art market that opened in
2020 and is doing uh pretty good
business um and let's talk to a
businessman now uh this is the the delhi
which is one of those uh businesses that
made it work made its way in i think we
can
if we're allowed behind the counter yeah
gary we can talk to you um thanks for
talking to us a new prime minister what
are your hopes today
well they've got to sort the energy out
for us
one way or the other um i don't know how
she's going to do it but she needs to
get it done
why are they charging
extra on standard charge why the tight
electricity is going through the roof
when it doesn't need to because it's
attached to the gas you've got diesel
that's as cheap as anything but still
pain we're paying for the nose for the
four courts there's a lot of people
making money but it shouldn't be and
it's going to the rich again and i mean
they're super rich how is it hitting
your but it could give us an idea of
what's happening he's doubled my lucky
bill a month i'm paying
nearly 700 and 750 pound a month now i
was only paying 350.
um that has an impact and they've
already told us that in april luckily
we're capital then
we've we save
it's going to double so that's 1500
pounds i couldn't support that
and i know p lads that have got chip
shops and
high energy users they don't know what
they're going to do
we're hearing this week there's going to
be a promise of help there's going to be
there's going to be a freeze on those
things if if that comes if liz trusts
his first act as prime minister is to to
solve this problem what would you say to
him
thank you
but they need to look at our energy
supply we've got wind farms we'll know
where to store the energy because he got
rid of it the gas we used to have them
they stopped that everything's so
short-sighted
we need like i said why is there
electricity gone up we've got wind farms
we've built them they're there
it's only going round they're not
costing anything to run so
why are they charging us so much and
this is all we get is they're going to
reinvest in the
structure but how many times we heard
that when the prices have gone up
they need to be capping if you're built
if i was giving you an electricity bill
of 100 pounds i was making 10 pound fine
it's now jumped to 200
i'm making 20 pound now what was wrong
with making the 10 pound they're making
it easier for everyone they're still
making the money still planned for the
investment what more do you want
well we'll see what happens later in the
week gary thanks for talking to us
that's a view shared by many inside the
market here and of course now it is liz
truss's problem to solve
greg thank you very much indeed greg
mile i'm live there in warrington well
this trusts will arrive here this
afternoon we just saw her plane take off
from aberdeen so it won't be long facing
some of the most serious challenges that
a uk prime minister has seen outside
wartime and she's expected to draw up
plans to try to tackle the crisis
including of course a freeze on energy
bills that could cost something like a
hundred billion pounds maybe more than
that well joining me now to discuss this
more is the chief executive of the new
economics foundation the atta fanduela
very good to talk to you out of hanbulla
well it seems from what we're hearing
and have been hearing for a few days
we're now getting more details about it
when it comes to an energy cap price
freeze they're more or less going to
steal labor's clothes
i mean yes they are um and it's a big
intervention it's being briefed that
it's not just for six months as labour
proposed but it's potentially for 18
months which is a huge huge intervention
a very expensive intervention as well
and i think the question for me is who
pays with labour's
proposal was very clear that they were
going to turn to energy giants that had
been making excess profits in order to
tax them in order to pay for this at the
moment it seems like the proposal is
that we the consumer will be paying this
through bills that will be higher for
the next 20 years and that doesn't seem
fair when again there are profits that
can be capped in order to plug the hole
for this
you are of course i i understand me out
uh applying to me or have already been
accepted as a labor candidate for the
next election correct me if i'm wrong so
so just how much further would labor go
so i mean i think in terms of
labor they've got to sort of decide
where they want to take this they've
proposed a six-month cap which is where
the government is the idea that we are
trying to push at the new economics
foundation is to
um essentially
uh put in place free basic energy where
you say to people for the first slug of
energy you use everyone that's free and
then you pay more if you use more energy
and that does the job of protecting
people it ensures that everyone
basically has energy to afford the
basics it protects low-income households
that tend to use less energy
but it also incentivizes us to use less
energy and then you combine that with a
big natural effort to reduce the energy
we use by insulating our homes that for
me feels like a package which by the way
is a fraction of the cost of the price
reason the government's talking about
that would be something that we could
have in place for the next two three
years but potentially something that we
could have in place permanently
that's a very interesting point i mean
are there any countries where that
operates where you get your first slug
of energy free and then you pay more
depending on how much you use and is it
difficult to administer
so india has it um italy has a similar
version but with less subsidy um from
the stake there would be about a 14
billion pound stubbsy there but there
are countries that have this uh
particularly countries that are poorer
where essentially you're having to
insulate people um against the cost of
something that is an essential good but
for us we sort of compared this with the
idea of freezing energy bills for the
medium term we actually think it's a
more efficient proposal
that does the job of protecting people
which you absolutely must do guarantees
everyone access to energy to do the
basics because you don't want to have to
choose whether you heat your home or
feed your kids because you can't get
your cooker on but critically if you use
more energy it incentivizes you to get
your home insulated in order to reduce
the demand
but just um
let me go back to that point you made
about um being unable to feed your kids
and you know the part of the cost of
that is not just about the energy to
heat that food it's getting your hands
on the food in the first place and this
is where soaring inflation comes and it
goes way beyond a fuel cost crisis
inflation seems to be baked into the
system for the moment some economists
predicting it could hit 20 22 percent
later on is there anything that any
government can do about that
so i think in the short term we've got
to buckle down uh because inflation is
going to be tough and you've got to
protect people and for me you know there
is a piece around
a universal payment a cost of living
allowance if for example you were to
introduce a much tougher windfall tax on
energy producers we think you could
raise about 22 billion that would
essentially allow every household to
have 750 pounds to cover the wider cost
of living and so for me something like
that product provides short-term
protection
whilst we ride this period you know if
you do things on energy that will help
people and then you do things to kind of
deal with the wider cost of living
crisis that's been driven by the
aftermath of the pandemic it's been
driven by the fact that we've got
constraints around grain and that
hopefully provides protection for
families in the round
there are concerns though aren't there
about the scale of the borrowing that
this all might take because this is
open-ended no one knows how long energy
is going to continue to rise or even
stay at these levels and of course as we
just discussed where inflation is going
yeah so look this is a challenge and you
know my view is on this uh it seems that
the trust administration probably has it
right which is this is a major crisis it
is akin to the sort of crisis we had in
the pandemic or in 2008 or indeed a war
it is the sort of thing that if you
don't grip will be absolutely
catastrophic for families but critically
will completely [ __ ] our economy and
for me
staving that off in the long term will
be far more cost effective than saying
we can't do anything we won't borrow
we'll just let it happen so yes there
will be a big hit but you know interest
rates are still relatively low
particularly when you compare it to
where we've been over the last 20 30
years the cost of borrowing is still
relatively cheap so you do have headroom
in order to do that in order to protect
people in the short term and insulate
the economy in the long term but the
critical thing is whatever the
government does it can't just be about
short-term relief it's got to drive
long-term structural change so you know
if you freeze bills for the short term
in the energy market you've got to
combine it with energy efficiency you've
got to combine it with energy security
and getting to a world where more of the
energy we own
is actually produced and is done at
affordable levels rather than what we're
seeing at the moment where there is huge
huge profiteering off the back of an
essential utility okay miata fanbooler
thank you very much indeed uh we're
coming back to me live here on downing
street because uh one of the new cabinet
we expected just arriving in there prime
minister there's coffee
that was uh of course there's coffee as
you heard our very experienced shelter
i'll call him our deputy political
editor sam coates is sitting with me
therese coffee one of the key allies and
friends of list trusts widely tipped to
have a senior role in the cabinet
perhaps uh sam as as health secretary
that's right and
potentially as i was just asking therese
coffee no answer deputy prime minister
now they're both norfolk mps liz trust
and there's coffee they are firm friends
they have been uh
therese coffo at liz trusted side all
the way through this campaign it is that
for that reason that therese coffee has
gone into downing street before liz
trust even has returned her plane has
even landed uh from scotland uh therese
coffey who is perhaps perceived as being
from a slightly different wing of the
conservative party to liz trust
and was accompanying her uh on monday
after it was announced that she was
going to become prime minister uh in her
first visit to uh conservative
headquarters she is the person that liz
trust likes most to have at her side of
all of her colleagues so she will be
incredibly influential an important
figure uh she of course was a key
cabinet minister under boris waiting for
liz trust as she arrives here for the
first time as prime minister what tone
does liz trust have to strike in that
speech ambition
uh reassurance uh and a sense that she
knows exactly direction that she's gonna
take people in she wants to do a lot of
change she knows she doesn't have a long
time to get the tone right and the
substance right it's a hell of an a hell
of a task she's been working on it for
weeks uh this afternoon is her first
very big moment as prime minister okay
sam thank you very much indeed much more
from you and me to come sam coats a
deputy political editor you're watching
sky news live from downing street we're
staying right here much more from here
with prime minister liz trust now in the
air on her way back to london after she
was formally appointed prime minister by
her majesty the queen in balmoral much
more coverage to come
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
is sky news live from downing street